Hey, what's up, it's john from coding attic.
And welcome to react tutorial video, where
we're going to take a deep dive into awesome
world of react, we're going to start from
the very scratch. So think setup, install
on general concepts, and slowly but surely
move towards more interesting and more complex
react topics, like react hooks, context API,
and react router, just to name a few. So by
the end of this video, you're going to have
a good grasp on how to use react for your
next project. As a side note, I'm currently
working on additional react projects video,
where we'll put all of our tutorial knowledge
to good use by building bunch of cool apps
with react. If you'd like to see some of the
projects we're going to build, just head on
over to react hyphen, project dotnet, we'll
find that app and look for a video link in
description. And lastly, both videos are part
of my react course, where we build even more
cool and complex projects using react. And
if you're interested, you can check out the
course at John's milgard.com. Alright, and
welcome to the course. And we're going to
kick things off by quickly covering what in
the world is. And there's no better place
to start than the official docs for me, by
the way, are located at react js.org. Once
we navigate there, we are greeted by this
one profound sentence. React is a JavaScript
library for building user interfaces. That's
it My friends, not a PhD dissertation paper,
just a short, concise one sentence explanation,
while I'm a big fan are straight to the point
answers. And the first one, by far sums up
react the best. Let me elaborate a bit on
that. So react was developed at Facebook in
2011. And currently, it is by far the most
popular years you heard correctly the most
popular JavaScript library to build user interfaces.
As I know, some of react competitors are Angular
view, as well. If there's one thing that I
would want you to take away from this video,
is this one. When it comes to react, it's
all about components. You can think of components
as independent chunks of user interfaces.
components can be as small as one HTML element,
or you can be a rebel, and jam your entire
Facebook clone in one component. At the end
of the day, a lot of it depends on your needs
and wants. In reality, though, you probably
will avoid the one component route. Since
it's somewhat defeats the purpose of using
react in the first place. You see the benefit
of the component is that you can build a bunch
of independent, isolated, and most importantly,
reusable user interfaces that you can run
piece it together, just like Lego blocks.
And as a result, build even super complex
apps without going insane. While your app
can have as many components as you'd like,
it will always always have at least one called
root component. We already glossed over it
a bit. But just to reiterate the major benefits
of using components and essentially, react,
develop your next app or phone, you can build
independent pieces of user interfaces, meaning
changing logic, or layout in one combined
will not break your OLAP once component is
ready to go, you can reuse it all throughout
Europe. But component code is still stored
in one place. So if you ever need to make
some changes, you don't have to run around
like a headless chicken, simply locate the
component, apply the changes, and all the
instances will be automatically updated. And
of course, let's also not forget about speed.
You see behind the scenes react is using something
called Virtual DOM, where only the component
that needs to be updated, is affected. And
what's really cool, it's done without re rendering
the whole app, which in turn, of course, increases
the speed of your final product. And as a
result, the user experience as well. Before
I let you go, I also want to show you somewhat
typical example that everyone uses to show
react components in action. And that is no
other than our beloved Twitter. So as we're
looking at the screen, and by the way, I can
see you getting distracted by my content we
focus people focus we We are here to learn.
Where was I? Oh, yes, the components. Let's
take a look at the sidebar. And as I'm working
on it, I can see a bunch of words. Or you
probably notice that each link is pretty much
the same structure, where there's some kind
of icon as well as a text. So essentially,
what we could do is set this up as one component.
And what that means is, we'll just set up
a structure, and everywhere where we would
want to use it, we will just need to pass
in the data. And by data, of course, I mean,
the specific icon, parent is going to be render.
And then of course, the text.
As a result, what that also means that I can
reuse that component, all throughout my application,
however, I would like. But if I would want
to make some changes, for example, if I would
want to add something here, I can just change
it in one place, and then all the instances
will be automatically updated. So that would
be a lynx example. And you can probably already
guess, the same, for example, would work with
a post. Because when we're looking at the
post, what do we have, we have some kind of
picture, we have the name, of course, we have
the text, we have all the retweet options,
as well as likes the comments, but the only
thing that is changing is the data. So the
person who is posting and how many likes,
that sort of thing. So the point that I'm
trying to make is that as you're looking at
the application, you can see a bunch of places
where we can set up a react component, and
use all the awesome benefits the components
provide. Before we go any further, let's also
cover the main goals of the course. And I
honestly there's only one or the other, the
course out wants you to be comfortable with
react. Now what that means to me is that you
can do two things. First, you are aware of
external resources. And more importantly,
you're comfortable with using them. When you'd
want to learn something new about react. Essentially,
you know where to find useful info. And second,
you are comfortable applying theory to practice
by building your own project using react.
Now goals are nice. But what is my plan to
get your answers simple. By building bunch
of projects using react? You see the course
goal is not to cover every smallest aspect
of react ecosystem. Since it's impossible.
A course that covers everything that there
is to know about react doesn't exist. While
the core API of react is actually quite small.
Since it is by far the most popular framework
out there, the ecosystem surrounding react
is as vast as you can imagine. What that means
is that essentially, there will be always
something new to learn about react.
That's why I would suggest adopting a student
mindset instead, where you're always open
to expanding your react knowledge. In my experience,
the best way to learn and get comfortable
with language or framework is by building
a bunch of projects. So that's exactly what
we'll do during this course, we'll start small,
our first project will be somewhat silly,
but slowly and surely, we will expand on our
knowledge. And by the end of the course, you
will be comfortable building your own complex
react apps, far as the core structure, we're
going to start by setting up our dev environment.
So think text error browser, or basic terminal
commands, and etc. Followed by extensive react
tutorial, during which we will build already
some small project to enforce that particular
subject matter that we're learning. And once
we're done with the dorial, we'll simply put
our heads down, roll up our sleeves and build
a react project. like there's no tomorrow.
How does that not the very end of the course.
We'll also cover Redux and why it is used
when I'm fully aware that the first part the
setup part might seem tedious, boring, and
maybe even unnecessary. Please keep in mind
that it is extremely important for me that
all of us are on the same page. And don't
worry, we'll get to react in when it comes
to course requirements. It would be extremely
beneficial. If you would be familiar with
HTML, CSS, and most importantly, JavaScript.
I can honestly say that the more JavaScript,
especially iOS six, you know, the easier is
going to be pick up react. Because at the
end of the day, React is just JavaScript.
So if you're familiar with things like spread
operator are all functions, destructuring,
etc, you'll be in good shape. Now, it's not
the end of the world if you're still getting
comfortable with JavaScript. Just keep in
mind that once in a while, you will have to
do some extra studying, since it is my assumption
that you are familiar with JavaScript topics.
And while I will try to cover as much JavaScript
info as possible, please understand that at
the end of the day, this is a react course.
Now, if you need to brush up on your JavaScript
knowledge, or if you'd like to find out more
about specific JavaScript topic during the
course, I would suggest utilizing my YouTube
channel, coding ionic, more specifically playlist
called JavaScript nuggets,
where we cover react specific JavaScript topics,
I'm constantly adding new topics. So while
at the time of recording, there are only three
videos, by the time you'll be watching this,
there will be more. So again, the channel
that you're looking for is coding out. And
more specifically, the playlist name is a
JavaScript nuggets. So the way it works, as
I'm recording the course. And once I hit a
specific job topic, or example map, or unique
values, or dynamic object keys, I will create
a separate video about that, just in case
you'd want to find out more about the topic.
When it comes to our dev environment, we will
need the following tools. No GS installed
on our machine web browser, I would suggest
Google Chrome. But technically it is optional.
As long as you have a web browser, you'll
be good to go. Just remember that once in
a while, your results might differ. Because
the browser that you choose if it's different
browser other than Google Chrome, maybe I
don't know displays CSS a little bit differently
than a text editor. Again, I would suggest
Visual Studio code, but we all have our preferences.
So no hard feelings, as well as react developer
tools which are not required, but will improve
your dev experience in the long run. And I
guess, let's go down the list. And first one,
we have a node. Now in order to check whether
you have node installed already on your machine,
you know, thermal, you need to run a node,
and then dash dash version. So you'll see
where in order is installed. And if it's successful,
it will also tell you what is the version.
And then if you don't have it installed, then
it's probably gonna say something along the
lines that he cannot find the command or something
like that. Where you're shooting for is at
least 5.2. or later, we will use a package
called create react app. And more specifically,
we'll use NPM. install it. And that comes
with a version of 5.2 minimum. Of course,
if you have a higher version, that is even
better. So in order to test that out, I'll
navigate right now to my terminal on massively
zoom in just so you can see what is happening.
We type here node dash dash version. So of
course, it's bits back then I have version
12. Okay, so I'm good to go. Now, if you don't
have node installed, I would suggest navigating
to node j s.org. And of course, you can just
get there by going to Google and typing node.
For example. Here you can say node and of
course, the first link that's going to move
up is going to be node js.org. And they will
right away detect which operating system you're
using. So in my case, that is Mac, and then
I would shoot for long term support option.
So click it over here. And you'll get yourself
now Now I'm not going to install it since
I already have it on my machine. And also
is just clicking bunch of checkboxes. Then
we have Google Chrome. So again, if you don't
go for Google Chrome, I'm on one of the first
links is going to be to a page where of course
you can download chrome when we have Visual
Studio code. Same deal. Just look for Visual
Studio code is a awesome open source text
editor from Microsoft. That is just amazing
as far as the development experience, once
you go to their site which is called Visual
Studio Yo yo.com, again, they will detect
which operating system you're using, and you
can right away, get yourself a nice fresh
out of the oven copy of the Visual Studio
code, then we've got a react developer tools,
then just look for them, one of the links
is going to be right away to the extensions.
And then of course, in my case, I already
have it. So I would need to remove it. But
in your case, if you don't have it installed,
then of course, you'll have Add to Chrome.
So you add an extension. And what you're looking
for are the components and the profiler. Keep
in mind that of course, if for example, you
are at the page that doesn't use react, and
of course, it's just gonna be gray, what I'm
talking about this little icon, notice this
react developer tools, when essentially it's
going to be gray. However, if the site is
using react, and of course, you will be able
to see it. And then once you open up the console,
so of course, you can either do it with a
shortcut, which I believe was option command,
and I, and there it is. And what you're looking
for is this profiler, and components. Again,
I'm not going to look at them right now, because
it's not gonna make sense. But eventually,
as we're progressing with the course, you
will see how react developer tools will make
your life a little bit easier. As far as working
with a react application. As far as my specific
text on our setup, meaning what extensions
I'm using, which ones I would suggest using
during the course as well, as well as my settings
JSON. I'm not going to cover them too much
in this video, because essentially, I don't
see the point. Once we start building the
React application, then one by one or I'll
set up a separate video, where essentially,
I'll show you all the expenses that I would
suggest getting, and also what settings, we
would need to set up in our Visual Studio
code in a text editor. Now, if you are impatient,
and if you'd want to see all the extensions
that I'm using, as well as my settings, you
can just navigate to my GitHub handle is john
hyphen smelter on the report in the journal
report is VS code setup. And here you'll find
all the extensions that I'm using, as well
as small description, and also my settings
JSON. Now again, let me reiterate a little
bit later in the course, I will cover which
extensions are crucial for you to follow along,
meaning which will make your life much easier
as you're working with react, and also what
settings you need to set up in your settings
JSON. But if you'd want to see them right
now, everything that I'm using, even though
some extensions are not required for discourse,
then again, navigate to a repo, which is john
hyphen, smil. And then VS code setup. on here,
you'll find my settings JSON, as well as all
the extensions that I currently have in my
Visual Studio code. Hopefully, everyone was
successful setting up the dev environment.
And now we can move on to the next phase of
our setup. Normally, this would be the point
where we download and examine create react
to horror, there's something that I would
like to cover first, and that is no other
than the scary terminal, some of its most
popular and used commands. You see, even though
this is a react course, we will use command
line on NPM during the course we might as
well get some basics out of the way. Now if
you're already comfortable with terminal and
NPM which by the way we'll cover in next video.
Feel free to skip these videos. If however,
you are seeing the scary terminal for the
first time. Hopefully you will not feel that
way after watching this video. Please keep
in mind though, we will just cover the basics.
So if you'd like to learn more, I would suggest
utilizing endless YouTube videos and medium
blog posts about command line and its commands.
First question coming out of your mouth is
probably along the lines oil waters terminal.
Why would want to use it for your sake. If
you're watching this course it is safe to
assume that you have successfully tackled
the graphical interface or at least the basics.
The Goj what is going well it is this Notice
the icons were confined more commands along
those lines. Now what are we can also do is
control our computer, not just using the GUI,
the graphical interface, but also the command
line. And that's where the terminal comes
down. I fully understand that the first time
seeing this is scary, don't worry, it is not
as bad as it looked like. The first command
that I want to look at is B WD, which will
show us a full path name to a current directory.
So where are we at as far as our machine in
the terminal, so we're just type B, WD. And
I can tell you right away that we will be
in the road. By the way, you can notice this
by this little symbol. Okay, so now, where's
my road, it is Ford slash users. And then
Ford slash my last name. So that is my root
directory. Now, if I want to see what directories
I have in a folder, well, I just go by LS,
and this is gonna spit back what directories
I have, in my root directory, multiple my
point, I'm going to navigate to my hard drive,
man, I'm looking for two users. And I'm looking
for my last name. And there it is. And now
you can clearly see that I'm not making this
up. I'm in the road, right now in the Finder,
as well, in my command line. Now, if I would
want to navigate to a specific folder, we
would need to type cd, and then whatever folder
name. So in this case, if I would want to
navigate to a desktop, or just need to write
this top knot, now, of course we navigate
to understand. And I can clearly see that
here as well. Now, if I would want to navigate
one level up, basically back to a parent,
I would need to go to CD, and then dot dot.
Now of course, you can again, see that I'm
sitting in the room. So if we want to navigate
back to the desktop, again, we will type cd
desktop, or also remember that we have option
of using arrow key up or down where we can
look for previous commands. So if I'll just
press the arrow key up, notice this will give
me the last command, which of course, is navigating
back to the parent. However, if I press it
one more time, this will spit back the CD
desktop. So of course, I can run the command
again, by pressing return. And of course,
I'm in a desktop. Now, once I'm in the desktop,
if I run LS, you'll notice that technically,
it doesn't return anything because of course,
my desktop is empty. However, there's going
to be may be some cases once in a while, where
you would want to also check for hidden folders.
Most likely in our course that is going to
have to do with Git. And in that case, you
can run with LS,
iPhone and a. So this will also show you hidden
folders. Now that is a little bit out of the
scope of the course. So don't worry about
it too much. We're not going to use it that
often. But once in a while, you maybe would
want to just double check whether there is
a gift as far as your folder structure. Now,
once that is done, why don't we create a new
directory. And to do that we would need to
run MK the RTR. so here we can clear the console.
And by the way, for that we have command of
clear, so we can clear the console. And now
in the desktop, I'm going to make a new directory.
And I'm just going to call this testing. So
I'm going to go with MK dir testing murders.
Now of course, I have my testing folder. Now
in order to navigate to that directory, again,
either I would need to run CD and man purse
thing. Or there's also another option where
I can just type cd event space, and just grab
this particular folder. So just drag and drop
over here. And now notice how it right away
tells me that I would navigate to users than
smellier than desktop testing. So once I press
over here, notice how I'm nicely sitting in
the testing folder. And what else we have.
We have city CD now that so that's going to
navigate again to a parent and clear in the
console which already we have covered. So
now let's set out how we can navigate outside
of course again, where we go with CD, Amanda
again, we're sitting in desktop. So those
would be the basic commands on the terminal.
And hopefully you don't feel as scared as
you did in the beginning of the video, when
we install Node, we also automatically install
NPM or node package manager. The reason why
it's so useful is because NPM allows us to
save time, automate our tasks and avoid reinventing
the wheel. We do that by installing packages,
or dependencies. packages can be as simple
as utility functions, and as complex as full
blown frameworks. And everything else. Of
course, in between, keep in mind that the
package we are going to use later, the Create
react app already does all the heavy lifting
for us under the hood. So this video is just
to give you a general overview. And for the
most part, you'll be just hitting NPM start
on a keyboard for the remainder of the course,
a command that will cover a bit later in the
course, as far as general NPM commands, we
have NPM minute, where is going to create
package JSON. So essentially, the manifest
file for our project, we're also will see
a list of dependencies, then we can install
package by running NPM, install a non package
name, and then we would need to run the dash
step. Now as far as does their save in the
latest versions of node, you already don't
have to run that meaning this would just save
it to a list of dependencies. Or like I said,
in the latest versions of node, you don't
have to do that anymore. Now what I've noticed,
though, that once in a while students ask
the question, and they share the project.
And then I can see that they have been using
older version, and they have not been saving
dependency. So in order for me to run their
project, I still need to install those dependencies.
So as a safeguard, I would suggest always
using bash, bash, bash, save, just in case,
I don't know, maybe your node version is out
of date. Now that is going to install that
package locally. Meaning in the project runner,
we also have the npm install, package name,
dash global. Now that is going to install
the package globally. And we can act anywhere,
or it comes with a gotcha where when you're
doing the global install, most likely you'll
be asked for permission. And of course, don't
worry, I'll show you that with our example.
And lastly, we also have an option of installing
package only while we're developing the flag
would be nice dash, save and then dash F.
Now what would be the most common one, I don't
know, maybe testing. So essentially, we only
need that package while we're developing,
then of course, we're just using it. And then
once we ship to production, we don't need
that package anymore. So remember that testing
folder that we created. So now let's try some
things out. What I'm going to do is first
course zoom in, in my terminal. And then of
course, I would want to navigate there. So
I think the fastest way will be just drag
and drop. Now, of course, I'm in my testing.
And remember, first would want to create that
manifest Well, again, something that create
react app package we're going to use does
already for us. So this is just to showcase
the general setup. And in order to get our
manifest file, we'll just run NPM in it. Now,
there's a bunch of questions there. So if
you would want to meet that you can just go
with dash y, or in my case, I'm going to go
with NPM in it and create a question. So in
this case, what would be the package name,
I'm going to call this app version. And as
you can see, I can skip them if I want to,
since again, this is just to showcase how
it's gonna look like. I'm just gonna skip
them by pressing Enter. And this shows what
I'm going to currently have in the package
JSON. So of course, I'm going to say yeah,
that that looks okay. So so yes. And now if
I check out my testing, I'll have the package
JSON.
So let me open my text editor here. I'll just
drag and drop testing, just so you can see
that of course, I have my package JSON. And
there it is. So apt nine version description,
what is going to be the entrance file, so
the main file, and I'm just curious, it is
index JS that is by default, of course, we
don't have the index js. And then we have
scripts and author. Now scripts is an interesting
one because with create react app, like I
was saying, the script that you'll use most
is going to be NPM start. So essentially,
these are just commands that you can run Now
let me showcase how we would install a package.
And we can do it directly from the text editor,
or we can do it from the terminal, please
keep in mind that as long as we're sitting
in the same folder, it doesn't matter. And
that's one of the reasons why I like Visual
Studio code. It comes, it comes with integrated
terminal. Now how we can access integrated
terminal in Visual Studio code, we go with
control until then, and notice here all the
way in the bottom, I have the terminal. And
what's really cool to notice out right away,
gonna be in the folder. So it's not like our
specifically need to navigate there, just
like I would do in the terminal. In this case,
when I'm opening up the integrated terminal,
from the Visual Studio code, I'm right away
at my project. So I'm in the first thing.
Now, of course, I would want to install first
dependency. And I'll just randomly install
bootstrap. So we'll go with NPM, install,
and then whatever is the package name, so
I know that it is bootstrap. And then like
I said, just in case, I'll run dash dash save.
And what you'll notice is that of course,
we're installing dependencies. And the moment
I do it, notice here how I have early property.
and the value right now is bootstrap. So now
I installed this dependency. And of course,
I can use it locally. Now what you'll notice
is that we have node modules, this is going
to be a folder, where we'll have a list of
our dependencies. Now at the moment we have
bootstrap. But then again, once we start using
create react app, you will see that of course,
since it is a bigger package, it uses more
and more dependencies. So our node modules
folder is going to be way bigger. Now, as
a side note, when you're sharing this, for
example, when you're adding this to a GitHub,
your folder, you usually just add package
JSON. So essentially, you wouldn't share no
modules, because usually, that is a massive,
massive folder. So much more easier way is
just adding everything forget, but not the
node modules. So essentially just a package
JSON. And then once you clone or fork, or
download the folder, what you can do is just
run npm install, which installs all dependencies.
Don't Don't worry, of course, we'll cover
that a little bit later in the course, because
there are some projects that are already set
up for you. So the only thing you will need
to do is just follow the link to the repo,
get it. And then once you get the link, meaning
once you clone or fork or download, then you
just need to run npm install. So this would
be for the local package. Essentially, once
I've installed bootstrap, now I can start
using it. However, remember, I also said that
we can use global packages correct. Now, I
can install global package from the integrated
terminal. Or I can do it again from the terminal,
that's up to you. The difference is that if
you install package globally, you can use
it anywhere in your machine, meaning you can
use it on the desktop, you can use it in the
project, or whatever. Now again, the gotcha
with a global install is that it is going
to be asking for permissions. So in this case,
you know what I'm going to go to terminal
just to showcase that, for example, I would
be installing a Gatsby CLR. From the remember,
this was a root folder, and the name was npm
install. And then I go with Gatsby CLR. And
then I need to go with dash G. Again, you
don't need to run this command. This is just
to showcase that if you won't have permissions,
which at the moment I don't, since I'm not
running sudo, then of course, I'm going to
get a big fat. And there it is, of course,
like I was saying we get a bunch of errors.
So again, in order to omit that, we would
need to add sudo. So I could go back to my
previous command. And I would just add sudo
here. And then once you're on of course it's
going to ask for your password. So you would
need to add your password. And then once you
do course you just press enter, and then the
install is going to be successful. So that's
the general overview of NPM. How we would
install locally and how we're set up globally.
Again, when it comes to create react app,
it does all the heavy lifting already for
us under the hood. So the only thing we'll
really need to care about is just checking
out the scripts. So essentially the script
commands that we have. So now we will know
how to set up the dev server and also wants
to know While Of course, we will install some
package locally to our project, whether that
is bootstrap whether that is react icons or
something along those lines. There are many
ways how to set up react application. By far
the easiest and fastest would be using create
react app, which is built by Facebook developers.
And it allows us to just focus on building
our apps, instead of spending our precious
time on tinkering or a configuration and build
those. If you're interested in finding out
more about the package, just type the name
in search engine, and look for the link in
the repo. I would like to re emphasize though,
technically, you don't need to use create
react app to work with react, you can build
the whole setup yourself. But trust me when
I say that, in the long run, create react
app will save you a bunch of time, as well
as some sanity. Because while tinkering with
Webpack sounds a lot of fun in the beginning.
In reality, it can get nutty, pretty, pretty
fast. Under the hood, create react app uses
Babel, and Webpack. And while we're still
on a subject, let me just quickly cover them
as well. So a Babel is a JavaScript transpiler
that converts the newest JavaScript into the
good old JavaScript. So we're going to use
all the newest features of the JavaScript
language. So think things like print operator,
destructuring, and all the other goodies that
come with air six. on behind the scenes, Babel
will turn into ears five, which in turn, will
make sure that our app runs smoothly in the
older browsers as well. So essentially, we
can have our cake and eat it too. Well, web
pack does a lot of other things as well. Essentially
Webpack works as a module bundler, the main
features of Webpack would be bundling our
resources, watching for changes, running Babel
transpiler. In order to bootstrap a fresh
instance of react app, they suggest using
an bx. So essentially, we won't need to install
their COI tool on our machine, which is a
setup they had before. And as a side note,
that's why our NPM version needs to be at
least five point to change we do want to use
and be thorough, while we're still on subject,
their previous setup was that we had to install
the COI to the Create react app global are
now they switch to NPM. And they're also suggesting
that if you have already installed the Create
react globally, so for example, maybe you
were watching some other tutorial and you
already installed create react app globally,
very suggest that you are installed. So you
need to run this command the npm install g
create react app to uninstall the CLR. Because
that way, it ensures that NPM uses always
the latest version. Now I already did that.
So I'm good to go. We're only looking for
this command. Now you can grab the whole thing.
That just means that your app will be called
my app. In my case, I'll just copy and PX
create react app. So I'm going to navigate
back. And by the way, if you want to check
what is your NPM version, same as with node,
we just run NPM and there's dash version.
And of course, I can see that I have six point
12. Now at this point, I would want to navigate
to a desktop, make sure you copy and paste
my command. And once I have command in place,
I just need to come up with a name of my folder,
and markers. I'm going to go with the tutorial.
And you'll see how the Create react app starts
bootstrapping your react application. Now
it does take a little bit of time. So I will
stop the video. And I'll resume it once all
the dependencies are in place. And once create
react app is done, installing dependencies
and essentially setting up a ready to go react
application. We can see in the terminal. There
we have quite a few commands that we can use.
Now again, as we're progressing with tutorial,
don't worry, we will cover other ones as well.
But for the time being. The one that we really
need is the NPM start, which starts the development
server now Let me tell you right away, that
there are two places where you can run the
commands. So essentially, start up the dev
server, or build the production ready application,
or, for example, install the dependency and
an extra dependency, for example, React icon.
And these two places are following where I
can run all my commands. In a terminal. However,
I just need to make sure that of course, I'm
located in my folder. So for example, in this
case, I would need to navigate to tutorial.
And then I can run, for example command of
MPM start, the other place is going to be
our text error. Now, I'm going to run my commands
in text editor in the integrated terminal.
The reason why I'm showing RBIs is once in
a while, some students who use Windows have
complained that unfortunately, when they run
their commands in the integrated terminal
in Visual Studio code, they're getting some
issues. So just keep in mind, you don't have
to run your commands in integrated terminal.
Now, of course, I will do that throughout
the course, because I'm not having any issues.
Once I do that. However, if you do, just remember
that you can always set them up in your terminal
as well. So in my case, I'm going to drag
and drop my application. And then I'll right
away, set up side by side a browser, because
of that, just how I prefer while I'm developing.
So this is going to be a fresh instance of
the browser. And this is going to be our project.
Now, don't worry, in the next video, we'll
take a closer look on what is our folder structure,
what essentially we can find in the fresh
instance of create react app. However, for
now, I would just want to spin up my bear
server. So like I said, I will open up the
integrated terminal with Ctrl tilde. And then
we run NPM.
start and run localhost 3000, we're going
to get a brand new instance of our application,
essentially, we'll see what create react app
created for us. Now, you see that we have
some logo, we have some text. And like I said,
In the next video, we'll take a closer look
at the folder structure. But for the time
being, I would just want to showcase that
the way that their server works is each and
every time we'll make some change, if there
is no error will automatically get the latest
version of our app right away in the browser.
So for example, if I change the text in the
app, and again, you don't have to do that.
But I'll change the text from the paragraph
to a Hello World. So whatever I have over
here, I'll just change to hello world. And
you'll see the moment I save i right away,
get the latest version of my app in a browser.
So create react app does this cool thing of
hot reloading, where essentially every time
we'll make some changes, unless we have some
bugs, meaning some errors than it right away,
restarts the application for us. And before
we go any further, let me just give you a
brief overview of the folder structure in
create react app. And I must warn you that
throughout the video out probably you men
zoom out quite a few times. So up on the top,
we have a node modules. Of course, this is
where we have all our dependencies. So if
you remember previously, when we installed
bootstrap, we essentially had only one folder.
Now, of course, since the dependencies that
our project has have their own dependencies,
while our node modules folder, of course is
way, way bigger. And of course, this is why
when we'll be setting up our source control,
we will ignore this folder. Now before we
go any further, I just want to show you a
cool thing, how the package JSON works together
with node modules. Please keep in mind that
is not unique to create react app. But I think
it's going to be a very useful info. So for
example, if I navigate to package JSON, we
already know that of course, this is going
to be our manifest file. And in here, as you
can see, these are the dependencies that we
are using in our project. And then of course,
in order to start up our application, we will
need to run NPM start. Now what if I delete
the node modules? What if I say you know what,
I don't need this particular folder. Okay,
I've deleted now in order to stop the dev
server And what you're looking for is control.
And see, that is going to stop the desert.
Now, of course, once I refresh, notice, I'm
going to get a big factor. Now I'll try to
run NPM start. But of course, I should get
a error. Why? Well, because I don't have my
dependencies anymore. So if I run NPM, start,
I will, of course, get my big fat error. Now,
do you think everything is lost? And of course,
the answer is no more we would need to do
is run npm install your list, of course, we'll
just check that in the package JSON, we have
a list of our dependencies, and it will just
install for us. And the moment we run npm
install, this will install all our dependencies.
And again, we're good to go. And this is exactly
what I was saying in previous videos, where
once we get our project from the GitHub, whether
we clone it, whether we fork it, whether we
are downloading, well, of course, we just
need to run npm install, because list of our
dependencies are going to be there. So that's
why of course, we don't need to share our
project, meaning we don't need to share the
massive node modules folder. So in this case,
what we can do is just run NPM start, and
everything will run exactly like we expect.
Because of course, now of course, we installed
all our dependencies back. Now after that,
we have the public folder, where we'll find
index HTML. Now, this is the index HTML file
that is displayed over here. So I can tell
right away that all of our work will do in
a source. But there are some few useful things
that we can do in the index. html, for example,
we could change the title correct. So at the
moment, I have react app, but I could go with
react tutorial, and don't be scared of this
file is just like a regular HTML file that
we have worked already before. And if you're
looking at the syntax, it also resembles everything
that we have seen already in the HTML files.
Now what other useful things that we can do
in the index HTML? Well, we could add Google
fonts, because like I just said, The syntax
would be exactly the same, like we have been
using already in the indexes journal, or the
font, awesome icons, or things of that nature.
And then, more importantly, we have all here,
this div with an ID of a rope. And I know
it sounds mind boggling at the moment. But
this is where our whole JavaScript application
eventually is going to live. I know sounds
really mind boggling at the moment. But don't
worry, of course, I will swing back to the
road more. And we cover some basics of the
React setup. So that is going to be index
HTML in our public, then we have a folder
that we currently don't see. And that is the
build one. Remember, in the package JSON,
we have the command of start. So that, of
course, starts the dev servers. Now let me
stop it. We also have a built unless command
essentially sets up a production already built
with mirror on it. And then of course, I'll
show you. So NPM, run build, shall we run
this command. And then of course, we will
see the build folder as well. Now it's going
to be very hard to tell anything in that folder,
meaning if I'll open up index HTML, you'll
notice that everything has been nicely minified.
And essentially, what you can do with this
folder is just static assets. So for example,
on nullify, you can just use for drag and
drop option. natla. Phi is, of course, the
hosting provider that we will use throughout
this tutorial. But of course, you can do it
in any other place where you can just grab
the static assets, that should do it for the
build folder. Up next we have the source folder,
where we will do most of our work. And that's
why we won't cover it in detail in this video.
As far as the files, we have the app CSS,
where eventually there's going to be a CSS
for our application. We have app j s, where
eventually all our components will meet. However,
keep in mind that the name is optional. You
can call this shake and break it doesn't really
matter is just the convention is to call this
app j s. And we have the file for testing
which we don't care about. We have index CSS,
and of course in here again, we have more
CSS. For our application, we have index j
s where we will start working starting from
The next video, although technically in the
next video, we will just wipe out all the
boilerplate. So I guess more properly would
be say in the video after that, we'll start
working in the index js. And even though there
are a lot of things already here, most importantly,
what I would want you to notice is that we
are targeting that route there. Remember,
I showed you in the index HTML, I said that,
of course, this is where all our application
is going to live. So essentially, we have
index j s, we're importing the app, show app,
of course, he is going to be a file where
all our components eventually will meet. And
we'll place our app in the root in the dev
with an ID of root. That's why I said that,
even though it looks a little bit mind boggling.
Put all our application will live in that
one div with an ID, of course, then we have
a logo, self explanatory, that is the logo
that we see right now. And then of course,
the service worker, as well as setup test,
which we won't cover in this particular course,
while we're still on a subject we have get
ignored. And like I said, this is a file that
just specifies which files will be ignored
by our source control. And of course, up on
the top, you can see the node modules, which
like I mentioned previously, will be ignored,
because there's no point of adding them as
well as the build. So build will also be ignored.
Because either you'll do your own drag and
drop. That's one of the options that you can
do as far as your production build. Or you'll
use some kind of continuous deployment, where
essentially the provider, the hosting provider,
does the build process for you. And then of
course, at the end, like I said, there's a
package JSON, where we have the manifest of
our project. Most importantly, we care about
the dependencies, as well as the commands
that we can run, start on build, all the way
at the bottom, we have README, which is a
markdown file that just contains information
about our project. That should do it for the
folder structure. next video, we'll clean
up some of the boilerplate. And then finally,
we'll start working on our first react
component. Well create react app is a awesome
tool. One of the issues that I have, especially
as we just start exploring the React world,
is the fact that there's bunch of worldport
since in my opinion, it will help us the most,
it will start everything from scratch, I would
want to do something barbaric, and modest
and delete pretty much all the files in the
source, apart from index js. So I would want
you to select app CSS, j s, also the app does
j s, the index, CSS logo, SVG, ServiceWorker,
and setup test. So pretty much all the files
apart from index j. s, I would want you to
delete them. Yes, we would want to remove
all these files. So at the moment, we just
have the index js, index j s, I also would
want to wipe it clean. So just delete all
the comments that we currently have in the
index j s. Now, of course, when you run NPM,
start, don't be surprised that there will
be a big fat error. Don't worry, once we create
our first component, then of course, this
error will be fixed. But for the time being,
we just want to remove all this unnecessary
boilerplate that we have in a source folder.
So that should be a start, where we have a
clean screen. And now of course, we can create
our first react component. Awesome. Once we
have removed all the boilerplate, let's kick
things into gear and start our react land
adventure. And the first thing I want to do
is to create our first component. Normally,
in order to do that, we will need only two
things a import from react dependency and
a function. Or keep in mind that since index
js is our JavaScript entry point, will need
to add some additional code. But normally,
it's just react as a function.
So let's start working on that. Now I'll toggle
my sidebar just to have a little bit more
real estate. And I'm doing that we'll use
a command of command and B. Notice here now
I'm toggling the sidebar in Visual Studio
code. And like I said, we would need to import
react from our react dependency. Now please
keep in mind About the code that I'm writing,
and I'm starting with the import, and I'm
looking for react and learn from react. So
this code is not react specific. Essentially,
this is something called year six modules,
where essentially, we can get piece of functionality
into our file. And if you have been taking
my adjust, of course, of course, you're already
familiar. However, if you haven't, don't worry.
Later in the course, we'll spend an entire
video on taking a look at the syntax and what
will be the purpose of using e6 modules. Just
keep in mind, this is just JavaScript, this
is nothing specific to react. Now, since react
is our main dependency for a project, I don't
need to go with a specific path. But later,
you'll see that when we're setting up our
own files, you'll have to specifically say,
well, which file are you looking for? Again,
we don't have our files. So normally, if it's
just a dependency virus for the whole project,
meaning it is in the node modules, then you
simply go with whatever is the name, so I'm
importing react from react. And now I would
want to set up my function, because I would
want to create my component. Now, there is
a gotcha, meaning, I can create whatever function
I want, whether it is a URL function, or whether
that is going to be good old function with
a function keyword. However, as far as the
name for react to know that this function
is special, and this function is a component,
you must capitalize the name. So again, we
can create a function however, we would like
function keyword or a function. Throughout
the course, I will switch just so you can
see that of course, it will work regardless.
But what we need to do in both cases, regardless
which option you choose, is to capitalize
the name. So for example, if I'm creating
a component by the name of greeting, I must
start with a capital G. And I'm going to go
with name when we have the parameters, which
eventually we'll use, but for the time being,
we'll just leave them empty. So we go with
parentheses. And then we have curly braces.
So as you can see traditional JavaScript syntax,
we just create a function. Now one gotcha
was the fact that we needed to capitalize
the first letter, so that way, JavaScript
knows, or I'm sorry, React knows that this
is special. So this is a component. And then
from react component, we would want to return
HTML. Now, technically, it is not called HTML,
or you'll see that in a lot of blog posts
and videos and all that. Technically, it is
called JSX. And don't worry, we'll cover JSX
in more detail. For now, we just want to have
something on the screen. So from this function,
we must, must must must return again, I will
call this HTML and you'll see that as HTML,
a bunch of places will keep in mind that it
is officially called JSX. So we go with our
return. And then we simply come up with a
heading for. So that's the HTML that will
be eventually displayed on screen. So I go
with my heading four on here. All right, this
is john. This is my first component. Awesome.
Now, once I've created, as you can see, even
though I saved or nothing is happening, but
there's no reason to worry, because remember,
I said index j s is a JavaScript entry point.
Which means that, yes, normally, this is the
only thing you'll need to set up the component,
import, as well as the function which essentially
is your component. However, since index js
is an entry point, we'll need to add some
additional code.
And what we're trying to do, we're trying
to add less functionality at the moment or
whatever functionality you have into our index
HTML. Remember, I said there was a div with
an ID of root. So now what I would want is
take whatever functionality I have, which
in my case, is just this one component, and
somehow somewhere injected into my div with
an ID of road. Now, how do I do that? Well,
I'm going to go with import than react DOM.
And that is coming from other dependency.
So there are multiple dependencies. You can
clearly see them in package JSON. And one
of the other dependencies was react DOM. So
we import list from react DOM, and then react
Dom has the render method. So we go with react
Dom Then dot, and then we type here render.
Now render method is looking for two things,
it is looking for what we're going to render,
which, of course, in our case, is going to
be greeting. And the second thing well, where
we would want to render it. And of course,
that's why I showed you the now First, let's
pass the greeting. So I'm going to go here
with a greeting. And I'll close it out. And
I'll talk about why we will need to close
the components as well in a second. And the
second thing, sir, we add comma, and then
we go with document, get element by ID. And
now I'm looking for that route. And the moment
I save it, if everything is correct, I should
see. Now let me double check. Of course, what
happens right now, my dev server is not running.
So of course, that's why I cannot see anything.
So go with NPM start, I'll spin up my dev
server.
Now on the screen, I should see my heading
four. And the text will be this is john. And
this is my first component. And of course,
there it is. Now it's kind of small. So let
me zoom in. And I can clearly see that this
is john. And this is my first component. Now
the gotcha about the closing tags in react
is simple. More, even though your HTML element
might not have a closing tag, as example,
that could be for example, image, because
you know that for the image, you don't have
closing tags, you still need to self close
it. So what I'm trying to say, in this greeting,
I cannot pass it like this. So I'm going to
get a error. So in order to avoid utter, either,
I would need to set up two tags like so where
I have the greeting, and then I'm closing
out the greeting component as well. And once
I save it, notice how everything works. Or
if you don't want this empty closing tag,
or, for example, in the image tag, you already
don't have that closing tag, then you'd still
need to add this closing tag inside the opening
brackets. So that's something you need to
keep in mind. Because with html5, of course,
we can do that willy nilly. For the image,
we can include it, we can omit it, it's up
to us. But in react, you must must, must must
must have the self closing tag, if there is
no closing tag. Let's go over the setup one
more time, where if we would want to create
a component, we need to import react from
react, we need to set up a function, that
function will be component. So this is our
component, how in order for react to know
that it is going to be a component, you need
to set this up as a capital Kessler. So that's
how react knows all right. So this is not
just the regular function, this is going to
be my component. And then from the component,
we are returning HTML, which officially is
called JSX. Because, of course, there's some
nice goodies that we can do, it's not just
going to be a simple HTML. And that since
this is a entry point, show only in this case,
and essentially, I can tell you right away
that, in most cases is just going to be in
one place in your application. So you only
have to do it once. And by the way, if you're
using create react app, you won't even have
to do that. But normally, you do that in one
place where you inject your JavaScript into
the index HTML. And we do that by importing
react DOM. And then we have a render function.
And then in that function, we pass in two
things, we pass in whatever we're going to
render, and then where we're going to render.
And then since Of course, in the index HTML,
we already have the div with an ID of root.
That's where we're targeting that div. And
now of course, we have our first component
successfully displayed on a screen.
Awesome. Before we continue exploring react,
now would be a great time for me to show you
which extensions and which settings JSON setup
is going to be really helpful throughout the
course. So first, let me show you the extension
that will help us to format the code. As I
keep on scrolling notice here I have the extension
by the name of prettier code former. Now of
course, in my case, I already have installed
it, but if you don't have it, you will need
to install and then once you install, you
can navigate to a settings. So this is going
to be a GUI for sending so graphics Want to
fish. And also later we'll take a look at
the JSON file. But for the time being, just
check for the prettier or you know what? No,
you can just go for format. And then once
you look for the format and a graphical interface,
you'll find format on page as well as format
on save. So I would suggest checking both
of these boxes. And then as a result, as you're
typing, premier will format the code for you.
Now, what am I talking about, for example,
if I just keep on adding spaces in between,
basically, I just make it a big fat mess.
The moment I say it, notice how prayer right
away nicely format the code for me. So that
will be the first thing. Now the second thing
that I would want to show you is the map.
So you're probably aware that when we work
with HTML, and CSS, we have the option of
using Emmet, which essentially just speeds
up our workflow. And of course, in the Visual
Studio code that is built in how when you
work with react as far as JSX, it won't work
right out of the box. Now one of my first
of all talking about, for example, if I want
a heading for, or I don't know, the div with
some kind of IDs and classes, which will later
I don't have to start with opening tag, and
then type heading four, or article or whatever
HTML element, I can just go with her in for.
And right away, notice how Emma gives me the
suggestion. Again, we can go the same route
with article, or we can go with section or
whatever. Notice how it right away creates
for me. Now, of course, it's going to be way
more beneficial once we start adding classes.
But there are some gotchas about classes in
JSX. That's why I'm not going to cover them
right now. But essentially, in order to have
these suggestions, so essentially, in order
for you to have this option, so you don't
have to type out everything from scratch,
you need to go to your settings. And once
you navigate there, the property you're looking
for is this Emmet. Errors include languages,
and then you'd want to set up JavaScript,
and then JavaScript Korea. So that's the code
you'll need. Again, if you just want to copy
and paste the code, I would suggest going
to a GitHub. Again, my handle is going to
be john hyphen smelter. And then you're looking
for VS code setup. Shown here, you'll find
settings JSON. And then of course, this is
the property that you're looking for. So if
you set this up as raw, you can right away,
just copy and paste of this particular value.
So that will enable me in your JSX. As well
as that not notice, this is going to be format
on paste and format on Save. You can also
add them manually, like show meaning in the
settings JSON, you don't have to do that in
a GUI. And then I have some particular things
for the printer. For example, here, I set
up only the single quotes and my JSX. But
that is a row. And that is really up to you,
whether that is your preference as far as
the single quotes
or double quotes. However, using Emmet will
definitely speed up your workflow when you're
working in JSX, as well. And lastly, I have
this awesome, awesome, awesome extension by
the name of yours seven react Redux graph
qL React Native snippets. Now why this particular
extension is so cool, because it saves us
on boilerplate. So for the time being, let
me just go back to whatever I had. Sure I
don't have some kind of error. So let me save
it here. Let's just create another testing
file in source. So in source, let's create
a new file. And I'll call this testing. Now,
don't worry, we won't use it. But just to
showcase how the extension is going to work.
For example, if I want to create this new
react component, I don't have to type import
react and then set up the component. I can
simply type my snippet where if I go with
R, A, F, C and E, right away, we'll create
it as a R function, and it's ready to go.
So notice how it right away imported the React
right away set up the component and you right
away have the return as well. Now, don't be
confused by the fact that in this case, it
is set up with a lowercase The only reason
for that is because we're exporting something
that we'll cover later. And then once we import,
then we will still need to use it with a application.
Okay, sure, it's not like I was just making
this up where this needs to be uppercase,
you can clearly test it out. If you'll go
with greeting and greeting, you'll see that
there is an R. So essentially, you don't see
anything on the screen. Because of course,
you must, must, must must, must have this
component with a capital case, again, in this
case, a little bit different because we're
exporting. We're not at that point yet. So
we'll cover that later. But this extension
just gives you a awesome setup, where you
don't have to keep on typing. There's boilerplate.
Now, of course, the arrow function is not
the only component that you can create, you
can create components with regular functions,
you can create them with classes, which is
the older syntax. And if you want to see what
kind of options you have for the snippets,
just go for the extension, keep on scrolling,
and notice, you can use imp for imports, for
example, keep on scrolling, keep on scrolling,
these are all the options that you have here.
And I think the irregular function was our
FC. So this is going to be 40 class components,
we're going to keep on scrolling. And eventually
we should see the regular function component,
Americas. So RFC is going to be just a react
component, but with a traditional syntax.
So if I go back, I can right away, delete
everything, and instead of our a monotype,
our FC, and then again, our right away export.
So export, and notice how we create the same
component, or in this case, it is using regular
function syntax. So these are the things that
I would suggest adding to your project as
far as the extensions, as well as the settings
JSON, because they will improve your workflow
tremendously. Now you know what, by the end
of this video, I can just delete the custom
j s, we won't need it, as well as close my
extension. And now of course, we can go back
to react. Now the one thing, of course, is
the fact that I will need to change this back
to a greeting. Because remember, when we're
setting up a react component, when we want
to render it, it must be capitalized, beautiful
job, once we're back from the useful extensions
Vidor, now out want to make a plunge into
our component. So essentially, we know we
will cover imports a little bit later, we
know that as far as the render, it is only
in one place, essentially, where we inject
our JavaScript. So now, of course, let's talk
about this sucker, especially the official
name is going to be stateless functional component.
Now, they're also called dumb components.
Because at the moment, it doesn't have something
called state, something that we'll cover later.
As far as the rules. And the biggest one would
be that we always always need to return something.
For example, if our work,
and if I'll delete, you'll see that there's
a big factor where it says nothing was returned
from the render. Sure, you always, always
must return something, even if that something
is an empty HTML element. Of course, you can
save it. And of course, you can see that at
least, now we don't have the URL. Now, I also
want to talk about this j. s. x. because technically,
you don't have to type here this HTML, this
HTML is to help you. Okay, I know it sounds
weird, because for a lot of people probably
seeing that we're returning just HTML might
seem a little bit foreign. But just keep in
mind that essentially, under the hood, we're
still calling functions. Now, don't believe
me? Why don't we do this? Why don't we set
up here Hello, world.
I'll create another component with the same
name and everything. And I'll set it up using
the function calls, just so you can see that
under the hood, when we type this heading
four, we're still making those function calls.
Not since we cannot have two components with
the same exact name, and I'm too lazy to come
up with new component and then treasured over
here. I'll just come under sell. And let's
set up our component one more time. So in
here we go with function. And you know what,
why don't we do in this case, as IRR function,
just so you can see that it's going to work
the same way. So we're going to go here with
a greeting. So that is going to be my arrow
function. And then instead of returning HTML,
which is to help us to have a little bit easier
syntax, what we could do is go with return.
And we're going to go with react, Van create
element, where is the function, and this function
is looking for three things, what element
we would want to return, that's number one,
then props object, which we haven't covered.
So don't worry, we'll just pass in the empty
object. And then what is going to be the children.
So what is going to be rendered inside that
element? Now as far as the element, I think
I'm going to go with heading one. And, like
I said, props object haven't covered props
yet. So let's just pass an empty object. And
then last thing is going to be the children.
So in here, I'm going to go with hello world.
And then once you save, notice, everything
works correctly. So like I said, we can use
the arrow function that still works, we are
returning heading one, and then we're using
hello world. Now one thing that when you're
passing the element here, you need to pass
it in the quotation marks. So when we're working
with components, and of course, we don't have
to do that. But then if we're passing it into
the function, we must set it up as quotation
marks, because then react knows that, well,
this is going to be HTML. And then this is
going to be the content in our element. Beautiful.
Now the thing is, it's not as easy as it seems.
Because at the moment, you might be well,
this is extremely foreign. I rather use this
function setup. Okay. Now, let me comment
this one out for now. And let me show you
what happens if we have some more elements.
Because normally, probably, you'll have more
than just one hang for. And what's really
cool about JSX, I mean, we can definitely
do it. So I can go with div. And then within
this div, I'm going to create a new one, we
have a Hello World. So of course, I can see
that it works. Now at the moment, of course,
there's a div. So technically, it is hard
to see. But I can tell you right away that
it does exist. But the gotcha here is, how
would I do that here with create element?
So yes, this video might be a little bit annoying,
where, again, I'll come on the top. And then
we'll take a look at how we can do that using
the function. Well, everything worked really
smoothly, when we just had a heading one correct.
Everything worked out of the box. But now
we need to understand that where we pass in
the children, we will need to invoke create
element one more time. How is that going to
look like? Well, we would go with react, because
that is our import, then we go with create
element, then again, what element we would
want to set up. So in my case, that is going
to be heading one than props object, again,
empty object for now. And then eventually,
what is going to be a text Well, I'm going
to go with HelloWorld. So you can probably
already see, I'm sorry, not this was heading
one, it should have been a dip, my apologies.
And now you can see that it can get messy
really, really fast. Because again, we're
just talking about right now a div that has
the heading one. Well, that's it. But keep
in mind that, of course, your normal structure
for the component is going to be way more
Messier. That's why I'll leave this for your
reference. So you know what is happening under
the hood. Just keep in mind that the reason
why you have this HTML syntax is so it is
easier for you to set up your return in your
component. Because I don't know about you.
But even though it might look a little bit
foreign, we're returning straight up HTML
from the function. At the end of the day,
what we're setting up looks way more readable
than starting with these endless, endless
function calls. Beautiful and previous video
we covered as far as the return from the component
is a j. s x. And in this video, I would like
to continue because in a previous video, we
learned that it is kind of like HTML, but
not really. So there are some specific roles.
So mine is we'll cover them right now. I will
start with a first one where we always always
need to return a single element. Now what
do I mean by that? Well, inside the element
of what we're returning You can get extremely,
extremely creative. Like I said, you're gonna
return the whole website. For example, I could
arrive and three, hello, people in here. And
after that in three I'm going to go with on
our list, and then list item. And then here,
let's place a link. Now just add hashtag,
so it's not gonna go anywhere. And then we'll
write another hello world. So I can save it.
And I can clearly see that there are no issues.
Everything is working like beaches. Now the
one thing we cannot do is notice where we
have this div, I cannot add adjacent element.
Now that could be any element. But of course,
just because it's going to be simpler, I'll
just place a div. Notice even before I save,
you'll have this red squiggly line. Well,
that just means that something in your project
went bananas. So if you save notice, you'll
get a error, where it says adjacent JSX elements
must be wrapped in the enclosing tag. Did
you want a JSX fragment? Now I'll talk about
JSX fragment in a second. Just keep in mind
that we always need to return a single moment.
Now what would be the solution? In this case?
Well, I could wrap everything here in a div.
Correct. So I'll place my parent live. And
once we save, we're not going to get any error.
Now please keep in mind One thing, though,
that at the end of the day, we're still rendering
the HTML, HTML, we have something called semantics,
where if we just return everything as div,
div, div, div div. So essentially, we're just
creating a div show, that is not the best
practice. So first, I would encourage you
to follow the semantics. For example, if versus
something as a section, then we return section
instead of a div. For example, if this would
be an article, we return the article. Now,
of course, keep in mind doesn't mean that
instead of the list item, you're going to
return the article, just as a common sense,
don't place everything as definitive. Now,
there's no rule against it. But a better practice
is to follow the HTML semantics. And one more
thing, remember this little error how it said
the fragment. Now, I'm going to skip ahead
a little bit. But for example, if I would
have the situation, by the way, let me go
back to these directives. If I wouldn't want
to wrap everything div, since now, where I'm
creating diff Su. In react, we also have something
called react fragment. How does that look
like? Well, instead of enclosing everything
in a div, I'm going to enclose this into a
react fragment. So I'm going to go with dot,
and then we're typing fragments. And you'll
notice that this will create a div in your
HTML. So in your final application, but also,
you'll have no error. And shortcut essentially,
would be just typing the angle brackets, and
the closing once again, we're skipping a little
bit of head. Don't worry, we will talk about
fragments a little bit later on. But just
keep in mind that either you have an option
of using proper HTML semantics, or you can
use a fragment numbers case, I'm going to
remove the div that was causing the problems.
And I'll remove the fragments as well. Once
I said, everything works nicely when we need
to talk about the attributes in the HTML.
Because again, we're returning JSX. And for
example, when we work with JavaScript, we
can have these inline event listeners, for
example, I could type here onClick. Now please
keep in mind, I'm adding just a div. Normally,
probably you would add this to a button. But
that doesn't change the setup, where essentially
in react, you're not going to write like this,
you're not going to say on click, notice how
since this is JavaScript, we must capitalize
it. So what I'm saying here is on click, now,
I'm not going to talk about the events right
now, I'm just telling you that each numeric
attribute that will need a capitalization,
you must add it otherwise there's going to
be an error. So the same will work with a
class where with your six class is already
a keyword, because we know that we can create
classes. So on a dev, if we have the attribute
of class in JSX, we cannot write class. So
this will spit back error. Okay. Now of course,
the error at the moment is the fact We cannot
see anything. But in general, you must use
class name. So that is the proper name. Now
we'll talk about CSS a little bit later. Just
remember, every time we talk about HTML attributes,
if you need to use the camel case, you have
to do that. Otherwise, it won't work. And
then also remember how I talked about how
we need to close out the elements, even the
ones that don't have the closing tag, and
even the ones that in html5, you can write
without the closing tag, well, in react, that's
not going to fly. So for example, around after
the list item, I'm going to go with image.
And notice how the image right away creates
for me with a closing tag, and if all images,
and if I save, again, I'm going to get error.
And it clearly tells me expected corresponding
JSX closing tag 40. img. Once I add, of course,
everything is going to work beautifully. Once
I save, there is there's no more. So the same
will work for input, for example, and go with
input text. Again, if I omit this closing
tag, again, I'm going to have the error. And
the last thing that I would want to mention
in this video are these parentheses, because
as you start working with JSX, you'll notice
that once in a while, they will be added by
the premier. And once in a while prayer will
just omit them. So what are the rules. Now,
technically, you don't have to use the parentheses,
but I can tell you right away that your life
will be a little bit easier if you do. So
let me show you what I mean. For example,
here I have the return, I'm just going to
go with anyone and I'm going to say hello
world, life is awesome. However, if for example,
you will move your whole thing over here,
notice how this one got grayed out. And essentially
now once you say it, you will have this some
icon. So technically, you can omit the parentheses,
but then you always always need to make sure
that your opening tag is in the same line
as your turn. Otherwise, it will have that
same icon. And then you will get this error.
So this just saves you from running around
like a headless chicken and looking for the
error where the error does not exist. However,
if you add those parentheses, it will be fixed
right away for you. Again, prettier, a lot
of times we'll just add them, or we'll remove
them. So don't stress about that. But I'm
just telling you the rule that if you have
these parentheses, then you don't have to
worry about placing this div, meaning the
opening tag in the same line here, I can simply
move to the next line. Again, I can go ahead
and go on and then hello world. And you'll
see that there are no issues. Okay, that's
something that I want you to keep in mind.
Again, we must, must must, must always return
a single element.
It is beneficial if we pay attention to a
HTML semantics or we can simply use the React
fragment. Then as far as the attributes, we
are using the camel case, because at the end
of the day, this is JavaScript when the class
is already keyword. So we must use a glass
now. We'll talk about the CSS in detail a
little bit later on, as well as we would want
to close up every single element, even the
ones that are not technically required by
html5. And then lastly, it is beneficial to
use these parentheses because you just don't
need to worry about setting up your opening
tag in the same line as the return. Not bad.
Not bad. We covered JSX rules. So now let's
talk about whether we can unmask components.
And the short answer is yes. Also, let's take
a look at the reactors. Remember when we install
them, I said probably won't make much sense.
But now it will. Since now, we have already
a general understanding how the components
work. First, let's start by creating the master
component structure. Like I said before, if
you want, you can place your whole app in
one component. However, it's somewhat defeats
the purpose of why you would want to use react
in the first place. Because the idea is that
you can split up your application in nice
separate chunks of functionality. Now in our
case, of course, we're just setting up simple
HTML. So now I'm going to look as you useful.
But in general, it's going to give us a good
idea how, and why we want to do that, for
example, I have to do, I'm going to have a
Heading Two, with a text of john doe, john
doe, a man, I'm going to have a paragraph
with the text of this is my message. And now
let's think about it. So I have the greeting
component, I have the heading two and I have
the paragraph, I want to set up two separate
components, one that just deals with heading
to the other one that just deals with a paragraph.
And just to spice things up, I'm going to
use arrow functions. And in one case, I'm
going to use implicit return. And the other
case, it's going to be a explicit return,
just so we can see that it is going to work
regardless. In this case, I'm going to go
with cons. Now we do need to come up with
a name. So I'm going to go with a person.
And this is going to be my implicit return.
So for those of you who are familiar with
our functions, course, I can add here curly
braces. So of course, then I will need to
set up explicit return, which we'll do in
the next component, or can simply say that,
whatever I'll type, well, that is what I'm
going to be returning. So in this case, what
I would like to return, well, I would want
to return john doe, right. So either you can
write it from scratch, or in this case, I'll
just copy and paste. And now of course, once
I render, well, I only have this is my message,
because now this value is in the person. So
how can I render whatever I'm returning from
this component more simple. In the greeting,
instead of HTML element, I'm going to go with
my react component, what is the name of the
component that is person. Again, remember,
we do need to self close it on the monitor,
save it, I have Jonathan. So of course, now
we can put two and two together, that I can
do the same thing with the paragraph. Again,
the only difference is going to be that I
would want to set up explicit return, just
so we can see the difference. So let's call
this message. And again, we have our function.
And in here, we'll just write return. And
then what I would like to return course, the
paragraph, so grab the paragraph, and this
is what we were returning from our message
function. Now, of course, let's just set up
a message right after the person. So once
I save, I have both of them. But notice how
we're nicely splitting up our application
into separate chunks. And that is really,
really cool because we can use them later,
Lego blocks to build our application. And
as a side note, this is a somewhat traditional
way of how to set up a react application,
where of course, we'll use the exports and
imports and everything of that nature. However,
we will set up this one component. In most
cases, the general convention is calling this
app, then in that app, we're going to be either
1234 or 55,000 components that will meet,
please keep in mind that you can have more
components in those specific components. So
for example, in the person, I could render
even more components, or there's going to
be this app where your components will meet.
And then you will import into an address that
particular component again, shake and bake
app or whatever you have decided to name it.
And then you will render it. So this is going
to be pretty typical setup. So that's how
we can nest components inside other react
components. And now let's also take a look
at the React developer tools. So I'm going
to make my right screen bigger on my open
up my developer tools. And we're looking for
the components. So of course, we installed
already react developer tools, that is out
of the way. And then we're looking for the
component. And now you'll notice something
interesting, where this is going to be our
root component. So at the moment, we call
this greeting. And then of course, inside
the greeting, I have a person and the message.
Again, we haven't covered props. So none of
that makes sense. Or we can clearly see that
this is going to be our component structure.
And as our apps and examples are going to
get more complicated course we will still
be able to see what in a world we're actually
rendering amazing work so far, and I think
we'll We have acquired enough knowledge to
create a simple Amazon best selling book list.
Now, what am I talking about? If we navigate
to search engine, just type Amazon best selling
books now the word Margaret asked you to buy
anything, but we will try to recreate at least
some parts of it using react. Now you can
pick any book you would like. But I'm gonna
go with this one. Because this one is by far
the most favorite book of my daughter and
I have probably read this, I don't know, I
want to say 1000 times. But I don't think
that even close to a real number. So here,
what are we looking for, we're going to go
back to our application, we'll just give it
a more meaningful name. Keep in mind, you
can call this greeting port, I'm going to
go with a book list,
let's say book list internationally, there
will be a list of books, then we're going
to go with book list as well. And then I'll
do a little bit of spring cleaning, where
for the time being, I'll say that it is going
to be a section on here, let's write this
is a book list. Now of course, there's nothing
there right now. Where we have the person
and message, well, eventually, it's going
to be two different components. So I'll just
remove them. And once we say that, of course,
we have this, this is a book. So now of course,
I would want to create four components. Now
please keep in mind, technically, I could
just set up one where I have the book. And
the book, I could have the image are going
to have title, as well as the author. Now
I'll purposely put this up into three components,
meaning there's going to be book component,
and then in there, there is going to be three
separate components, one for image, one for
title, and one for author, just to showcase
how we would mask those components even more.
And then later, we will refactor it back to
one book. And this is just to showcase that
it is up to you how you want to structure
your application. If you want to create everything
as a component, you can definitely do it.
Or you can just place everything in one book
component. So where we have the book list,
right after that, I am going to create another
component. Now in this case, though, I'm going
to use our function. Again, you can use regular
function if you want. But I'm going to go
with our function, we have our parameters,
we have implicit return. And then as far as
return out, want to return the article, another
HTML element in there are going to be three
separate components. For time being, I'll
just say this is a book. Okay, we save that.
And then where we have book list, now what
we could do is just get rid of this generic
text and say that I'm looking for the book.
So once I save it, I have this is a book.
Now what's really, really, really, really
cool about react is that I can add multiple
instances of that book. So if I start just
copying, pasting the same instance of the
book, notice how here, I'm getting these values
as well. So what that means is that the moment
I'll change something in my book, but of course,
it will affect all the instances that I have.
So here, I'll say this is a book of churches
around to this is a car. Now, of course, it's
not gonna make sense. But you'll see right
away that all my instances in here are changed,
which is really, really, really cool. And
of course, I'm gonna have 5000 of them, I
could one of them, or now, three of them,
or whatever. And then later, we'll take a
look at how we can render with a different
input, because we need to understand that
of course, at the moment, we'll just hard
code this one value, but it's already really
cool that we can multiply it on the fly, and
then change it in one place. Because notice,
it's not like I had to hop from one place
to another one. To change this text. I just
set up the components are copied, how many
times I want. And then once I change something
in here, that's it, all the instances will
be affected. Now, I will go back to my one
single book. And like I said, it's gonna be
a little bit of overkill right now. But I'll
set up three separate components. So here
I'll call this image or just try and push
it return because why not? So we'll return
a wrench and in To get that image, just click
on it, and you're looking for the copy image
address, that's the one you need, and then
place it here in source. Now as far as the
alternative, I'm not going to worry about
it. And then where we have the book, instead
of this is a car, which totally doesn't make
sense. Now I'm just looking for this image.
So like I said, even though this is a component,
I can match even more components. So I have
a book, that is the render in a book list.
However, in the book, there is going to be
three separate components, let's say with
a murders. Now, of course, I have my image.
Now, what's next? Well, now what I would want
is to grab a title, as well as the author.
And again, it's going to be a little bit of
overkill, but we'll create two more components.
So let's call this author course, we will
need to set up our return. Again, you want
implicit, you can set up implicit, if you
want explicit, you can set up explicit, I
think I'm going to go with implicit, where
I'm going to go with heading one, by the way,
I need to have this fat arrow function. As
far as the value let's just already not, didn't
copy. So let me grab this one. By the way,
I think I was going for the author, my apologies,
I think I'm gonna have to rename this, it's
not going to be your author is going to be
a title, my bad. So there's my title. And
then right after this image, I would want
to add my title. So that's, of course, my
title component. And there it is, now I have
my coupon. And lastly, of course, let's also
the author, show, we're going to go with cons
and then author, again, implicit, explicit,
whatever, you can set up a traditional function
if you want, and then we're looking for this
value. So let me figure out how I can copy
that work. So I don't know I'm going to close
this and heading for copy and paste. And then
of course, I'll do the same thing over here,
where we're going to go with an author. Now
once we set this up, notice, I have my book
component. In that book component, I have
three separate components, one for the image,
one for the title, and one for the author,
I'm on where I render my book, he found crazy
knowledge. Now, of course, we have these multiple
instances. And we already saw the moment,
I'll change something around here, it will
affect all the instances where I render my
book. And my opinion, it's really, really
awesome, because as you can see, we can nicely
utilize our component structure where we can
have as many instances as we would want, but
we control them in only one plus. And the
moment we add those changes, all the instances
will be affected. Nice work, we've got our
list. Now granted, there's a bunch of hard
coded values. But of course, we'll fix that
a little bit later. Now I'd want to focus
on the presentation because it looks somewhat
okay. But at the end of the day, it could
look a little bit less hideous. So essentially,
I would want to set up some kind of grid layout
with some columns, and maybe a better coloring
as well. And in the process, we'll take a
look at how we can add CSS to our react project.
Now, I also would like to mention that this
is going to be the only video where we will
type out the CSS remaining of the course,
since it is a react course at the end of the
day, all the CSS is already prepared, whether
that is going to be the examples or project
or whatever. Or in this case, in this video.
Yes, we will type out CSS properties. Now,
if you're not too familiar with CSS, don't
worry, just type them along and we will be
in good shape. So we've got our project now,
here find navigate to a new tab. And by the
way, I think I failed to mention that if you'd
want to see your project, you'd need to navigate
to a localhost 3000. So essentially, when
the dev server spins up the server, the port
is localhost. And then 3000. That's the one
that you're looking for. If I open this up,
of course, this is what I see. I see a list
of books and like I said, Our just want to
take a look at how we can add CSS. So we have
some minimal grid layout with some columns
and maybe a little bit different styling as
well. And if I take a look at my project,
yeah, of course I have the React tools and
that is very useful. But of course, I can
also inspect the elements correct. And what
I see here is the root. Like I said, this
is where we Polish our app. And then we have
a section, since that is my tag, and then
I have the article. And this also underscores
the point about those divs. It's not like
they will disappear, the more lives you will
place over here, the more harder it's going
to be, of course, for you to navigate around
your project, because you will have div div,
div, div, div, div div. So again, I'm returning
to that point, but I think it's quite important.
And of course, as you can see, as I'm hovering
around, these are my items. So we could put
two and two together, we have the HTML. Now
how do we usually add CSS, we create some
kind of CSS file correct. So let's navigate
back to our project.
We're looking for my source. And we'll create
a new file. We can call it whatever we want.
But, of course, convention is that if this
is the file for images, and I might as well
call it index c, s s. So once I created this
file, let me just add some general styling.
And then of course, we will need to figure
out how we can attach it because I can tell
you right away whatever changes we'll write
right now won't affect our project. Because
we haven't connected to now what I would want
is to set up basic reset, where we've got
a margin zero, than padding zero, padding
zero, was up a box sizing to be a border box
box sizing to be border box. And then let's
also target the body with some background
and the color. So we're looking for the body,
then font family, and here, I'll go for a
system font. So let's try to get the system
font. And also let's add a little bit of gray
background. So we go with background. And
then we're looking for hashtag, f one, f five
f eight, macho. And then lastly, I would want
to add a color for all my text hashtag tu
tu tu, tu herbertson. Beautiful. Now once
I've got this, of course, how do we connect
it? Well, the same how we were importing our
code, meaning functionality from the dependencies,
we also need to import our CSS. Now, the gotcha
here is following, where if it's going to
be a JavaScript file that we haven't covered,
of course, we'll cover that a little bit later,
then we don't need to add the extension. However,
if it is a CSS, you need to provide a full
path. So if I'm going for CSS, I'm still going
40 import, then I need to use the relative
path, because this is not my projects dependency
anymore. So here I'm looking for specific
file. So I go with a dot and then forward
slash. Now what that means, or that means
that the file is in the same folder. If it's
going to be one level up, then we're going
to go with two dots. And of course, we'll
take a look at that example, a little bit
later. For now, this is a relative path, there's
just says that this file is in the same folder,
so dot and then forward slash. And like I
said, either that would be a JavaScript file
would simply would write a file name. So file
name lecture. However, if this is a CSS file,
then we need to go with index, and then dot
and then CSS. So full extension. Now also,
of course, with JavaScript file, we'll probably
import something from there. In here, we're
just grabbing everything. So I'll save. And
we should notice some changes. And of course,
we do. Now see how the margin is not there
anymore, the padding, also the background
changed a little bit. And overall, it looks
a little bit more presentable. So that's an
awesome start, we know that we can start targeting
the elements. And of course, since I know
that I have these heading ones, I could simply
say something like that color, and then a
red and beautiful. And now all my heading
ones, of course are going to be red. Now that's
a little bit drastic. So now let's take a
look at how we can work with glasses. So index
js, remember I said class, we cannot use.
So if I go with section, and then say here,
simply class, and I don't know, I'll write
this as a book list. You'll notice and I'm
gonna go to a bigger browser window is going
to be easier to see. If we take a look at
the console. We have warning invalid Dom property
class. Did you mean class name? Sure. We always
always need to use a class name.
So we go back, we fix it. And now we have
a book list. Again, please don't worry about
the CSS. This is The only time we have to
write CSS, but essentially owD, one, set it
up as a grid, once we get to, I don't know
768. So now of course, I added my class to
my section, the book list, just like I would
in a normal index HTML, CSS project. Online,
of course, I need to target it in CSS. Correct.
So we go with booklists, I'll add a little
bit of width. So 90 view with van, we're going
to add max width to be 1170 pixels, we're
going to add a little bit of margin top bottom
five are yams, but I would like to place it
in the center. So we'll also add auto, and
we will set it right away as grid. And I'll
add some gap in between, so say gap to REM.
So that just means that for my rows and for
the columns will have to REM as far as the
gap. Okay, looks already a little bit better.
And now let's set up quickly that three column
layout once we get to 768, so we're going
to go with media screen. And, and in here
we're looking for men with men with and that
will be equal to 768 pixels. Awesome. I'm
looking for my booklist again. So that's the
class that of course, added to a section.
And I'm looking for grid, template columns.
And we're gonna go with repeat, and three
on one fraction. So essentially, once we navigate
to a bigger screen Veritas, we have our three
column layout. And of course, let's add a
little bit more styling here for the book
itself. Now, what is a book? My book was that
article correct? Again, let me go back here,
my road. In the road, I have my list. And
then I have all these items. Now, of course,
I'll need to add a class on the article. So
I can target them when we navigate to images.
Now where I would need to add this class,
you added here where I'm rendering the book,
or where I'm setting up the book. Of course,
the answer is where I'm setting up the book.
So we go with article, class name, and that
will be equal to a book. So now in the index
CSS, right after our media query, we go with
book, our different background. So we're gonna
go with hashtag fff, so white border radius,
I don't know, I'm gonna go with the one REM,
and that should do it. And then also, I'm
going to add a little bit of padding. So we're
gonna go with padding to be one REM,
to RPMs, like so. So that's our padding. And
then of course, I could also target the heading
one. Now, the reason why I'm showing you the
heading one is not because I really want to
work on the CSS. It is because in the next
video, we'll take a look at another way how
we can do styling in react. So let's just
target in this time, heading one. Now, again,
I can target all the heading ones if I want,
but a little bit more precise would be going
for the book, and then heading one. And then
I'll just say margin, top to be equal to 0.5.
REM. And that's it. Now, of course, we add
the margin. So that probably is the most straightforward
way how to add CSS. However, of course, keep
in mind that this works nicely. If you have
somewhat of a small project, the bigger the
project gets, then of course, you need to
start spinning your wheels. Because still
same issues apply as far as, for example,
name collisions, or you cannot reuse the same
name, essentially the same rules as with CSS.
So that's usually when, for example, solutions
like CSS in j s come into play. And yes, we
will cover that a little bit later since I
will use that solution throughout the course,
because that's just easier for me to add all
the CSS that we'll use. But this is definitely
one of the options where we create a index
CSS or app CSS, whatever CSS file you would
want. And then in there, we add our classes,
we add our roles. And then of course, the
only thing we need to do is include that file
in our index JS or abjures or whatever. And
once you're included, then of course, if you're
out these classes, if you have those styles,
they will right away affect your project,
just like in a normal HTML CSS project, while
adding your CSS from the CSS file is definitely
an option. We also can do it directly in the
J s x now For my example, I will pick my heading
for, just please keep in mind the same rules
would apply for heading one, or image or article,
or whatever HTML element we are placing. Now
of course, I'm doing air quotes right now
around the HTML element, then of course, it
is a JSX. And the way we do that, we need
to add a style attribute on that particular
element. So I'm going to look for my heading
for, and I'll type here style. Now in the
following videos, we will take a look at what
it actually means as far as the JavaScript.
But for now, just remember that if you would
want to access JavaScript world, in the JSX,
you would need to set up your curly braces.
Now, why am I setting up these curly braces?
Well, because in order to set up a values
for the style, the gotcha is that you need
to have a JavaScript object, meaning object,
and then all the properties are going to be
as a JavaScript powers, like you would have
in the object. And you'll see what exactly
that means in a second. Now, why am I telling
you all this is because once I'm in the JavaScript
world, here with these curly braces, of course,
in order to create an object, I would need
to set up another pair of curly braces. And
a lot of times for students, this is confusing,
where they think that this is somehow a special
syntax. In fact, it's not, it only means that
if I set up here, these curly braces, I'm
back in just one. So for example, I can type
whatever I would want, as far as JavaScript.
Now, of course, that whatever in this case
is just an object. Okay. That's why we have
these double curly braces. So for the first
ones, we go back to JavaScript world. And
of course, we will cover the other things
that we can do as far as JavaScript in the
following videos. But for now, we only want
the object. So that's why we have another
set of curly braces. So what we could do is,
of course, set up the style. And like I said,
this is JavaScript. Now what that means is,
you cannot write properties like this, because
you're setting up a JavaScript object, how
that would look like, well, for example, if
I go with color, it's somewhat straightforward,
where Nat is my property, notice, I don't
need to capitalize it or nothing like that.
However, as far as my value, I cannot simply
go with one REM. Notice, it spits back error,
because in JavaScript, of course, we have
properties and then values. So in this case,
all your values must be in quotation marks.
So in here, if I go with hashtag, and then
617. And then I'm going to go D nine, eight,
of course, I'll change the color of my heading
four, then I would want to go with font size.
And this is the case where I will have to
capitalize because again, I cannot write font
and then hyphen size. Now I have to go with
font size. And again, the same thing, values
must be in quotation marks. So we go with
zero point 75 ariados. So a little bit smaller.
And then also, let's add a margin to the top.
So we're gonna go with margin, and then grand,
we'll set it up to be zero point 25. REM.
So once we save it, notice how we nicely apply
both styles. Now, one thing we need to keep
in mind, though, that when we add the styles
are this way, so directly in the JSX. This
is set up as inline. So what that means is
that of course, we know that when we set up
something inline, and notice this is what
I'm talking about. Then, of course, if I'm
targeting the same element from the CSS from
my index, CSS in this example, of course,
rules, whatever I'm applying are not going
to be added. Why? Well, because inline CSS
is more powerful than the one that's coming
from the CSS. For example, if I would go here
and say book, a man, what I was using, I think
heading four. If I'll try to change the color,
so color to red, you'll see that that is not
possible.
That's not going to work. However, if it's
a property that of course I haven't added,
like for example, letter spacing, and I'll
set it equal to five pixels, when of course
it will be applied. So what I'm trying to
say is that Be careful when you start adding
the CSS here in the JSX. This will right away
go in line and once it goes in line, it is
stronger than the CSS that you're adding from
Your specific CSS file. Now, why am I telling
you that because of course later, as you're
progressing with react, you will start using
some libraries. And a lot of times in those
libraries, there are some properties that
are already added this way. So when you're
targeting from CSS, it looks like you're not
applying those properties. But always, always
double check whether the library that you're
using hasn't already added those styles in
line. And then of course, you just need to
figure out how you can override them. Okay,
so that would be another way we can CSS in
react. And that also underscores Another point
that I would want to make. One thing about
react is, there's always multiple ways, or
you can do the same thing. So my job is to
show you what other options and then your
job is to decide which route I'm going to
take. And I would suggest a judging that on
your experience, and on your project, not
on whatever the influencer is saying on Twitter,
because at the end of that you are going to
be one working on a project. So my preference,
of course, is at least setting up in the CSS.
Now in general, my preference, of course,
is using CSS engineers. But that is my preference.
That doesn't mean that it is some kind of
rule. No, it is just my preference, because
I find it easier to work in the CSS, and then
just add classes. If you prefer this type
of way. There's nothing stopping you from
applying your styles of this way. Not bad
and bad. We now know how we can add CSS to
our rear project. But in a previous video,
I mentioned that you in order to access JavaScript
world in the JSX, we need to add these curly
braces. So let me expand on that. So essentially,
we're going to take a look at the other options
we have as far as adding JavaScript directly
in our JSX. Now before we do anything, though,
I would want to do a little bit of spring
cleanup, just because I'm looking at the file,
and I think it's getting quite busy. Now at
this point, I will switch from these three
separate components to one component, book
component, and all my return in there. Again,
that is up to you. If you want to keep everything
a separate component, you can definitely do
it. My goal was to showcase that no one is
stopping you. But in general, my preference
is not to go too crazy. As far as splitting
up certain here, the only thing that I would
want is Where have all the returns. So I'll
just place them here. So for example, in this
book article, I'm gonna have the image, I'm
gonna have my heading one. And also a little
bit more things in here. Now, in here, of
course, I placed it side by side. So right
away have the error. And then as far as the
styling, that's not usually my preference.
So I'll just remove it altogether. So our
more style, please keep in mind, you always
have a reference to the files we have been
working on. So here are right off 30 hanging
for more heading one, I'll place my heading
for our move my components that I have, will
save. And then of course, I'm going to go
back to the CSS that are added in the previous
video shown here, of course, we just need
to change it, where if I remember correctly,
the color that I had was hashtag. So let's
go back hashtag, and 617. And then D Nine,
eight Vann letter spacing, I'm not going to
add that on, by the way, muster up here, so
it's not f it is six. Um, what else font size,
I guess was different, right? So font size,
we're looking for zero point 75 volumes, and
also add a little bit of margin to the top
margin top, and we go with zero point 25 volumes.
That's it. Now, of course, we set everything
up correctly. So back in the images. Now let's
take a look at what else can we do as far
as the JavaScript, because in a previous video,
we had a look of how we can add a CSS. But
of course, we can do way more than that again.
In order to go back to a JavaScript world.
What do we need to do is to have curly braces.
So now I would want to replace this heading
one with some kind of variable value. Now
I'm going to start here where I'm gonna say
const and Title
Nine is going to be equal to whatever text
I have. So I love you to the moon and back.
Of course, I'll set this up as a string, shell
copy and paste. And in here, once I go back
to the JavaScript world, how do I access the
variables in JavaScript? Now simply, I just
write a title, correct, because that is the
name of my variable. So now, of course, I'm
not hard coding this anymore. Because in here,
this is sitting in a variable. And if I'll
just start adding SS here, of course, you
can see that this value, also right away changes.
And if you want, of course, we can keep this
outside as well. Now are you always going
to keep the variables inside the function
or outside? Well, that depends, a lot of times
you'll be getting this as props, something
we haven't covered yet, show, it really depends,
I'm just showing you the options where you
can store those variables for this particular
example. And if I would want to have the author,
I'm going to create another one. So there's
going to be a variable outside this time,
just so you can see that it will still work.
So let me grab this value. And then of course,
I'm going to have my author,
or XL. Now wonderful about setting up JavaScript
here in the JSX, that it must return a value
show, it has to be an expression, it cannot
be a statement shown here. Let's create a
paragraph. Let's just test that out. So we
have here a JavaScript, but I'm going to write
a statement. So I'll say let x is equal to
six. Now the moment I'll save it, I will have
a big fat error, where it's going to point
to a lot. So essentially, we always need to
pass something here that returns the value.
So now let me comment this out. By the way,
the way we comment out in JSX, we have curly
brace, and then we have forward slash, and
then the star. Now, I'm using the shortcut,
which is command and then forward slash. But
if you want to check it out how to actually
do that as far as your setup, then look for
the Edit. And then you're looking for this
toggle line comment. And as you can see, in
my case, it is a command and then port slash,
that's the shortcut that I'm using. Also,
as a side note, if you want to check out all
the shortcuts that you have, and the reason
why I'm showing that because not everyone
uses Mac. So of course, some are a little
bit different for the windows, just go to
Visual Studio Code near will open up in a
new window. And by the way, I'll open up also
right away a new browser window. And then
once you open up before you drag and drop
anything, just look for printable keyboard
cheat sheet. And this is where you'll find
for your operating system. Now I'm not saying
that you need to sit for one month and memorize
them. But for example, if you'll learn one
keyboard shortcut today, trust me it will
overall improve your workflow tremendously.
So that is a quick side note. And now of course,
we're heading back to our project. So that's
how we're coming out, we cannot have here
a statement. But if we'll set up a expression,
everything will work. Now, if I'll try to
do the same thing, for example, with a paragraph,
and in here, I'll pass six plus six. Now,
of course, I'm returning a value. And as a
result, I'm going to have this 12. So that's
how we can work with JavaScript in the JSX.
So we set up here, curly braces, that means
we're going back to a JavaScript plan. And
Land Of course, as long as we're setting up
expression, we're good to go. Now, of course,
we can do tons of cool things in here. For
example, I have the author. Now, what is the
property, or I'm sorry, what is the method
that we can use on a string, we can go to,
for example, uppercase correct, I could just
invoke it. And I'll see that my value right
away is invoked. So these are just a few things
that we can do. Now that we know that we can
set up JavaScript in our JSX. Essentially,
you can see that we right away make our JSX
way more dynamic. That just means that we
don't have to hard code everything. amazing
job. Now that we know that we can access JavaScript
in our JSX course let's take a look at the
props. Wire would want to props. Well, even
though I could set these ones up as variables,
I can pass them when I'll copy and paste The
book essentially went on have multiple instances
of the book, at the end of the day, they will
still display the same result. So now I'd
want to take a look at how we can change these
values here, depending on whatever we are
passing in. Now I'll start by moving all my
variables, right after the CSS. So I'll say
here, set up bars. And then I'll do the same
thing for the title. So I'll push it over
here. And you know what, I'll do the exact
same thing with an image. So call this const.
And an IMG. And that will be equal to whatever
value I have or here, now right away copy,
a string is going to be easier copy and paste,
I have author, title image. And now of course,
where I have the source. Again, I go back
to JavaScript land. And what is the variable
name, that is I am G. So once I sell it, nothing
breaks, which is beautiful. When our remove
some of the stuff that we added in last video,
I don't think it is necessary over here.
Let's remove both of these things as well.
So now we go back to our standard setup. So
once this is done, well, how we can pass something
unique over here, because like I said, or
copy and paste. Yeah, it works really well,
we get the same instance. And everything is
beautiful. But the values don't change. Now,
book is a function. Correct? Now, what do
we know about functions in JavaScript? well
know that there are parameters or arguments.
So if I would have simple function, if I set
up some kind of parameter, for example, name,
and then if I pass it in, and of course, I
can use it in my function. So can we do the
same thing in react? Now, let's say, and you
can probably already guess that. I'm suggesting
that that most likely, we'll be able to do
that. Otherwise? I mean, I wouldn't be kind
of mean, wouldn't it? Okay, so I have my book
component, which is a function. Now where
do we write usually parameters? It is right
here. Correct. So let's write a parameter
name. Now, all right, this is a prop, because
that is a general convention. It just stands
short. For properties, we usually pass in.
However, you can call this shake,
and bake,
and bake, or whatever you would want. Okay,
just keep that in mind. And of course, we'll
take a look at the example a little bit later
where we call the shake and bake. So we've
got our props. Now, of course, I want to console
login, because I want to see, well, what is
this value here? What is this props, and I
can console log in two places, I can do it
above the return. And I can just say props,
just make sure that the name is exactly the
same. So if you're trying to test it out that
you can call this whatever you would want.
So if you wrote here, bananas, don't console
log props, console log bananas. And also I
can do the same thing here. Correct. Because
remember, in the JSX, we could console log,
meaning we can go back to just bland certain
here. All right, perhaps, as well. And we'll
notice something interesting, where if I inspect
in my console, I have object object object.
Okay, what's happening here? Well, there is
an object. Now the cool thing now is that,
of course, I can access that object. But obviously,
the next question is, how can I pass something
in here, I do have the object. That's why
you can see that we can name it whatever rude.
One can be banana, she can be shaken, bake,
whatever. At the end of the day, it's always
going to be an object, our convention is using
props. So unless you want to be a real rebel,
I would suggest sticking to that convention.
And you're not I think there's too many console
logs at this point. But beautifully, we can
see that it is an object. Now. Well, in order
to pass the sin, we need to go back to where
we are rendering the book, not where we're
setting up your access, or where we render
the book. This is where we need to pass it.
And the way we pass it, we have a prop name,
and then whatever value. So if I'm going to
go here with a random problem of a job, and
if I set this up as a value of developer,
you'll notice that now when we go console
log, we have job. And then we have developer.
So that's it. Awesome. Now, of course, we
can access those values. Now a few things
that we can notice here. For the second book,
I'm still console logging the props. However,
I didn't pass anything correct. In here, course
we have the job with the value, how in here,
or just have the empty object? That's why
the second console log essentially is just
an empty object because I didn't pass him.
Can we pass something in? Yeah, I can say
title. And I'll call this random battle. Ram,
can we pass for example, a number? Yeah, I
could go with number, where price or whatever.
And I can just say simply over here, the value
will be equal to something. Again, I go back
to JavaScript, because again, this is still
JSX. For the time being, I'll just pass in
22. So now notice, for the first one, I have
job, and developer, that is the property and
the value in my object. Horror, for the second
one, I have a title property, the value is
random title. And here are passed in a number
property with a value of 23. So what I'm trying
to say, as far as the value, same as with
JavaScript, we can pass the values here in
props. Now the next question, of course, is
now how we can access them. There's multiple
ways that we can do that. That's why we'll
split this up in multiple videos, but the
most basic one would be using the same name
that you used over here. So again, if I go,
shake, and bake, I'll still be able to do
it. Keep that in mind, but you use the same
name. And now of course, we are just accessing
those properties, just like in regular react.
Now, I did not pass my correct values as far
as author, title and image. So for the time
being, I'll just create two paragraphs will
show you how I can access those values. So
in here, I'll say that I'm looking for props
and a job. And then we'll see two things,
we'll see that for the first value, we do
have developer. So that is correct. But then
for the second one, we have nothing. Now why
is that happening? Well, because I did not
pass the prop by the name of job for the second
one. So that is what is going to happen when
the prop is not there. So if the prop is not
there, it just won't be displayed.
However, in this case, I have the title for
the second one right here, copy and paste.
Again, I'm looking for props and then battle.
So now of course, this will be displayed on
the second one, but not on the first one.
So hopefully this makes sense where when you're
setting up a list, of course, you need to
make sure that the props that you're passing
actually match to whatever you're looking
in the component. Correct. So if for example,
in the component, I'm looking for job, and
make sure that all your instances have that
job, because if that value won't be there,
well, you just want displayed on the last
one, let's go with paragraph here. And again,
we'll look for props. And then what was the
property that I was looking for, not as of
course, the number, of course, I'm passing
in the number of murders, right, so we can
start making these values more dynamic, as
you can see, because we're accessing the props.
And, of course, when we're rendering the book,
we pass it in again, we have proper name,
and then the value. And now as I'm looking
at my values over here, calm, we set this
up as two separate objects, where essentially
what I could do is for the first book, pass
the property values from the first object,
where of course, I'm going to have my image,
my author and title. And then of course, we
will do the same thing for a different book.
Now let me look for a short name. I think
I'm going to use this one, because I just
don't want to copy too long of a name. So
let's do that. Let's refactor these three
values into a object and let's call this first
book. So const first book, that will be equal
to our object. And then again, we have a bunch
of properties. I'll start with an image and
I'll just take these values. So cut it out,
copy Based on what else we have course we
have the title. So we're going to go with
title property. Man, what is the value it
is this one over here we have the last one
of the author. So we'll go with author, and
also this equal to whatever value I had.
And now, of course, I would want to access
them. Now keep in mind, we could have access
this as a straight up variables, like I just
had them before. The only difference right
now is going to be that of course, I'll set
up proper props. So in here, let's start with
IMG. So that's my IMG prop. And that will
be equal to first book, because that, of course,
is my object name. And then property value
is IMG, a man where I'm accessing the props
right now, I'm not going to be looking for
job title number, since I will remove them
however, for the image. And we're going to
go for props. And then I'm looking for the
I am G. Now of course, again, I'm grabbing
whatever I have, in the first book, I would
need to do the same thing for the title. So
again, the proper name is title. Again, we're
going back to a JavaScript land. And in here
on maxon, first book, I'm not I'm looking
for the title. So I'll say first book on land
title. Again, let me emphasize something where
it doesn't have to be an object, we could
have just access the properties. But since
I would want to set up two of them to object
since I would want to have two different values.
That's why of course, I set it up as a object.
And last one was the author. Again, we have
the proper name, which is an author, and then
we look in the first book, and then the property
we're looking for is the author. So now of
course, I can remove these ones, they were
just for testing purposes, and then just replace
where I have the props, more preferred title,
where I have the author, I'm looking for the
author. Now the problem right now is going
to be that Yeah, the first one is displayed
nicely. However, for the second one, notice,
I'm just passing in some random values. So
like I was saying, Yeah, we can pass whatever
props you would want. But keep in mind that
if in the component, you're not looking for
them, Well, nothing is gonna happen. You can
pass all day long, but nothing is going to
be around. However, if the component is looking
for specific prop and you're not passing,
notice, I cannot see the image. So what we
would need to do, well, eventually, we'll
set up a list and we'll iterate over the list.
Now all that is coming up. But for the time
being, what I would want is just copy and
paste. And we'll write a second book. Now
why am I setting up a second book because
now of course, I would want change of those
values, shown here, I'm going to go for copy
image address, and we'll replace it. We're
going to copy and paste. So this is going
to be different image, then, of course, I
would want also get my name. So let me see.
Now, of course this navigates here. So I guess
I can just copy and paste from here, or so.
So let's navigate back, we're gonna go with
a different value here. And of course, I also
would want to get a author. So let me somehow
copy and paste, comprehend, praise the author.
And there it is, now we have this value. So
what we need to do right now for the second
book, is pass these values as well. But remember,
of course, now I'm looking for the second
object. Now I could technically look for the
first one. But it somewhat doesn't make sense,
since I wouldn't want to be that. So I'm going
to go with IMG. That will be equal to a second
book. And then again, I'm looking for IMG
property. Then the same goes for title when
I'm looking for title. And then I'm looking
for second book under Title. And the last
one, of course, you can probably already guess
we have the author. And then we're looking
for second book, the author. And once I pass
in these values, notice
I have my first instance. All that is beautiful.
And I have a second instance where I'm getting
those unique values. So we can already see
on nicely, we can start creating these lists
where Yes, they all will be displayed the
same way. Because we made sure that when we're
setting up our component power, because we
have something called props, we can start
passing in unique values, where we have prop
name, and either we can hard code here, Mike
We did in the beginning with a string, either
we can set up a variable, or we can set up
objects or arrays or whatever, and then pass
it as a value here as well, since when we
set up curly braces, we're going back to a
JavaScript land, couple of roles, we can call
it whatever we want. But convention is calling
it prompts. One way how to access it is just
by looking in the object that we're getting.
So we'll go with the props, and then whatever
name of the prop. And the last thing is that
if you pass in some Prop, that you're not
looking in a component, nothing will happen.
But if the component is looking for the prop
that you're not passing in, essentially, you'll
just have the empty space, Sharon's component
is going to be looking for the prop. But the
value will be undefined. mostly done. While
we're still on the subject of the prompts.
I also would want to show you two alternative
ways how you can access them. And they all
have to do with the way we destructure properties
from the objects in JavaScript. So if you
need to study up on that, please do so. Because
again, this has nothing to do with react,
it is just a JavaScript. Where if fine now
was that I have this props object. And if
I don't want to repeat myself, where I go
props dot props, dot props dot, I could just
the structure of the properties, where I can
go with cons or what. So in my case, I'm going
to go with cons. And then I'm just going to
signal which properties out one. Now keep
in mind, though, that of course, I still need
access, the same thing that I'm setting up
as a perhaps, in my parameters. So these names
need to match. Otherwise, it's not going to
work. I'm not, I'm just going to say yeah,
I would like to access image, I would like
access title, as well as the author. So I
go with IMG, then the title, and then comma,
the author. And once I have access to each
and every property in my props object. Now
I'm going to select multiple cursors. And
I do that by pressing option, and mouse. And
then of course, I will remove the props, I
don't need them anymore. And as you can see
right now, on accident each and every property,
and everything is still render. So that's
one of the options we can do on Also, if you're
familiar with structuring, you also know that
you can do directly where you're setting up
the function parameters. So here's what I'm
saying right now. I'm saying yes, I will get
a object, I know that my props, of course,
is going to be an object. And I will destructured
here in the parameters instead. So I don't
even need to set it up equal to props. Because
now I'm just saying, Yeah, there will be a
props object, and this props object is going
to have these properties in there. so we can
simply say, IMG, and title and the author.
Now please keep in mind that both of them
are exactly the same. So the result is exactly
the same. These are just the syntaxes that
you'll see around where some people prefer
doing destructuring.
Here, where did you set it equal to an object,
or you can do it directly, where you're setting
up parameters. Again, if you need to jog your
memory, please check object destructuring
in JavaScript, because this is not react Pacific
centrally, this is JavaScript. And if you
are familiar with object destructuring, you're
know that of course, we can destructure even
more nested structures. In here, I'm not going
to create a more complicated example just
to showcase that. But I will just want to
let you know that if you are familiar with
that, that yes, the same rules would apply
more. For example, if in the author, I would
have more properties, essentially, if the
author would be an object, I'll just place
a colon, and then I'll keep on structuring.
And yes, we will do that in some of the later
projects. But for now, just remember that
if you don't want to shut up props object
in your parameter, and then access each property
by typing the props, and then dot and props,
and that you can either destructure them inside
the function body, where you just look for
specific properties that are in the object
and markers, IMG, title and author, or we
can simply destructure the props object in
the function parameters. And while we're still
on the topic of props, I also would like to
talk about the special prop called children.
So this is going to be the case where please
don't name this mama juice. Okay, this is
not the case where, as usual, I say, yeah,
you can name it whatever you'd want chicken,
bake uncle Bobby or whatever. In this case,
the name has to match exactly. Now, what am
I talking about? You see, the children prop
is everything that we render in between the
opening and closing tag off the component.
So for example, for the first or second book,
you can pick whichever you would like, I would
like to add the description. But again, the
gotcha over here is that only one of them
will have that description, not all cars,
evil would want all of them, of course, we
just need to add that property in the object
that I'm looking for the Prop, I set the value,
and I'm good to go. Now, this is going to
be the case where only one of them will have
that description. So I'm going to go with
the first one. But as always, you can pick
whichever you would like. So of course, first,
I would need to change this around where I'm
not going to be self closing, because children
prop will be here, in between my dogs. And
I'm just going to go with a paragraph on I'm
going to use a lorem ipsum. So in Visual Studio
code, you just need to type Lorem. And how
many words you would like sir Marcos, I'm
going to go with 20. Now the moment or run
it, notice how nothing changes, I don't see
any difference. So the paragraph is only for
the first one. But there's no difference on
what is rendered, show how I can access whatever
I place in between. And keep in mind, again,
you can place here, the whole project doesn't
matter. In my case, I just placed one paragraph
with 20 words, but you can place your buttons
you can place your forms, whatever you would
like place to in between the opening and closing
back. Now the better question right now is,
how can I access this. And the thing is, I
already destructured the props object, where
I said that I'm looking for the prop prop
and the author prop. Now the children prop
is on the props object, I can tell you right
away that it is there. So what I could do
is just write comma, and then children now
Don't worry, I will refactor a little bit
later. So essentially, that way, you can definitely
see it. But for now, just look for children.
And the name again here is important. What
you'll notice that since again, we can access
JavaScript can just place children wherever
I would like. So once I run it, notice. Now
of course, everything is displayed correctly,
because this is my paragraph. Now as far as
where you would want to render, it's really
up to you where if I'll move this up, notice.
Now of course, it's going to be above the
author, if I'll move this above the title,
and of course, it's going to be about the
title. Again, the name is very special, erase
children. And in this case, I destructured
right here in function parameters. And then
of course you also accept, so we use the curly
braces, we go back to JavaScript, and then
we access the same name. And then wherever
I'm going to close this in the component,
it will be rendered, meaning we'll place it
in between the opening and a closing tag.
And then where we set up the component, we
can render it anywhere. And where we would
want now mark is of course, I'm going to do
this in the bottom. So now let me rewrite
where I'm not going to destructure everything
and function parameters. Essentially, I'll
go back to props. So I'm going to go back
here to the props. I will comment this out.
So I'm still accessing these values. And of
course, now I would need to go with props,
and then dot children. Now the reason why
I refactor it a little bit, because I clearly
want to show you that of course the props
will be there. So if we go back, and if we
inspect, take a look at the console. Notice
again, I have two objects. So my props object.
However, for the second one, eat has this
children prop. That's why I said the name
is special, or I'm sorry, for the first one.
For the first one, we have children. And the
second one doesn't have that. So of course,
that's why the second one doesn't display
we children. The first one goes. Now CSS specific
thing. For example, if you don't like this
CSS Grid, meaning that both cards right now
are extended, you can simply go back to index
CSS. Where, where you're setting up the grid,
you can say on line items. And we can just
say start on what you'll notice right now
that only the one that has the children, meaning
the paragraph that I want is extended. So
that's up to you. If you like this type of
seriousness matter where each card has its
own height, you can keep it. If you don't
want, of course, don't add it. So for example,
if I comment this out, and of course, notice
how both of them are extended. Now, I will
add a little bit of CSS where I'm going to
say book, and we'll just say margin top, we're
gonna go with, I don't know, porn, firearms,
something like that. Not much in there. And
now, of course, we know how we can work with
a children prop in react, where again, is
going to be content in between the opening
and closing tag, when the name is special,
you need to go with children. So either you
destructured here, function parameters, or
you still keep the name, and then you destruct
the rest of the properties. By the way, please
keep in mind can still do it here as well,
or say, children. And then of course, when
I access, I also need to access children.
I can also do it this way as well. Nice, we're
done. And once we're experts on props. Now
let's focus on our data. Because at the moment
notice, we have first book we have a second
book on life is great. But we are somewhat
repeating ourselves on we were on creating
same component, when I pass in the van, for
example, I will be setting up some children.
And we can already imagine that if we have
list, like they have an Amazon, it would be
somewhat tiresome to keep on repeating the
same stuff. So each and every time we would
need to create a object, then each and every
time, we also would need to set up a component
and then notice how our file is getting bigger
and bigger. So if I have 100 books like this,
it is not very practical. So how we can change
that around is we could set this up as an
array. So we would still have objects, but
they will be in the array. And then we could
iterate over that array. And for each and
every item, display that book. So that way,
we don't have to repeat ourselves. And yes,
again, we will refactor the application. Now
let me just quickly mentioned the reason why
we keep on refactoring because, of course,
we're starting with the most basic example.
And we're slowly building up on that, as we're
building up, yes, we will delete some stuff.
Yes, we will refactor some stuff. for you
guys. That's the only way we can do that.
So our remove my children are time being,
we really don't care about the children run.
Well, of course, we're dealing with children,
we're also will remove them. Now, of course,
you can keep them you want. But since we're
not passing anything, doesn't really make
much sense. I'll also remove averse children
as well. And I guess let's start with our
list. So first, we're have the first book
and second book, I can just simply remove
both variables. So these will become objects.
Now what do we need to do here is simply set
up array, and I'll call this books. So const
is equal to a box. And then of course, let's
enclose both of our objects. And of course,
from here, it's not going to be a semicolon
anymore, it is going to be a comma. Same thing
over here, let's remove that semicolon. Now,
of course, we get bunch of errors. Why? Because
there is no variable anymore. First Book and
second book. And I think it's actually going
to be quite easier. If we just remove the
both books as well. For the time being. Don't
worry, later, of course, we will add it. So
what I would want to showcase First, well
first I want to showcase that
yes, of course we can access this books. Alright.
So in the book list, I'm going to go back
to JavaScript, so I will shut up my curly
braces, and I'll just type books. Now life
is great. But it says over here that objects
are not valid as react child. Okay, what is
happening over here? Well, we have the array
but each and every item in that array is an
object. And react will complain that Listen,
I cannot render the object. Okay, so let's
start out with just an array of strings. So
in here, I'm going to go with const. And the
names. I'll pass in the uragan. So john, man,
Peter, on also, let's set up, Susan. So three
names analysis that Oh, and by the way, the
reason why I showed you this error, because
once in a while you will hit this error, when
essentially, you'll set up a map method that
we'll cover a little bit later. So once you
hit this error, just try to remember that
you're not accessing the proper values. Because
if you have this error of the child where
it is an object, that just means that you
either haven't structured properly, or you're
not acting properly. And now let's start out
with those strange. So now I'm going to go
back to names, and life is awesome. I am displaying
Mirek correctly in react. Now the gotcha here,
of course, is that I'm not wrapping those
names in anything, right now how we can wrap
our JavaScript powers in the HTML. And of
course, in JavaScript, we do that with a map
method. So I can write it here, where I'm
accessing the JavaScript plan, or I can set
up a new variable that is up to me. So I'll
try it with a new variable here. And then
when we work with those books, and of course,
I'll do it right here in the React meaning
in the JSX. So let's call this new name. So
const, new names, and that is equal to A names.
And of course, I'm iterating over this array
using a map method. And now what I would want
is to wrap each and every name in a heading
one, because at the moment, yeah, it's nice,
I can see my list of names. But it's also
somewhat meaningless, because it is not displayed
nicely. So I already know that with map method,
a magazine, each and every name. Now, if you
want to access that, of course, you can just
set up a parameter. So I'm going to say here
name. And then for time being if you want
to console log it, sure console, log the name.
And this is also something that will do a
lot in the course is we will console log it.
Now also console log new name, just so we
can see the result. And once we take a look
at the console, I can see it each and every
time. I'm logging a name. Alright, so my name
is john Peter, and tourism, but my values
come back as undefined. And the reason for
that because I'm not returning anything. So
okay, we have the names, and I can access
each and every name. Why don't we wrap this
in the HTML, meaning, instead of just displaying
what items I have in my array, now, I'd want
to display each and every item wrapped in
a heading one, and the only thing I would
need to do is go with return, then I'll set
up my header one, and then I'll pass in the
name shown here. Of course, if I want to access
that particular variable, I will need to go
with a name, Mark. So that's how I'm acting
right now. So I'm mapping over, and I'm saying,
Yeah, get me the heading one. And then I'm
going back to a JavaScript. Remember, that
was the setup, where essentially, we were
setting up the name. Now, of course, if I
check it out my value, then this will be already
different than I had before. Before that I
had undefined. Now, essentially, you can see
that I'm getting something interesting. Now
that's something interesting is my heading
one. Now what I'm trying to say over here
is, by the way, you know what, I want to rename
this to new names. So if we will go back,
and it will say, new names. You'll see that
now I have john Peter and Susan, don't worry
about this warning, we will fix it. But the
more important part is here, that yes, in
react we can, right away, render that array,
our value array, of course, cannot be objects.
So if you're going to have objects, you will
have some problems and errors and our if it's
just a simple string. Yes, of course, you
can render our is going to make way more sense
if we will wrap those values in something
more meaningful and mysterious. Of course,
that is heading one. But in the next video,
we'll take a look at how we can iterate over
the array as the object, and instead of just
adding one, now I would want to return a component
for each and every item, not a heading one
or Heading Two, or whatever, but the actual
component. Alright, and once we have covered
a simple example, Now, of course, let's iterate
over our books array, access each and every
item, which is a object. So start by removing
the suckers starting from line 2224, I'm also
not going to be looking for the names. And
we're going to go right for the books. So
like I said, we can shut up separately variable,
and then render it here. Or we can iterate
over it in the JSX. Because remember, that
map will return a new array. Sure, now I go
with a map method. And then I would want to
access each and every item in my callback
function correct. And I'll name my parameter
book. Just keep in mind that whatever you
name, this primer, will just point to each
and every object in our iteration. And for
the time being, I'll just return a low, because
I would just want to see how everything is
going to work. So once I returned us, hello,
notice not acceptable. So that one is grayed
out. But I have two routers. Now, why do I
have two routers, because I have two items
in the array. So as I'm iterating with map,
I will always return the amount of items that
I have in the original, right. So if I would
have 2000. Since I'm just returning a low
from this function, I'll have 2000. So now
of course, if I really want to test that out,
I can say well show me that book. And that
book
should be this object, it should be the first
object, second object, okay. And we already
know that, of course, I can either access
those properties, using dot certain, say,
book, dot, author, book, dot image, or whatever.
Or, of course, I can use destructuring. And
here, I'm going to say const. And then what
properties I'm looking for the same ones,
IMG, event title, and the author. Now that
is coming from the book. Now, I'm not going
to console log them anymore. I'm just want
to showcase that here, I can return whatever
I would want. So if I really wanted to, I
could say that there's going to be a div.
Now I'm not going to add an image, but all
the other ones where I'll say, heading three,
for example, with a title. And then heading
six is going to be with an author. So let's
add those two values. And now of course, I
have the name, as well as the author. So I
have these two routers, like I said, I can
return whatever I would want from this map
method. And of course, that will be displayed.
The key, of course, was that we could not
render the object. That's why specifically,
we need to look for those properties. Okay,
good. Now what? Well, if we put two and two
together, I already have the book. Correct?
I already have the component. So in here,
if I can return whatever I want, why don't
we return a book? So what we would need to
do is just change around the div to a book.
And now in a book, of course, the biggest
question is, how do we pass in the props?
Well, I could add them one by one. I could
say IMG is equal to mg titles equals a title.
That is doable, because Please keep in mind
that in a props, I already destructured them.
Correct. I heard the structure, IMG, title
and author. However, there are two other ways
how I can do that. So in this video, I'll
show you the first one. And then in next video,
I'll show you how we can use a spread operator
instead. So instead of passing all of them
here, one by one, I could simply say, all
right, you know, there's going to be a book
prop. And that book prop will be equal to
a book that I'm passing in. So remember, we
were looking for what we were looking for
the object here, correct, sir instead of destructuring,
one by one, IMG, title and author are going
to say I'm going to be passing this object
as a prop Nothing stops me whatever the problem
is going to be that we will get an error here.
Why? Because now props is not simply a object
with IMG title and author is going to be a
object with a book object. So let's see, we're
going to go with props. And like I said, there's
going to be no values here, because we're
not accessing the title. But notice how props
now has the property that is the value. And
then in that object, I see that I have my
properties. So what do we need to do here?
Well, simply, we would just need to set up
props, and then the property that I'm looking
for, what is the property, that is, of course,
a book. So once I do that, now, I only have
this warning about the child, which we will
fix in the next video. However, let's see
the cool thing, where now I'm iterating over
my array, and for each and every object, I'm
returning that book. And what that means is,
for example, I can go and find another book.
So for example, this one, I'm going to go
and I'm going to set up a copy image address.
And here was just make another object. So
copy and paste for the image value. That is,
of course, going to be equal to my new book
ran, of course, we'll also
get the author work show. And I would want
to do the same thing with a title as well.
So copy that value. And of course, I'll pass
it in the title. So now if we navigate to
a bigger screen, check it out. Whatever items
we will have in array. Now, of course, we
are displaying them. And for each and every
item that we have, we're using that book component,
and we set up the map method. Now we don't
need to manually keep on adding this book
component each and every time. And we don't
need to manually keep on adding IMG, title
and author. But what we could do instead is
just grab our book, meaning our parameter,
which will point always back to that item
in the array, which in our case, is the object.
And then of course, where we have the props,
we are just destructuring our in this case,
we're not destructuring, the props, we're
destructuring, the book property. So in this
case, of course, I can just remove this book
altogether, correct. And now of course, I
can see in my console that I have three items.
Why? Well, because now I have three items
in the array. So I guess I can remove this
console log as well. Now we just need to fix
this a little warning about the fact that
each child must have a unique key prop. Excellent
job, we have our list, the only nagging thing
is the fact that we have this warning about
that unique key prop. What is happening here
on how we can fix it. You see later, as we're
progressing with react course, what we would
want to do with lists is, for example, to
remove some items or maybe add the items.
And react wants to keep a track of what we're
adding, what removing. So react is always
in the loop. Now in order to do that, we would
need to set up a special key prop for each
and every item that we're returning. So essentially
each and every time you have a list in react,
you need to add a key prop with a unique value.
Now I can tell right away that in most cases,
we'll be hitting up the API anyway. So there's
always some kind of unique value, whether
or not to support a product, whether that
is for the user, or whatever. However, in
this case, since we are the ones who are setting
up this items, well, of course, I'll need
to add that. So in here, we just need to go
with ID, and then whatever value you'd want,
as long as it is unique. So in my case, I'm
just going to go with ID one, an ID of two,
and then Id of three as well. So copy and
paste an ID of three. So now of course you'll
notice that we have the error because we're
not passing it. Now how I can access that,
well, I could destructured if I had one, correct
her in this case, I think it's just going
to be simple where I go with book and then
ID. Now I don't need to deal with that key,
anything in the actual book. But now you'll
notice that react is not going to complain
anymore, where now everything is fine. As
long as you pass this special prop. Again,
this is not chicken back. This has to be a
key and unique value. Now one thing you will
notice once in a while
where people are adding index because in the
map you can access index, yes, you can technically
do that, in this case, there's going to be
no problem, you can, however, it's going to
be a problem. If you're actually doing something
with a list. Here, my suggestion would be
falling, where, if you know that your list
will never pretty much change here, you won't
be removing the items, or adding them dynamically,
you can technically love the slide and use
the next hour areas a better setup, if you
would always definitely use something unique,
because keep in mind that indexes change as
your array is changing, how are the ID, so
that unique property won't change. Alright.
And the last thing that I would want to talk
about in this video is another way how we
can pass in those props. So one of the ways
was setting up this book as an object Prop,
where I have the book Prop, and then I'm passing
in, of course, this book object. However,
there's also a case where we can use a spread
operator, again, my job is to show you multiple
syntaxes, multiple ways how you can solve
it, it is up to you whichever way you prefer,
if you don't like the spread operator setup,
you don't have to use it however, it is my
favorites. I will use it some more often throughout
the course. So what am I doing over here,
instead of passing this as a object? What
I'm saying is that, I would want to spread
out all the properties. So in year six, we
have spirit operator, where I just go with
dot, dot dump on whatever is the name of the
object. So now what happens when I'm passing
in, I'm not passing anymore this book property
as a object, what I'm passing this in a separate
properties. And in that way, I don't need
to use an a more of a book property altogether,
what I can just say is that I would like to
spread out
all the properties here that are coming from
the book on my property. So what that means,
again, we go back to our previous setup, where
either I'm looking for the props, if I'm destructuring
over here, or keep in mind, I can also do
it in function parameters as well. So yes,
again, some refactoring, some different way
how to solve that. I know it's annoying for
some people. But in general, it is a good
practice to understand that there's multiple
ways how to solve it. And again, it's up to
you to decide whichever method you prefer.
So again, if we will console log props, right
now, you'll see that we are back to that setup,
where props is an object. So not anymore,
this book object that we're passing in, we're
spraying out all the properties that we have
in the book. So once it's back to being an
object, and of course, I can access these
properties one by one, either here, or of
course, we can come this out. And yes, we'll
refactor it one more time where we say, IMG,
title, and the author. Again, both of them
do exactly the same thing. So the result will
be exactly the same. But you will see this
type of syntax in other people's code. So
it's very useful to understand what is happening.
So instead of passing a book as an object,
and then accessing those properties, one by
one, I can say how many properties I have
doesn't matter, just spread them out as props.
And then of course, I can access them. Now,
of course, the names need to match up or I
call this IMG. And, of course, when you're
trying to access them, when you're destructuring
them, that also you will need to have the
same name. My bad, not bad. We now know how
we can run the list of objects, and nicely
wrap it into our component. But the next thing
that I want to talk about is of course, events.
Everything is nice. We have our list. Of course,
what makes applications so appealing is the
fact that we can start responding to user
events, essentially, when user clicks the
button or hovers over the card, or whatever.
Now the problem is that we haven't covered
yet the state. So in our examples, we'll just
deal with console logs when maybe throw in
some alert. Essentially, this is just to give
you a general idea. When we cover state. Then
of course our examples are going to become
more interesting because We will add some
items, we'll remove some items, we'll toggle
some info, and all that good stuff. So this
is just to give you a general overview how
the event will work in react. Now, as a side
note, if you'd like to see all the rents,
because in our examples, we'll just take a
look at the two hours just googling react
events, and then look for this link, the synthetic
event. And then if you keep on scrolling,
notice in react docs, you'll find all the
possible events that react supports. Again,
in our example, we'll just take a look at
two, one on hover, and the second one on Eclipse.
So I'll navigate back to our project. And
we'll work in the book component, what do
we need in order to set up a vent in react?
Now, first of all, we'll need to add the attribute.
So right here attribute, and the second one
is the event handler. Now, the one thing that
is different from the JavaScript is that since
we're setting this up in line, again, we need
to make sure that we're using the camera crash.
So instead of on click, lowercase, like you
would normally write as far as inline JavaScript.
In this case, we need to set this up with
a camel case, which would mean
a man, like I said, in our video, we'll take
a look at the on click event. And the second
one will be on mouse over. But I just showed
you where you can find rest of the events
as well. Now, we set it up. First, I'm going
to create a button. Now, technically, you
don't have to create button for the on click,
course you can catch it 204 and one through
the whole article if you want. But just to
be more correct, I'm going to add a button.
So out here type, say that it will be a button.
And then like I said, in order to set up a
event, we would need to have the entrepreneur.
And since I would want to listen for clicker
runs are simply we'll go with arm CT. And
like I just mentioned, we will need to set
this up as a camel case. So on click, and
then we need to have our handler. Now, I'll
set up multiple examples because we have multiple
options, just so you can see whichever makes
more sense to you. So we can set it up as
a reference. Or we can set it up as a inline
function, how we would set that up as a reference
Well, in here, I could come up with a function.
So it's a click, ler. Man, of course, we are
having our function, man, we just need to
pass it in as a reference. So we have click
handler, and then we pass it here on click.
So our click handler. Now what I would want
to do over here, well, I could just go simply
with our hello world. And you'll see that
first we'll have the button. But of course,
I skipped the name. So let me write here,
reference example, manual, so that I have
my button. Where is the reference example.
And the moment you click it, you have the
Hello World. Beautiful. So we know how we
can respond to the first event, the click
event. So this is going to be a reference
example. But like I just said, we also have
an option of setting this up as a inline function.
Now what that means is that I could simply
place my function here, instead of setting
this up as a reference, how's that gonna look
like? Well, in this case, I think I'm gonna
go with heading one, just so we can spice
things up. Just please keep in mind, of course,
as far as accessibility, that is not the best
case scenario. But let's just go with that.
So we'll have on click that and like I said,
click will become my inline function. And
in here, I'll simply say that I would like
to console log, and I just want to showcase
but of course, within this function, I can
access my variables, my props. For time being,
I'll just go with a title. So once we click
on a title, in a console will should also
see the title. So let's say I'm going to go
with console. Once I click on a title, notice,
now I'm getting that specific title that is
displayed here for each and every book. Of
course, title is unique. And then once we
click on the title, but of course we can see
it in a console log. Please keep in mind that
both of them are doing the same thing right
now. Great. In one case, we have the inline
function that has the functionality. In the
second case, we Have the reference. So now
we're referencing the function. And again,
we have some kind of functionality. So you
can choose whichever option makes sense to
you. Now, the gotcha is going to be when we
would want to pass some kind of value. So
this is going to be later on where, for example,
we would want to delete the item for the list,
we will need to pass the actual ID, so we
know which item to delete. So again, in this
case, we won't delete the item from the list
our, we'll take a look at what happens if
we're passing in that item, because this is
going to be a gotcha. So in here, I'll set
up another button. Also, again, type is equal
to a button will have a on click for time
being, we'll just leave it empty, and also
more complex. Example. Alright, good. So what
if I would have a function, and I'll call
this const and complex example. Again, we're
setting up our function in this function,
I will get the author, I can get the ID, I
can get the title, I can even get the image
if I want to. But let's just imagine that
I would want to console log, this author,
each and every time when I click it. Okay.
Now, what's important, though, that this will
be passed dynamically. It's not like in here
where I have a console log, and then I'm just
accessing the file, we need to imagine that
in this function in a complex example, I'm
looking for as an argument, so say, here,
I will pass in the author. Now, you'll notice
that if I just run my complex example, if
I pass in the author, well, yeah, technically
it will work. But it will work, the moment
I render my application. So the moment I render,
nourish, I run all three of them. So I have
all three orders over here. So why do you
think is that happening? Well, because here,
notice, I invoke this function, I invoke it,
the moment I run my application. And that
is not what I'm looking for. Of course, what
I would want is run it only once I click it.
So here's the thing, if you have this kind
of situation, where you must pass the argument
into the function, you will have to first
set up a arrow function. So here, we'll start
with an N line. And then we can either set
up the curly braces if we want, that's definitely
an option. Or we can simply say, you know
what, once I click run out want to run the
function. Again, that is going to be the case,
if you must pass this into as an argument.
And again, this is going to be for more complex
scenarios, where we'll start passing data,
for example, to the database, or we'll be
removing items. Again, this is not going to
be just with simple console logs. Of course,
at the moment, you can just simply argue,
well, I would write it as an inline function,
there's going to be cases where you cannot
do that. That's why, of course, I'm showing
you this. So now of course, what happens once
I click on More complex example, only then
I arrived, because we need to understand that
once we start up the application, we run our
function or function. And then of course,
we return the complex example. And only then,
once we're clicking, then we invoke our complex
example. Also, I would like to mention that
in all the functions in all our event handlers,
we can access the event object. In this case,
I'll just show you with one with a click handler,
just please understand, of course, you can
access in all of them, where essentially,
we have our event object. And we can do things
we can console log event. And we can also,
for example, go for event target, that's probably
going to be the most useful scenario because
normally you'll use this we inputs a lot,
where we'll be looking for the name, we'll
be looking for the value, and all that good
stuff for the button, we'll just take a look
at what we're working on. So remember, that
was the first one. So once I click, notice
I have my alert here that is beautiful. And
then I have my whole big event. So of course
we can find blotch of useful info here. But
also, I have what I'm clicking on. So that
is my target. This is something that we will
use quite often, especially once we start
working with the input. And the second event
I would want to take a look at is on mouse
over, which essentially occurs when the mouse
pointer is moved on to a element. So I can
set this up anywhere I would like but I think
I'm gonna go with an article just to make
it interesting. So first I'm ordering for
my attribute for mouse over. And then again,
we have the handler. Now in this case, I'll
pass this as inline. However, instead of just
implicitly return like we had before. Now,
of course, notice I'm setting up the curly
braces. And again, I will do some kind of
functionality over here. This is just the
showcase that regardless whether you go with
implicit return, or you're setting up the
curly braces, it will work. So we have our
mouse over beautiful. And we're going to go
with some kind of function.
I don't know, I'm just gonna go with console
log. And I would like to console log, I guess
we have been console logging the author, why
don't we console log the battle, because I'm
still access that specific title for each
and every component. So now what happens as
I hover over a moment, my mouse moves on to
the element. Now, of course, I'm console logging
the title of the book for each and every time
I do that, notice how I increase the amount
in the console. So if I'll move my mouse on
to a different arm, but of course, I will
console log, that particular title. So that's
how we can work with events. So essentially,
those are the basics of how we can listen
for events in react. Alright, once we're successfully
done, we'll get to react basics. But before
we move on to more interesting and advanced
react topics, I would like to cover import
and export statement. Now, let me tell you
right away that imports and exports are not
react specific. In fact, they are your six
modules. So think JavaScript. And the reason
why I would want to cover them now is because
we will rely heavily on them throughout the
remaining of the course, as well as the project.
And essentially Yes, six modules or ability
to import and export our code allows us to
split up our app into small chunks, which
of course makes it easier to manage it. In
general, there are two flavors named and default
exports. And even though there are a few more
variations for both of them, for now, we'll
just cover the most straightforward setup.
So as we're looking at our app, everything
is beautiful. But don't you think that our
index js is getting quite big. And we need
to keep in mind at the moment, we literally
have only three cards with some books. Of
course, normally, you have way more functionality
than that. So wouldn't make sense to start
splitting up our functionality into separate
files. Because that way, of course, we can
manage it way easier. So here's what I'm talking
about, I'm going to open up the sidebar, in
the source, I would like to create two new
files. So one is going to be called books.
js, this is where I would want to store my
books. And the other one is going to be book
js. And this is of course, where I would want
to store my component. So my book component,
let's create this file, so a new file. And
then I'm going for books, j s, this is where
I'll store my data. And then I'll have another
one new file. And then I'm looking for this
book, man, j s. Now what I would want to do
right now is head back to index j s, and grab
my books. Alright, so let's keep on scrolling.
And just got it out. And then of course, we
navigate to books, just copy and paste. Now
everything is beautiful. But of course in
the index js, where we have the book list,
of course, we are not anymore accessing the
books. So how we can fix that, well, in the
box j s, we would need to go for the named
export. Again, there are two flavors, and
you can use them however you like. Meaning
we could have set this up as default export
as well. But I'm going to show you the named
export movie as a box. And then with a book.
So with the component, I will show you the
default export. So we go here we use export.
So that is a key word. And then of course
we go with let or const and then whatever
we would want to export. So that's going to
be most straightforward setup. Like I said,
there are a few flavors. So essentially, there
are a few other ways how we can write the
same thing. Again, the idea won't change,
we're still exporting this box array. But
there are a few more variations how we can
do that. But for now we'll just stick with
the most straightforward one, where we go
with export and whatever we would want to
export. So now of course in the index JS What
I want is to import and similarly like we
imported the index CSS. Now of course I'm
looking for that particular right, now it's
going to be a little bit different where I'm
going for the import statement. Then since
it is a named import, or named export, I would
need to go with curly braces. And then the
name for the named export needs to match exactly.
So if this is Bugs Bunny, make sure that in
the index js, you're also targeting the same
name. So in my case, I need to go for books.
So go for books, and that is coming from.
And now we go with relative path. So notice
something interesting. We're not importing
from the package, like we did with react,
which of course, was coming for our node module.
And like I mentioned back then, since it is
not coming from the node modules, now we need
to set up a path. So in this case, since it
was coming from node modules, we didn't care,
we just said, Hey, get me this one from this
package. However, in this case, we need to
have a relative path. But since the box is
in the same folder, I just go with that, then
forward slash, and then I'm looking forward
to file and I go here with books. Now, since
it is a js file, we don't need to have the
extension. Previously, remember, when we work
with CSS, we needed to have the CSS extension.
with JavaScript, we don't have to do that.
So if it is a JavaScript file, excellent.
We just keep on moving on. So now we save
it. Okay, beautiful. And notice how our app
still works. So everything works as expected.
Now, of course, like I said, he file, for
example, set this up as data. And I'll save
it notice, it will say, well, books is not
defined. So now of course, since I named this
data, also where I'm using it, of course,
I would need to rename it as the however,
it says import error data is not exported
from books. So if you're changing something
around, like I said, this is a named export.
So for example, you need to access exactly
the same name. So in here a maximum data however,
React is complaining here, listen, you're
not
exporting data. So if that is the case, of
course, we can just change it. So that is
up to you. This is just to showcase that,
of course, names need to match exactly. So
once we have this particular setup, everything
is beautiful. And now let's focus on the default
one. Now before we set up our components,
let me just show you the extension, like I
mentioned previously, where we have the reacts,
numbered. So for example, if we create this
component in if I go with a snippet of our
a FZE, are right away have my component. And
this is going to be the case where it will
always match the name of that particular file.
So in this case, notice it is named book j
s. So that's why right away my component is
book chairs. And again, there are multiple
flavors. But this is the most basic one, where
we import react from react, of course, we
need to do that, since we're setting up the
component. And as far as default export, we
go with export. But then we have this default,
and then whatever we would want export as
default. Now surely the differences between
the two in a second, but just keep in mind
that of course, again, these names need to
match. So if you're setting up your function,
your component, name and book, if you want
to export as default, of course, you would
need to use the same name. And also keep in
mind that you can have only one, only one
default export per file, meaning you can set
up more named exports from this particular
file from book js. But as far as default,
you can have only one. Now what I would want
in this book JS component, once had back to
measures. And then of course, this is my component,
correct. So what I could do is just keep on
scrolling, keep on scrolling, crowded out.
And we can just remove the empty function
that we currently have in the book, component,
and then copy and paste. And now of course,
everything works awesome. So everything is
displayed exactly like we wanted. And now
in the index, again, we would need to import
show the difference between named and default
exports is the fact that now I can name it,
whatever I want. Shown here. If I go with
import, if I'll call this book, and then from
an angle again, we're looking for relative
path. We're looking for book js, everything
will work as expected. So now when we save
notice here is running like nothing happened.
Okay? So once all that is running, now, once
everything is in place, then of course, we
can just take a look what happens. If, for
example, I change this name. So I have import
book from the book. Like I said, this is a
default export. So what that means is, I don't
need to look for a specific name. So if I'll
change this around, and if I'll call this
specific book, then of course, the only thing
I need to do is change where I call it. So
notice here I have my book. So if I'll just
call this specific book, you'll notice that
everything will still work. So even though
I renamed it and from the book jers. On exporting
the book, everything works as expected, because
it is a default export. And I can rename it
however I would want. So in here, I renamed
it to a specific book that is coming from
the book js file. And then of course, the
only thing I need to do is just remember,
what is the name I gave. So if this was specific
book, of course, I need access to the same
name. And then let me just show you the relative
path from a different folder. Because once
in a while, of course, we will use that throughout
the course, where I'm just going to create
a new folder. I'll say, testing here. And
within this folder, let's just come up with
a file of testing a j s, and let's export
as default, and also export. Let and we'll
call this hello world.
So greeting greeting. And that is going to
be hello world. Cheryl in any of the files
now, we can exporters' our Of course, relative
path will change because now we need to go
one level up into testing. And then look for
this testing j s file. Again, it's not going
to do anything however, I just want to showcase
in the index j s, where if I go with import,
remember the name was greeting. And we're
export it as a named import. So we go here
with a greeting. And that is coming from.
So now we're looking into the testing testing
folder. And then we're looking for the testing
file. So testing js. And now of course anywhere
where I would want I can just for example
console login. So I go with console, log and
then greeting. And of course, once I open
this up, I will notice that in my console,
I should have the hello world. And of course
I do notice the line 12 is hello world. So
everything works as expected. Like I said,
it is not a react thing. It is iOS six modules.
Man. If you have covered iOS six module before
you are in good shape. However, we will heavily
rely on this functionality, because it will
just allow us to set up our applications in
a more manageable way. We're notice now I
have my index JS in the index js, I only have
the book list. So that is my component. And
then I'm getting the specific pieces of data
where all the books, whether that is specific
component, or whether that is some other functionality,
in this case HelloWorld. And as you can see,
it is much more easier to manage arap where
we split up our data into multiple files.
So those are the basics, how we can use import,
export statements in create react app. And
the last thing that I would want to cover
in react and basic section is how we can host
our application on the internet. So how we
can move the sucker from localhost 3000 to
some kind of URL that we can share with our
friends or family or anyone that would be
interested in our project. Because of course,
it is kind of hard to do with our localhost
3000 correct. Now, there are many hosting
providers out there. But for this specific
one, I picked netlify because it is very easy
to set up and you will have your application
online in no time. Now you can sign up for
free, so they will not ask for your credit
card. So keep that in mind. You're in good
shape. Online. Once you sign up for account.
Of course you'll have ability to log in, which
is exactly what I'm allowed to do. And then
once you log in, if you keep on scrolling,
keep on scrolling, you have this option of
just drag and drop. Now Later, we'll take
a look at the continuous deployment option
that is through the gate. However, in this
case, we'll just cover the simple drag and
drop essentially These are just the project
that I'm already hosting, on nullify. So if
you just sign up for an account, of course,
this part will be empty. So if you'll go with
continuous deployment with git, which we'll
do later, then you'll use this option new
site from GitHub, or in our case, like I said,
we'll keep on scrolling. And we're looking
for this one to deploy in your site, without
connecting to get drag and drop your site
folder here. Now, before we can do anything,
remember, we have this option of NPM, run
build. So that sets up our production build.
So instead of running NPM, start, which spins
up the dev server, now we need to go with
NPM. Run, build. And once we run this command,
of course, our production build, the one that
we can host online, is being created. And
once it's done, it's going to be available
in the build folder. So that's the folder
that we will
drag and drop in. And of course, once it's
done, notice, it says that everything is good
to go, the bill folder is already to be deployed.
Now we either can run serve, and that will
just show what do we have locally. But of
course, that's not the option we're looking
for, I would want to see how it's going to
look online using natla phi. So of course,
in this case, what I'm doing here, by the
way, let me close my bunch of windows on what
I would want is, of course, everything is
saved up over here. And what I would want
is to open this sucker up, I have my build,
and I'm looking for this build folder. Like
I said, we'll just drag and drop. So grab
the build folder, and just drag and drop over
here that I know maximize my window again,
it's gonna give you this interesting name.
And at the end, you'll notice this netlify
that now of course, eventually, you can have
a custom name. So if you have or even domain,
you can connect to nullify. But for our purposes,
we'll just use this option, where essentially
there's going to be this netlify dot app.
So we're looking for Site Settings. If we're
on version nine, we go for change site name,
and then you can come up with whatever name
you would want. So I'm going to go with react
tutorial, or basics, tutorial, basics, tutorial,
and then 2020. That's the name I chose. Of
course, if you'll go with some type of name
that is already used, of course, it's not
going to be available. So it will complain.
But in my case, I think I'm going to be good
to go. So of course, that is my site. So now
what I would want is either go to overview,
and then just click on this URL. And you'll
notice that this is our project. And now it
is successfully running online, where you
can share it with your friends and your family.
Essentially, all the projects that you create,
you can host it with notify within a matter
of seconds. Again, you'd sign up for a free
account. And I'm gonna ask you for your credit
card. And what you could do is just use the
drag and drop option where you run NPM, run
build first, then drag and drop. And then
of course, you have your Project Online within
a matter of seconds. Nicely done. Hopefully
we're familiar with react basics. And I think
this is a perfect time to dive into more interesting
and more complex react topics. Now, when it
comes to advanced react, a lot of our attention
will be spent on something called hooks. And
by the way, you can see that by just looking
at the names of our upcoming topics, if it
has the name use in it. So use state use effect.
And along those lines, that just means that
it is certain react hook, we will talk about.
So why hooks, you see if all we have is a
component with some static data, or a component
with a list, life is great. But once we want
to make our components dynamic, and more complex,
and of course, as a result, also our app,
we will need to use react hooks, which are
functions react provides to help us to complete
various tasks. For example, adding removing
the items from the list, toggling the modal
and fetching the data, just to name a few.
There are quite a few hooks out there, but
I can honestly say that if you understand
only two of them, use state and use effect,
you will be already an extremely good shape.
That's why we'll cover them first of the most
number of examples on them. And we'll keep
on using them, even if the main topic of the
lecture will be some other hook, or different
subjects. As we'll be approaching the end
of the section, you might find some repetition.
But it was done on purpose only because I
definitely would want you to be familiar with
those two hooks. So you state and use effect.
And my experience when it comes to learning,
important stuff is well worth repeating. Now,
even though react hooks will be the main focus
of this upcoming section, we will cover other
useful topics as well, like conditional rendering
forms in react, prop drilling context API,
as well as react router, all included. So
by the end of the section, you can easily
build cool and complex react apps. In order
to follow along with the upcoming part of
the video, you'll need a starter project,
I provide a link at john smith.com. So bravely
navigate to John's milk without calm, and
then look for the videos page. And in the
videos page, of course, we are looking for
react. So click on that page. And, of course,
at this point, I haven't uploaded the video.
So that's why for me, I can see the JavaScript
but by the time you'll be watching this, of
course, there's going to be a big massive
react logo. And then you're looking for this
source code link, click on that. This is going
to direct you to my GitHub, more specifically
react advanced 2020 repo. And once you get
there, you're in good shape. Once we have
a good idea of what we're going to cover next
hour want to start by getting the starter
project. So just follow the link of that I
provided. You can either download zip fork
or clone. And I think I'm going to go with
clone option, I'm going to navigate back to
my desktop. I'll zoom in just so you can see.
So of course I'm in Terminal now navigating
to a desktop, and I'm gonna run git clone.
And of course, now I have my repo run, I'll
open up the Visual Studio code, drag and drop.
Now my preference is right away, set it side
by side with a browser. But of course, that
is up to you. I'll also have one bigger browser
window open as well. So in this case, I'm
going to go with new window and offset side
by side with my texts that are sure I'll have
browser on a small screen, of course, and
also, the big one, as well run in the Visual
Studio code, first we will need to do is install
the dependencies. So we're going to go here
with NPM and install amount. All right aware
on the command of NPM start, which obviously,
we'll spin up the dev server on localhost
3000. And once the dependencies have been
installed, also, once the dev server is running,
run, I'll just open up localhost 3000, small
screen, as well as the big one. So let me
open up one more browser window. So this is
going to be a big browser window, of course.
And at the moment, of course, there's going
to be nothing there on localhost 3000, because
their server is not running yet. And once
the dev server is up and running, you should
see your screen advanced react. And same thing
should be on a small browser window. Again,
the URL is localhost 3000. And then at this
point, I think I'm going to close the integrated
terminal. And I'll start by giving you a overview
of our project, just so we all are on the
same page. As far as the store, a lot of things
should look very familiar, since I use the
same create react app boilerplate we used
in the previous section. So remember, previously,
when we run, create react app, online, we
created our first project. Well, essentially,
I did the same thing. But of course, I removed
and added some files in this case. Now when
it comes to upcoming lectures in order not
to waste your time, I already prepared all
the necessary boilerplate. So we just need
to focus on functionality. And the same goes
for styles, even though we are not going to
use that much CSS. Since at the end of the
day, it is still tutorial, I did prepare on
CSS for you though, you just need to include
classes and you'll be good to go. I also provided
the complete source code so that way you can
right away compare it with your results so
you don't have to run around and see where
there are you right away can look in the final
folder and you'll be in good shape now As
far as the files and folders, like I said,
a lot of things should be very familiar, where
we have the public. And of course, we have
the source. Now we will do all our work in
the source folder. Now the difference, remember
in the previous section, we worked in the
image. Now, in this case, what happens with
a boilerplate, they right away set up index
j s, as a place where they import app component.
And then remember that document get element
by ID, where essentially, we are placing all
our functionality into that route there. While
they're doing that by just placing that
app component. And I just left it the way
it is. Because that way, once you start a
brand new application, we have create react
app, you're not going to be confused. Just
remember, it is the same thing. Previously,
we just set up our components in the index
j s. In this case, what they're doing is they
create everything in the app address, meaning
all the components meet in the app js file,
run the export as default. Remember, by the
end of the tutorial, we talked about exporting
and importing, in the image j s, very import
app up and just place it over here. Now as
far as this reacts, Rick, no, don't worry
about it. This is just for create react app
purposes. Now in the objects, if you just
want to simply test that out, we can change
on return. And we can say here Heading Two,
and let's say advanced, advanced react tutorial.
And like I said, the idea is exactly the same.
All we had in the previous section. The difference,
of course, previously, we placed our components
right here next to the render method. In this
case, they have this app. So the root component
where all of our components were made, and
then they just run through it. Now when it
comes to CSS, like I said, I already prepared
even though there's not that much CSS already
prepared a little bit of global styling, some
fonts and all that good stuff. So if you're
interested, of course, be my guest, you can
come here and check it out what kind of styling
are added. Now the most important thing is
the tutorial folder. So in dorial folder,
you'll see a bunch of folders, starting with
one on non hyphen use, sir, what that means
is that it's going to be our first topic.
And then for each topic, we will have two
folders, we'll have the setup folder. So this
is where we'll do all of our work. Like I
said, I also provided right away a complete
source code. So that way, if you don't get
the result that you're looking for more than
just right away, navigate to a final folder,
look for the same exact file we're working
on. You'll get your answer. Now in the next
video, I'll show you how we'll be doing importing
and how you can right away, check out the
final. The one thing that I would want to
mention, though, is that I saved up on the
boilerplate, where you will notice that in
all the setup files, right away have the component.
Now I'm also right away exporting as default.
And I'll talk about it in more detail in the
next video. But the idea is that we don't
need to create each and every time the file
and the component and all that annoying stuff.
Instead, everything is already right away
prepared for you, then you'll just have to
import that particular file in the app js.
And then just follow along and do all of your
work in this file. So that way we can focus
on functionality instead of unnecessary boilerplate.
And that is the brief overview on start application.
And I think we're ready to kick things into
gear. And finally, learn some advanced react.
Nice. And once we're familiar with a setup
course, of course, we'll start by looking
at the use state hook. Since like I just mentioned,
the use that as well as users are going to
be most used hooks. However, before we do
anything, let me just showcase why we would
want to use use state in the first place.
Now this is going to be a basic example. Please
understand that course, you state can do way
way more than that. But I think it's going
to give you a good idea why using use state
hook is necessary as our applications get
bigger and more complicated. So the file that
we're looking For years going to be located
in tutorial folder, a man we're looking for
US state. And then we have the final one.
So that is going to be our complete code.
And then we have the setup one. So this is
where we'll do our work on the file we're
looking for is this error example, j s. Now,
first, what I would want in the app j. s,
though, is set up the container.
Now, why do I want to have a container, because
it's just gonna have a little bit of styling.
If you navigate to index CSS, you'll notice
the container class, I just added a little
bit of styling. So I'll add that container
for all my examples. Just please keep in mind,
it doesn't affect the functionality, it just
affects how the examples are going to look
like. So if I navigate back to jazz, I'm going
to wrap all my examples into this container.
So what I would want right now is where we
have the return, we're just going to go with
dev within us there for the time being just
to showcase that nothing will change our place
the setting to so let me move up the syringe
here. Now, of course, I need to set up a proper
return, and all that I don't want. So I do
notice, like I said, equal just this class
name of container, we'll get a little bit
of styling. So essentially, I'll place all
our examples in that container. So that way,
it's just going to look a little bit better.
And then in order to work with our files,
we're looking for this error example, chairs.
Now all of them have been set up as default.
So we can name them whatever we would want.
Now in my case, I named them explicitly what
we're covering in that particular video. For
example, if this is our example, I went with
explicit name. Now, of course, if you want,
you can shorten this up in the objects. That
is up to you. And Marcus, I'll call all of
them setup, meaning as we move from lecture
to lecture, I'll keep this name off setup.
And the only thing that will change is the
file where I'm getting the component. So in
this case, of course, I'm looking into the
Oreo folder, when I'm navigating to use state.
And then I'm looking forward to setup. Like
I said, I'm, I'm looking for the error example.
So that's the component I would want to work
in. That's why I'm importing into address.
And then I'll just place it in the container.
So I have my setup. And I'm good to go.
So what you should see on the screen is this
text of use state, or example, if you see
that VAT is awesome, because that is the file
that we will work in. Now if that is not the
text that you see, then of course, make sure
that your import errors correct. Like I just
mentioned already 30,000 times, if you want
to see complete code, you're looking in the
same folder in the US state however, you're
looking for the final folder, an error, example
address. So the filenames will be exactly
the same. The difference, of course, is that
in here, you can see the complete code. So
for example, in the app j s, if you'd want
to see the complete code, what you could do
is simply go with import, again, whatever
name because it is default. So in my case,
I'll call this final from online. Again, we're
looking forward to dorial, then I'm looking
for US state, and I'm looking for final, and
then our example. So right below the setup,
I'm going to go with my final, and you'll
see the complete code. Okay, so this is what
we will build in this project. Now the reason
why I'm showing you that because that is going
to be our setup for the remainder of the advanced
tutorial videos, where essentially, you'll
have one setup file, and then the final one,
where you can see the complete code. So if
you ever want to run more, I have built that
of course, just import the final. So that
is going to be coming from the final folder.
But the files that we're going to be working
are going to be coming from the setup. So
hopefully this is clear. So I can remove my
final. And finally we can start working in
our file in the urges. So let me navigate
there, the error example now of course, notice
this is the complete one. Now that's not the
one that I want. I want our example just where
adjust have the use state or example. And
what I would want to build over here. Well,
I would just want to set up some kind of logic
where once we press on button, we would change
the name. So what am I talking about? Well,
here, I could go with let title. So some kind
of variable, I'll call this random barrel.
And then where are my JSX, I would want to
have some kind of return. So in this case,
what I'm going to do is use the React fragment.
Again, I just don't want to create this div
soup. So I'm going to go with react dot and
then fragment. And then when this fragment,
let's go with Heading Two, and I'll look for
my title. Remember, in JSX, we needed to use
the curly braces in order to access the variable.
And of course, once I do, I have my random
title, beautiful. Life is great. But what
if I were to add a button, so I'm going to
go here with button, type of button, as well
as add a class name. Now this class is coming
from my index CSS. Again, if you want, you
can check it over here. And it just adds a
little bit of styling. And the class we're
looking for is btn. And let's set up a on
click handler. And of course, we'll have to
set up a function. So call this handle click
function within the button, I don't know what's
called this change title. Let's say right,
now, there's going to be an error because
of course, we haven't created a handle quick.
So let's do that. So const handle, click Movado
is my function. Beautiful. Now what I would
want is to change this title from random people
to something else, my first legitimacy with
a weakened x as the title. Of course, I'll
open up my console. Let's see, what do we
have in a console? Once I click Change, that'll,
of course, I can access the random title.
However, the idea was that once I click, I
would want to change it to something else,
I would want to change it to Hello people.
So let's try whether we can do that. I'm going
to go here with that all
and learn Hello, people. Now my question to
you is, once we click the button, the handle
click, do you think the random title will
be updated? In my component? Again, the question
is, once we click the button, notice, I'm
changing the title. So do you think we will
change also the value that we have in the
JSX? Well, let's try it out. We have random
title, or click on Change title, and nothing
happens. And what's even more interesting
that technically, you can see in a console
that we change this value, correct. Because
in here it is title and it is random title.
And of course we change it to help people
now once we console log, it is Hello people.
Now the problem is that we are not re rendering
the component. So we change the value. And
we're not re rendering the component. That's
the reason why we cannot see any changes.
Now the second thing is that we have no way
to preserve this value in between the renders
as well. So essentially, we would want two
things, we would want to keep the value between
the renders. But also we would want to trigger
that rerender versus where the use state hook
comes into play, where it will allow us to
do just that. Again, very basic example. Of
course, you can use use state for more on
that. But this clearly shows us why we would
want to use the use state in the first place.
Alright, and once we have covered why would
want to use US state. Now of course, let's
learn the basics about the use state. And
here's what we're going to build me just quickly
show you we're going to go with import. Again,
I'll call this final from online, we're looking
forward tutorial folder. When you state final,
online use state basics. Now since I named
the final Of course, right after the setup,
I can just go with final, close that out.
This is going to be our component, we have
random title. And then notice how once we
start using your state, not only we can change
the value and trigger a rerender, but we can
also preserve the value in between the renders.
Again, this is just to showcase that you can
always take a look at what we're going to
build but of course the file that we're looking
for is a bit different. Again, I will still
call this setup because it's just easy However,
I'll change the path where I'm looking for
a setup folder. Van. Instead of folder, I'm
looking for US state basics component, or
file. And of course, you should see on the
screen use state basic example. And let me
open up the sidebar, I'm going to navigate
over. And essentially use state is a function.
It is a function that is coming from rear
however, notice that it is a named import.
So unlike react, this is a named one. So we
must, must, must must, must have the curly
braces. And the name needs to be exact, where
we go with us state. Now just to prove that
use there is a function, we simply console
log, and we write us state. And you can clearly
see that it is a function beautiful. So once
that is clear, once we know that you state
is a function. Now let's see what this function
returns. Because that is very, very important.
Shown here, I'll just invoke it. And you'll
notice something interesting, where it returns
an array. And first thing is going to be undefined.
And essentially, this is going to be the state
value that we're going to use. And the second
one is a function. Now this function will
control this value. Now you're probably wondering,
okay, well why this is undefined? Well, because
when we invoke use state, we need to pass
in default value. Now keep in mind, this value
can be a string, it could be a number can
be an array, it can be an object can be Boolean,
whatever JavaScript value you'd want. So for
example, if I'll pass here, HelloWorld, what
you'll see that our value now is a string.
So that is my default value. And then again,
we have this function.
And
from this point, we have multiple ways how
we can access that. Just keep in mind, if
use state returns an array, of course, we
can assign it to a variable, correct. So in
here, I could go with const, and then value
is equal to my use state again, we will need
to pass in some kind of default value. So
for now, I'll just passing number, just so
you can see that of course, we can pass in
a number as well. And then in order to access
the first item in the array, we would go with
square brackets, and then the zero. Now let
me copy and paste in here, I'll set up my
function, since that is going to be the second
thing that I'm looking for. So I'm going to
be looking for the handler. And of course,
I'll change this value as well, we're now
I'm looking for my function for the second
item from my array. If we'll console log,
if we go for example, we have a value and
handler, you'll notice that the value will
be one. And the second value will be that
function. The function of that controls this
novel understand that the moment it might
be a little bit confusing, don't worry, just
remember to this handler will be the function
that controls the value that we have in our
state. So in this case, of course, this is
one. In our first example, this was HelloWorld.
Now all of this is beautiful. But what I would
want is to select all of these and then just
comment them out, just so you can say for
reference. If you remember, we had array destructuring.
Now what that allows us to do is set up everything
in one line, where I'm going to go with cons,
and then I would need to come up with a name
for my state value. So this name could be
anything, I will name this text, just keep
in mind, you can name this Bobby, you can
name this apple, banana, whatever you would
want. So I'll name my first value, text. So
that of course will be my state value. And
the second thing is my function. So now of
course I need to name that function. Now a
common convention is using set wherever you
name your variable. So if you've named your
state value, for example, text, then you go
set text. If you'd set this up as Apple, you
go to Apple, and then set apple. Now again,
this is a convention, you can name this taco
and burrito, it doesn't matter. And then for
destruction rules, you need to set it equal
to your array. Now of course our array is
coming from us
Alright, then we need to invoke it. And then
we need to pass in whatever, again is going
to be our default value. Now what is going
to be our default value? Well, there will
be that random battle. And once we have this
setup, now let's try it out in our return.
Again, we'll have our JSX. Of course, again,
I'll go with react fragment, just so we can
keep on practicing. And then in here, let's
use the heading one instead. And I'll look
for my text. So that is my state value. And
just to showcase that we can place whatever
we would want, or here, I can just change
it around to a one or 10 or 109, something
like that. And then of course, this value
will be displayed. Just keep that in mind
that whatever value you'd want as default
on, you can set it up with a rather than array,
whether that is an object, string number,
Boolean, whatever. And of course, once I have
these two things, now we will need to come
up with the button correct, or the button
that can change this value. Because we saw
previously how we were not able to give up,
reverse, let's come up with that button.
In here, I'll add a class name, we'll say
btn. Just so we have a little bit of styling,
and we'll do the same way how we'll have a
unclick. And we'll pass in handle.
Click now within the button. Alright, change
arrow, Mark show. And again, there's going
to be an error where handle click is not defined.
Now, of course, let's set it up, we're going
to go with handle click
on probably add const over here, and then
we'll pass in our function.
In this function, now we'll finally use this
set text. Word works, we have multiple ways
how we can do that, how we can pass the new
value. And a little bit later on, we'll look
at the functional example. But for the time
being, let me just go with text. And then
whatever we'll pass it in here, now will be
our new route. So for example, if I want to
change this around to a Hello World, I just
need to pass in that string, where if I'll
say hello world. Now what you'll notice that
once we click on Change title,
of course, we invoke the handle click, and
then in click, we have our set text function.
So the function that we're getting back from
the use state, we get back that function,
and then each and every time we invoke this
function, we can change this value. So there
it is, once I click notice, now nicely, I
see my hello world. Now of course, since I
don't have any more logic, than every time,
we'll click after that is just going to be
this HelloWorld. But at least we already made
good progress, correct, because previously,
we were not able to do that. Now, of course
we are where once we click on a button, we
change this, again, we can refresh, we have
random title. And once we click that, of course,
it is going to be a Hello World. Now just
to showcase that we can set it up as always,
to whatever we would want, just like with
the default one. If I'll go to 109, you will
see that I have ramped idle mode when I click
the button, of course I have 109. All right.
Hopefully that is clear. And now let me just
set up a little bit of if and else statements,
where essentially, depending on whatever value
I already have, I'm going to set my new value
using set x. And the way I can do that is
I can say if and then I'll check what is the
value for the text. If it is random, and Pyro,
then of course, I would want to invoke set
text. And I would want to set it equal to
a Hello World. However, if that is not the
case, essentially, if it is already HelloWorld
well, then I will just set it back to a random
one. So go set text, plan, random, and then
title. So now you'll notice that we'll have
this toggling functionality, where I'm changing
the title. Now of course it is going to change
to hello world beautiful. We trigger rerender
and then of course again once we click we
have random title, awesome. This is how we
can use the use that again it is a function
that we get from react. Once we invoke the
function, we would need to pass in default
value, whatever route one as far as string,
number, Boolean or object or array.
And then from this function, once we invoke
it, we get an array with two values, we use
array destructuring, because it is just faster.
However, we can also do this manually,
where we get that particular value, and the
function of that controls that value. And
each and every time we'll invoke this function,
whatever value we'll pass in, now will be
that new state value. And of course, in order
to access it, just like with normal variables,
we just go with whatever name we passed here.
Again, please keep in mind, you can name these
things however you'd want. But a common practice
is using set, and then whatever name of the
value that you already set it up. And then
of course, each and every time we click the
button, notice how we invoke our set text.
And we keep on changing this state value.
Beautiful. And those are the basics of use
state hook in react. And before we cover more
complicated use state examples, let me just
cover some things that relate to all hooks.
So this will also relate to all the other
hooks we'll learn later. First, we need to
remember as far as hooks, vary, we'll start
with this use, whether that is use effect,
you state, use callback, use memo, or whatever.
So you always see this use not also applies
to whatever hooks we'll create ourselves later
on, we must use this use in the beginning,
run the components where we invoke those hooks
must be the application. So let me show you
the example. If for example, I'll change this
to a state basics.
This is going to be with lowercase, we will
see a big fat error here in order to use hook,
whether it is your state use effect, or whatever
the component needs to be obligation. That
is a small gotcha. But a small gotcha, that
can catch up with you in very random times.
Now, also, the hook needs to be in the function
or component body. For example, if you're
moving this outside, it's not going to work
again, there's going to be a big fat error,
because you need to invoke the hook, again,
with our errors use state or whichever hook
you'd want, it needs to be invoked in the
function body. And the last thing is something
that we'll take a look at later. And that
is that we cannot call the hook conditionally.
And I'll show you that would use the fact
because it's just going to make a little bit
more sense. Now keep in mind, I'm not talking
about the function that we're getting back
from the phone. Because of course, in this
case, yes, we're calling this conditionally
where I'm checking the state value. And when
I'm saying all right, so if the state value
is equal to a random data, then I'll invoke
my handler function. Keep in mind, I'm not
talking about this function. Yes, this function
you can call conditionally. However, what
I'm talking about is the fact that I cannot
just say, EFF, man, some kind of hook inside
of that is not going to work. And it's going
to be easier for me to share with us the fact
because there's going to be a proper example.
Again, this applies to all the custom hooks,
we're going to create ourselves, as well as
all the hooks that you can use from react,
whether that use the fact use callback, you
state or all the other hooks. So that was
one. Now let's take a look at a more interesting
example, where our default value or state
value will be an array. And essentially, we'll
be able to add the items will be able to remove
the items, as well as clear the state value
back to an empty array.
In order to see what we're going to create.
I'm going to change of course, my file, so
I'll use a different path right now. I'll
go for setup, then I'm looking for US state
and then array. And what you should see in
a browser is used state array, an example.
Now let's navigate in there to that particular
file. So what we're looking for is use state
array address and again, it is located in
the setup. Now in this case, though, I'll
change this around and instead of importing
as a named export, I can show you that we
also have another option, where again, our
need to come up with those two values. Our
our we'll call them
So in my case, it is going to be people. So
that is going to be my array. And then the
function will be called serve people. So these
two things I need regardless, online in order
to invoke use state, instead of importing,
which is always an option, we can also do
something like this is where we go with react,
and then use
state. And like I said, this is where we pass
in that default route. So for example, as
far as the row, we could go with empty array.
So these are two ways how we can set up either
your import, or you go with react dot, and
then you state, please keep in mind, both
of them do exactly the same thing. And that
really depends on your preference. In my case,
if I know that, I will use it just once, most
of the time, I'm just lazy and I go with react,
and then you state how if I know that I only
walk it quite a few times in my component,
then of course, I just go with import, and
then use use state or whichever hook name
I pick,
that just saves me a little bit of typing.
Again, that is up to you. So for the time
being, we just have the empty array, which
is somewhat okay. But we remember that we
can pass whatever we want. Now, if you'll
take a look at the source folder, you'll find
data j s. Now in the data address, we have
an array. And I named this data. And then
in here we have an array of objects, where
we have the ID remember, we needed to do that,
if we're rendering the list, there has to
be some kind of unique ID. And then we just
have the name, and then value. So john, Peter,
Susan, an honor. So what I would want to do
right now and use theta Ray, I already imported
the data. So notice the path, I'm looking
forward data. And then I need to go quite
a few levels up, and then look for that there.
So I leave one folder second, and third. And
then eventually, I hit the source. And this
is where I'm looking for today. Again, this
is going to be a relative path. So now what
I want is to pass in that data array as my
default value. All right, awesome. And then
of course, let's work on our return. Now I
could go with react dot fragment, or a member,
there is a shortcut, where if I go with my
angle brackets, now essentially, I'm creating
my fragment, and I don't have that diff soup.
So now what I would want is to iterate over
my array. So I go with people, then again,
we'll use the map method. And then on each
and every person, I would want to return something
more meaningful.
First, I guess we can just return a Hello.
And then we can just double check whether
everything works. Because of course that is
very, very important. If I don't have access
to each and every person, essentially, if
I don't have access to the object, well, kind
of doesn't make sense. Correct. So if we console
log, beautifully, what I could see is john
Peter, Susan.
And then I have four hellos. So now of course,
let's do something a bit more meaningful,
where what I would want right now is to destructure,
these two things, the ID. And then I'm also
looking for the name. Now that is coming from
the person. And then I would want to return
a div. Now remember, when we render a list,
we need to have this key prop. And we need
to pass in that unique value. Now add a little
bit of styling here, where I'm going to say
item, again, that has nothing to do with functionality
is just for the styling. Let's set up a heading
four with a value of name, just so we can
see the name. And then eventually, we will
set up our button. So awesome. Notice, I have
my list. Again, I used use state hook when
I provided some default value, which in my
case was no way. I could have added the empty
array. But in my case, I already prepared
an array in data JS array, it is a array of
objects, then, of course I invoked it. And
then I'm getting two things. I'm getting whatever
default value I have. So that is my state
value. And then I have the function that controls
it. Okay, good. And then of course, just like
with any other variable, I can just access
it. And then I'm iterating over like we have
covered already before, where we're iterating
over. And then we display for each and every
item. There's dev online, we're just destructuring
ID.
But of course, now let's make it a bit more
interesting. What if our
Want to come up with a button that just delete
all the items. So right next to the people,
I'll set up my button. I'll add here a class
name, or btn. And we'll set up our on click.
Now, if you want, you can set up here, a function
reference, unless is something that we'll
do later once, we would want to remove a specific
item. But for now, I just want to showcase
that, of course, you can invoke this function
directly in here, where we're setting up the
onClick. But the gotcha is going to be in
this case, since we need to pass in the value,
we'll have to set up a arrow function as well.
Remember, that was one of the cases that I
showcased before. So in this case, let me
write clear items. So that is the text in
my button. And let me showcase that. If we
go set people, of course, we would need to
pass in that new value, correct. And if I
want to set it up to an empty array, that
just means that I will clear out all your
items. Now the problem is going to be that
we right away, invoke it. And that's not what
we're looking for. So what we would want is
only to invoke it, once we click on it. And
remember, the solution was to set up our arrow
function first. So once we do that, then we'll
have our button. And now what this button
is doing? Well, it is calling a set people
function. And remember, the only thing we
need to do is to pass in that new value. So
what is the new value in this case? Well,
since I would want to clear all the items,
I just pass in the empty array. Correct. Now,
let's see. And of course, everything works.
So now we remove all the items. Again, that
is something you need to remember where Yes,
you can call directly this function, you can
set up a handler, like we did previously.
And like we will do here, where we would want
to remove a single item. Yeah, that is definitely
an option. We could have used the reference
instead. But just keep in mind that yes, you
always can also use the inline function, where
you just need to set up a arrow function,
and then call whatever function you have a
new state, that is always also your option.
And now of course, let's work on removing
that individually. So in this case, I would
want to first create a button I guess, right
next to a heading for let's go with button.
Again, we'll have on a click. And in this
case, I will shut up a function reference.
So here, let's set up a curly braces. And
we'll have again our function, because we
will invoke our reference here. So say remove
item. And now we want to pass in the ID. And
then I'll say, Ram whatsoever. And at the
moment it complains, well, you haven't created
this remove item. So now of course we need
to work on our function, where we say remove
item. And then this remove item is going to
be looking for the ID. Because of course,
for each and every item, I can grab that ID.
And then notice how we set up the arrow function.
And we right away invoke the Remove item with
that specific ID. So essentially what happens,
this doesn't run each and every time we render
a wrap. In fact, it runs only when we click
on a button. And this is going to be that
use case that I talked about before when we
talked about the events where you must have
this arrow function each and every time you
are invoking this function, you must have
the arrow function, because you would want
this to run only when you click on a button.
And in this case, you have no other options,
since you are passing some kind of arguments
you are invoking. So that's why you always
need to return it from the arrow function.
So we have our remove item, remove item is
always going to be looking for the ID. And
now let's set up the functionality. So in
the Remove item, what I would want is to filter
out the array. So all the items that don't
have the matching ID, I would want to leave
them in unless you're the one that has the
matching ID. That one of course would want
to remove. Now I can say set people and then
set up the functionality right here in the
parentheses is always an option. But as far
as tutorials and projects, I always like to
be a bit more explicit where I'm going to
create new variable. So for example, let new
people amount is going to be equal to my
People's state value. So my original Ray,
Van filter, so now I'm filtering. And then
for each and every person that I have our
just want to remove the one that has the matching
ID. So if I go here with person ID, remember
I'm filtering out the array correct. And then
each and every object is there. And when I'm
saying, Hey, listen, if the person ID matches
the ID that I'm passing, and then of course,
remove it on the way I can do that. I can
say, motion point,
equals to an ID. So essentially, the logic
is following, where we pass in the ID, then
we filter out our array. And all the items
whose IDs are not passing to wherever we're
passing in, those ones are returned in new
people. Now, if you want, you can console,
log it, but in my case, I'll pass in the,
the search people. So I have my function.
And like I said, I can pass in whatever I
want. So of course, this is that new array
that we're getting back. And I'm just passing
in into the set people. And what you'll notice
right now that we have our buttons, and the
moment I click, I removed that specific item.
Then I click on john, I removed john Peter.
And of course, once I refresh, I have all
my items back. Now if I want to remove all
the list, or I can do it also as well, few
takeaways, we can set up this logic right
here, where we're passing in the new value,
because remember, with filter, we are getting
a new array anyway at the end of the day.
So in my case, I just like to go a bit more
explicit, where I'm creating a new variable,
and only then I pass it in to the people.
And the second one is going to be pretty common
Gracia where since we have either function
reference in here, or we would want to invoke,
of course, the function that we're getting
back from the use state, since in both cases,
we're passing in the argument, we're also
invoking. And that's why we always need to
set up the arrow function, otherwise it will
run right away. So essentially, when we run
the wrap on, it will invoke it. And then in
that case, we are not running at one we're
clicking on a function, we are running at
the moment our app runs. And that's not what
we're looking for. But those would be the
basics how we can use use state hook with
an array. Not bad, not bad. Once we have covered
how we can use use state with array, I think
it also makes sense, if we take a look at
how we can use with an object, because there
is a gotcha. So again, we're looking for to
set a folder, and then we're looking for US
state object. And once we save, we should
see the US state object example. Now of course,
we just need to now get to that particular
file, which is in the setup, again,
use state object and
of course, I would want to use my hook. So
let's go with two values, I'm going to go
with person, and then set person, and that
is going to be equal to my use state. And
then I'll pass in that object directly. Again,
that is something that I would want you to
keep in mind where you can pass in the variable,
like we just did with an array, or we can
pass in directly. So in this case, I'll pass
in the object, where is it going to be name,
now that name will be pure, an age will be
24. So let's do that. And then lastly, we'll
have some kind of message message. I'll set
this up as a string. so beautifully, I have
my object. So let's call this urandom.
message. So once we save, course, we are in
good shape. And if we want to console log
the person, of course, we'll be able to see
our object much. Not that at all. Now, the
thing is, what happens if we change this value?
And what gotcha should we be looking for?
Because with IRA, it was somewhat straightforward.
We're in one case, we just wiped out all the
data when we set it back to an empty array.
And the second thing, we have the function
of that was just returning a new array. Now
this is going to be a little bit different,
because we'll have some values that we would
want to preserve. And what may Shockers, what
am I talking about? I'll start with my return
where I'll set it back to a fragment online
and here. Let's type few heading threes. So
first, we'll look for person name, personal
name and notice say
Here's an object, of course, I have my value,
I'm accessing my state value. And then I'm
just looking for the property. Now I will
copy and paste. And I'll just change these
ones around, where of course, we'll have age
here, we'll have also a message. And let's
save. And there it is Peter 24, around messenger.
And eventually, I would want to have a button
that changes the message, again button via
a class name for the styling. So btn, a man
on click.
In here, let's call the change message, change
message, a function that we haven't created
yet. So in button, let's write change message.
And let's come up with that function, shown
here. const, change message providers my function,
I'm not looking for any arguments in this
case, but I would want to invoke my set person.
Now what you'll notice, though, that, for
example, if I want to change the message to
a HelloWorld, the problem is going to be that
when we invoke this function, essentially,
we wipe out all the routers. Remember, I told
you, when we set up the value, the state value,
it can be anything that you want. So even
though in the beginning, we went with an object,
if we invoke the function that changes the
state value, and we pass in the string, this
will be a string. So originally, we had an
object, we're treating, like an object will
go person name, person age, and the message
here, I just wipe out the data. And then I
say, you know what, it is going to be a Hello.
Now you could make an argument. Alright, but
what if we would set this up as an object,
I'll pass in the property of message. So in
this case, I'll say message is equal to hello
world. And technically you are correct, where
now we will change only the message. But again,
rest of the data gets wiped out. So what is
the solution? Well, solution is using a spread
operator, where if you remember what's proper,
with first copy the values, and then we come
up with whichever value would want to override.
So how we would fix this in this scenario,
I would go data dot, unknown person, and then
comma, and then I'm just gonna say, you know
what, leave these two values the name and
age, as they are at overwrite only the message.
So this is the gotcha. For example, if you're
using the object, then you need to make sure
that you always, always use the spirit operator.
Or there's also some other older setup, where
essentially, you copy the old values from
the state value. And then you just decide
which one you'd want to choose. In this case,
we want to change the hello world. So of course,
once we click, notice how we also change only
the message. All right, routers clear. But
as you're looking at our setup, you're probably
wondering, okay, but why do we have to even
bother with an object in the first place?
Can we set up three separate state values?
And whichever we want to change? Of course,
we would use that little method. Well, let's
try it out. But I can right away, spare you
the cliffhanger. So but yeah, but visually,
what you can do, sir, near I'm going to go
name, online shirt name. So I'm going to be
somewhat original, where I'm not going to
go with a wild name for my handler function.
And, again, I'm looking for the same thing,
theater, man, I'll just copy and paste and
we'll change these of ours around where now
we have age, man we're looking for set age
on the value will be 24. On the last one,
of course, is going to be a message. So we're
going message set message there is going to
be more function amount as far as the original
value, what we passed in here, we said random
message. Now, of course, in this case, we
are not dealing with objects anymore. So we
have these state values. So one by one, of
course, we will need to access them. So now
I'm looking for name, and I'm looking for
a person. And lastly, I'm looking forward
a message. When we talk about this change
message. Well, we can either right away call
set message here on click. So remember that
of course, we'll have to set up the inline
because we're passing in the argument. Or
since we already have the handler, I can simply
pass here and say
message, we would want to change it, of course,
to a Hello World. So once we set that up,
notice once you click course, I have my value.
So essentially what I'm trying to say that
there is no rule that prevents you from showing
up as many state values as you'd want. So
instead of going for one giant object, you
can set up multiple smaller state values,
where you have just a single value, and then
a function that controls our, if you do decide
going with an object, there's going to be
some use cases where object might make a little
bit more sense. But always, always, always
remember that you need to make sure that you
preserve these old values.
A nifty way of doing that is using a spread
operator, where essentially, we copy the properties
from the previous object. And then we'll just
choose whichever we would want to override.
And of course, in this case, it was a message.
So we went from random message to a Hello
World, our Yes, there is an alternative, where
you can set up as many state values as you'd
want, just by calling your state your state
passing in default value. And then you have
that single state value, as well as the handler
function for that set value. Not bad, not
bad. I think we're progressing nicely with
our use state examples. In our last example,
I want to showcase how we can work with numbers.
And not only how we can work with numbers,
but how we can set up a functional update
for the all this time, we have been using
the value update. Now what that means is where
we have this function, the subtext or whatever
set function we get back from you state, we
just call the function, and then we pass in
that new value map essentially sets our state
equal to that new realm. However, there's
also a method of passing in the function.
In the following videos, I'll show you why
that is important. But first, I would want
you to head back to objects. And then import
again, component, you can call it whatever
you'd want from your state event setup folder.
And then the file name is US state counter.
Essentially, that is going to be our last
file, how our split this up in multiple videos,
because I want you to get a better understanding
of what we're doing. So once you import this
file, via just navigate there, and you should
see on a screen use that counter example.
And you can probably already guess that we
are going to create a counter with not just
a simple counter, we'll have one with straight
up ladders. And the second one, we'll use
a V function. Now we'll start with our turn
first, though, where it's not going to be
an interior. Again, we're gonna go for a fragment,
so we don't need to overpopulate everything,
we have divs a man, once we have our fragment,
then I would want to go with a section. Now
add a little bit of styling right here,
where I'm going to say margin, and then that
is going to be equal to four, REM and zero,
and nine within the section. Let's just go
with heading two. And I'm going to call this
a regular
encounter version, see something like this
on the screen. Now after the Heading Two,
I'm going to set up my value show at the moment.
Of course we don't have anything, but we will
use you state. And you're not, I don't want
you to set up a state value because that should
take us a second since we already know how
to do that. So I'm going to go with value
and set value. And that is equal to or use
state. And then as far as my initial value,
well, that is going to be a number of zero.
And now in heading one, I can just simply
go get more value. And surprise surprise,
of course I have the zero. And now let's add
three buttons, one for increase, one for reset,
and one for decrease. So I guess we'll start
with the decrease one. Let's go with button
on my class name. That will be equal to A
btn. And let's just right here decrease. And
we'll just copy and paste the same button.
So one, two, and then of course three buttons
total. And we just need to change these routers
around where we're going to go with the reset,
as well as the increase or just go here.
Again, I know I've covered this before but
I'll set up two ways how we can click on a
button. One is going to be, we have a function
here. So where we reference it, for example,
with the reset, and the decrease and increase
is going to be with inline functions, just
showcase, again, that you always have multiple
ways how to set it up. And essentially, it
is up to you. Now there's going to be some
cases where you definitely need to use the
inline when you are actually passing in. But
then, in some cases, you can simply use the
reference, and you're good to go. So we have
our buttons. And like I just said, we'll go
with on click,
set up a inline function here, where we go
with set value. And now I'll use the old value,
I'll say value, whatever it is, of course,
at the moment is zero. And then I'll say minus
one, because of course, the button is decrease.
And we'll do the same thing here, we're going
to increase,
copy and paste. Now, of course, now the value
should be plus one, correct. So once we click
on a button, I would want to invoke my cell
function on whatever is the value, and then
plus one, like I just said, for the reset,
let's set up a reference, just so we are all
on the same page that we have multiple ways
how we can get the same result. So I'm going
to go here with reset, I'll have my function.
And then within this function, I'm just gonna
say set value, again, my sub function, and
I'll set it equal to zero. And now where I
have the reset, I'm just gonna go with on
click, I just need to reference the function.
So in this case, of course, he is a reset.
And then let's test that out. So once we click,
of course, notice, we can nicely increase,
we can also decrease,
we can reset. So again, this is a way of passing
directly the value in our set function, where
we pass in the value. And then the moment
we do that, of course, that is our new state
value. Following video, I would want to cover
the functional updater form, where essentially,
we pass in a function on why would want to
do that in the first place. Nice. And once
we have our simple counter, let's take a look
at how we can pass in a function in our set
function. And why we would want to do that.
So first, we'll set up a counter or this is
going to be more complex problem. However,
the JSX pretty much is going to be the same,
the only difference is that we're not going
to use that many buttons. So what I would
want to do is grab all my section, copy and
paste, I'll still keep the margin that stays
the same. Let's call this a more complex or
complex counter, more complex counter value
store the same.
As far as the buttons, we'll delete most of
them on what just say here button. And it's
going to be just a increase button. So let's
say here button for the class for the styling.
As far as the text inside the button, let's
just say increase layer. And now I would want
to set up a function that is going to be a
complex increase. Why am I calling this a
complex increase, because I would want to
add a little bit of the timeout. So essentially,
once I collect, there should be some delay.
So once we click will set up two seconds delay,
and only then the value should be updated.
In a process, we'll see why would want to
use that functional updater warm. Now, let's
first set up the onClick. Let's say on click
over here, and that is going to be equal to
a complex.
Let's call it my function, the increase complex
increase over here. Now of course, we do need
to create a VAT function, because now we're
just referencing. So let's say const. And
non complex increase, that is my function.
It's not going to be looking for any argument.
However, in here, like I said, I don't want
to simply call my set value, what I would
want is to go with set timeout. And then remember,
in the set timeout, we needed to pass into
things a callback function, which is going
to run push in a certain amount of time. In
our case, that is going to be two seconds.
And in here we just pass in that value. Two
seconds. Well, we in our set timeout we have
the callback function that is going to run
in two seconds, just remember that as far
as the
Time, we're passing here to milliseconds.
That's why for two seconds, we are going to
pass in 2000. And then within the callback
function, this is where I would want to call
my set
value, because that is my function. Now in
this case, again, I'm going to go with a simple
way, where we have the value directly in our
set function. So in my case, I'm going to
go with set value, and value plus one. And
now million dollar question, do you think
once you click three, four or five, whatever
times that will, right away update after those
two seconds each and every time or there's
going to be an issue. And you can probably
already guess, since we're setting up the
whole example, that there has to be a gotcha.
So let's try it out. What I'm gonna do right
now is click three times. And the moment you
click, you notice that Yeah, after two seconds,
something happens. But essentially, I have
clicked only once, meaning my value only increased
by once. So why is that happening? Well, let's
think about it. So we're grabbing here, the
value, correct part, we need to understand
that this set function is a synchronous. So
what happens is the for example, I click three
times, all these three times, it thinks that
the value is zero, or in this case, if I click
it right, now, of course, he's going to think
that the value is one. So again, I can click
three times. And yeah, is going to increase
but again, only by one. Because all those
three times, when we call this set value,
we'll still be looking for at all the value,
meaning to one, or whatever. So essentially,
we're not using the current value in your
state, because what should happen is each
and every time we click, we grab that previous
value, that was just right there before. And
then we update. And this is the case where
of course, we would want to use that functional
approach. Now how does that work? By the way,
I'll leave this for your reference, just so
you can have it later. And the way it works,
we go with set value. And then instead of
passing directly, that new value that we want,
we pass in the function. Now what's really
interesting about this function that as a
parameter, it get that old state value. So
right before the update, now, what is really,
really important that it gets that current
one, and you'll see that in a second. So in
this case, it gets the one that is actually
correct. Now the one that is called, for example,
two seconds ago, now, it gets the current
one. So of course, in this case, what we can
do is we can increase and we'll see how our
values update right away. And since it is
a parameter, you can call it whatever you
want. But pretty common convention is going
with pre state or pre value, whatever you'd
want.
And then whatever you're going to return from
this function is now the new value. Now this
is very, very important. Because if you leave
this on the farm, and of course, your whole
functionality will break. Now I know what
you're thinking, you're like, Well, why would
I ever leave this undefined? Well, also keep
in mind that you can start setting up here,
some kind of conditions based on something
really small gotcha is that if you will return
undefined, meaning if you won't return anything,
and we know already that in JavaScript, functions
return undefined, run, your whole functionality
might break. So just be careful, when you're
setting up this function, whatever you'll
return from this function will be that new
set value. And if it is undefined, well, when
is going to be a problem. So in this case,
what I would want is to go with brief state.
So whatever is my primer, and my last one.
And now what you'll notice is that if I click
I don't know, 10 times, it's going to wait
for the first one. And then of course right
after that, notice how we nicely increase
the function, meaning the value, and it is
happening, because in this case, we are getting
that correct. Old value. So right before the
update. Previously, when we use this one,
no, we were not getting the correct value.
Because if I clicked for example, three, four,
or whatever times, I was all the time getting
the same value
is when I call all my functions. In this case,
it gets the current one, one that is right
before the update, and what you're thinking,
you're like, Okay, why we haven't used the
function before? because let me tell you
right away that yes, you can use a setup for
all the previous examples that we used before.
And you'll see some people that prefer that
type of method. Now, it is not set in stone,
of course, in this case, you have to use it.
Because, of course, it wouldn't make sense,
we show the error that we're getting our,
in some cases, the ones that we covered before,
you can use the value way of doing that, where
you just pass in the value. But just so we
all are on the same page, let me change this
around to for example, I don't know, final
one mondas case, I'm going to look for a re
example. And we'll reformat a little bit,
just so you understand that yes, you can use
function in any of the examples that we covered,
whether that is this one, whether that is
the second one with array, or with an object,
and you might see some people who prefer doing
that way. Now, whichever way you choose is
up to you. Some people choose to use all the
time function, some people just use it whenever
it is definitely necessary, which of course,
would be this case. And the way we're going
to do that is simply we'll change this around,
I'll say that I'm going to be looking for
the final one in this case. Now keep in mind
that of course how we'll delete it, meaning
I'll leave the final that was there before,
I just want to showcase that, of course, we
can use the functional approach as well. So
I'm going to go with you stay here. And I'm
going to go with final this case, I'm going
to do the array example. Since I changed this
around, we're going to go with final here.
Now that is my array. Remember, the functionality
should still work, where we can remove one
item working, we can clear all of them. And
now let's navigate to that final one. Again,
you don't have to do it with me, brought in
markers, I'm just going to show cares that,
of course, we can refactor this, using the
functional approach, where remember, we use
the sub people. Now what I'm going to do is
just instead of the new people will say here
yeah, that we will pass in the function. Remember,
whatever we return from this function is going
to be the new value. If we really needed to
or wanted to our guess we can just set up
the whole functionality here within this function.
Sure, what I'm going to do is just grab everything
that we currently have within the Remove item
and move it to the function within a set people.
Now in this case, again, we're not really
depending on that value. But just to showcase
that, of course we can use it, I will go we
people. So that is going to be my new or I'm
sorry, the old value that is coming from the
state. And of course, I now filter it, or
you're not more just say old people,
old people. And we will refactor it a little
bit. So old people. Now again, we filter it,
and then whatever we return, that is going
to be our new value. So once I save Notice
how I can still remove the item correctly,
like I did before. However, in this case,
of course, we're using this function approach,
where again, we're getting the parameter that
is our old state value, so right before we're
updating, or you can maybe also say, the current
value of that state. And then whatever we
return from this function is going to be that
new state value, and just showcase where you
can set up a bug. For example, if I say that
I don't have the return, sorry, fall common.
So you'll notice that the first time our remote
something, I just have the bananas happening
in my application. Why? Well, because now
from this function, I'm setting up my people
my shared value to be undefined rather why
it is very, very important for us to always
return something from this function, and that
something will be that state value. Again,
just to reiterate, we have multiple options,
we can either pass in the value, however,
there is going to be some cases or or some
people who prefer using functional approach
all the time, where you can pass in the function
in your set function. And then you can have
the parameter and that parameter will be that
current state or previous state right before
the update. And then you can set up some grand
functionality, whatever you would want, and
whatever you will return
From that function will be that new state
value.
While spending time in tutorial will, is nice,
you'll only get better. If you start applying
the concept we just covered by building something
cool. That's why I would highly highly, highly
encourage you to check out the React project
video where we do just that. More specifically,
you're looking for project number one, the
birthday reminder, if you want to see some
of the projects, we're going to build in the
projects video, just navigate to react hyphen,
project dot nullify dot app. Now it is still
working progress. time when I'm recording
this video, I only have one project. But don't
worry. By the time you'll be watching this
video, of course, there's going to be more
project. I purposely structured them in a
way where we build the easier projects first.
And then as our topics in tutorial are getting
more complex, we right away have the corresponding
project that emphasizes the knowledge we just
learn. And then if you want to check out the
apps just hover over the card. And of course
click it on this is going to be the app that
we're going to build. Now I also would like
to mention that if you're interested in more
corresponding projects, for the remaining
of the topics, and tutorial project, navigate
to README markdown file. And here you'll find
the project that relate to the topic. So like
I said, once you learn use state, I would
highly encourage you to go out and work on
birthday reminder, then, once you will learn
use effect and conditional rendering, of course,
there is going to be some project that you
can practice on. Again, this is still work
in progress. Because as I'm recording, I only
have two projects done, then by the time you'll
be working on the React tutorial, there is
going to be more project that correspond to
the topics. And I also want to let you know
right away that some topics won't have the
corresponding project, for example, prop drilling,
so keep that in mind, just follow the roadmap
in the readme. And I'll also leave here the
link for the project video. As well as the
link is going to be available in the description
of this video. Not bad, not bad. We're done
with the first part of our tutorial, the use
state hook. Hopefully you completed the project
as well, because it will help solidify all
the knowledge that we're learning in tutorial,
because at the end of the day, we can stay
in tutorial will for remaining of the days.
But if you won't know how to apply that knowledge,
as far as building project, it is going to
be somewhat useless. So even though it's not
mandatory, technically, you can just keep
on going through the tutorial, I would suggest
every time we are done with some specific
tutorial part, just go ahead and do the project
that I'm suggesting. Because at the end of
the day, if you won't know how to apply them
to build a project now, and we can sit in
tutorial Ville all day long, but it's not
going to make much sense. And our second tutorial
topic is going to be the second most use talk.
So like I mentioned previously, the use state
and use effect are going to be most used hooks.
And now we finally arrived at the second hook
the use effect. official explanation of use
effect hook is falling where it allows you
to do the side effect. Now before you freak
out, frantically start searching for urban
dictionary. Essentially, when we talk about
side effects, we talk about any work outside
of the component. Now that work could be changing
document title, that could be signing up for
subscription that could be fetching data that
could be setting up a event listener and stuff
along those lines. So every time you think
of use effect, think of work outside of the
component. And similarly to our first topic.
Of course, we do have the folder in tutorial,
and we're looking forward to second folder
and name is user. And then of course again,
we have the final folder where we have complete
code. And then we have a setup folder where
we will set up our examples. And the file
that we're looking for is this use effect
basics. So what I would
Want you to do first is in the app j s, again,
come up with the name my case, it's going
to be a setup, just so you know that we're
working on a setup folder. And then you're
looking for tutorial, you're looking for us
effect folder, vendor setup. And the file
name is one hyphen, user, and learn basics.
And once you render the component, you should
see in the screen, use the fact breadsticks.
And once that is done, of course, let's navigate
to the file. Go ahead and let me reiterate,
it is in tutorial, then use a quick run setup,
and then use the fact basics js. So that's
the file we're looking for. And just like
we use state, we have two ways how we can
set up our hook, we can either import it and
notice again, areas a named import, or remember
how we did react dot and then use the foot.
So that is also an option. Now, by default
use effect arounds after every render region,
every time we re render a component use effect
will run. So that is going to be by default.
And there's two more comments that I will
cover the cleanup function and second parameter,
whole area is going to be more important in
the later videos. So first, let's set up I
guess, some kind of use effect. So we have
our function body, again, we go with use effect.
And then the way use effect works is we pass
in the callback function. So we have use effect.
So that's the hook. And then within this callback
function, whatever functionality will place
will run after every render. And just to showcase
that let me go with log, and I'll say render
component here. And then I will log as well
call us.
So I'll go here, call us back like so. And
then if we'll open up the console, more you
should see is around their component. So we
have that. And then of course, we have the
call use effect. So as you can see, once we
render the component, we also call the use
effect. Now the reason why you see these render
component wise is simply because in the setup
in the index js, we have this react strict
mode. So if I move this out,
if I remove it, you will see that only once.
So basically that is their setup. So as you
can see now we have only render a component
once. So if you're wondering why you will
see once in a while, the render component
twice, essentially whatever we played as far
as the function body, it is because of the
strict mode. Right? So let me close the sidebar
right now. And let's talk about the use effect.
So at the moment, we have only simple console
log. And by the way, yes, even the console
log is considered a side effect. I know it
sounds funny, but that is true. And once we
are on the side effect will what we would
want to do, for example, I would want to change
the title or the document title. So the moment
I react up, can we do that? Well, let's try
it out. I think I'm going to close the console.
For now. I think I'm going to come up with
a button. So in my JSX, I'll set up a button,
where essentially we click on a button, then
we increase the value,
we will set up a new document title that shows
the messages, not say new messages. And of
course the value will be equal to whatever
is the amount of times we click on a button.
Here. Let's do this way, we'll go back to
a react fragment. And in here, we'll type
out heading one, where eventually there's
going to be a value.
And let's go right away with the button class
name btn just for styling, on click, we will
increase the value. Now of course we haven't
used the use state yet. So let's go here with
const non value, then set value function set
value, not as equal to use date. Again, we'll
start with a zero. And of course, once we
click on a button, what I would want is to
increase that value by one. Now I'm not relying
on the previous values. So we'll just pass
in the new value in the set value. Here was
just right click me. Click me where we have
the button. So of course now I have the value.
If you'll notice
moment or click, couple of things are happening.
So in my console each and every time I click,
I'll have that render component. And then
I'll have that call usually.
So each and every time we click, this is exactly
what is happening. Why is that happening?
Because every time we click the button, we
invoke set value correct. Now what happened
with the use state, you stayed the two things,
a, preserve the value between their fingers.
And the second one is triggered rerender.
So every time I click on a button, I'm essentially
running my use effect. Because remember, by
default, use effect will run after every render.
So each and every time we rerender, the component,
we are running essentially this use effect
hook. That's why in the console, we can see
call use effect, call us call use effect.
Now, of course, let's do some more interesting
side effect, where not only I would want to
console log, but I want to go with document.
And then title amount is going to be called
to a template string. Now say new messages.
And in this case, I'm going to use parentheses,
Van out want to grab much that value, which
you'll notice that the moment we render the
component, of course, we call the use effect,
we can see that in console. But I can also
see here where I have the new messages. Now,
I have new messages. And now I'm using my
state value, which of course, is zero. But
now, every time we click, notice how we're
updating the value here, we're calling the
use effect after every render. And of course,
the functionality that is within the use effect
also runs because now I have document title.
And our new messages is three for each and
every time I increase. Also, my title changes
as well. Now again, just to reiterate, use
effect is used when we want to set up a side
effect. And that is some work outside of the
component. So think data fetching, think listening
for events, think signing up for subscriptions,
and stuff along those lines. And then by default,
it will run after every render. And the way
it works, we pass in the callback function.
And then whatever functionality we set up
within that callback function will run after
every render. Now, this is nice. So we're
updating our document title, each and every
time we click on a button. And of course,
we do that using the use of However, what
if we would want to change our functionality
a little bit around? Where What if I wouldn't
want to showcase that I have zero messages?
What if I would want to do that only when
essentially, I have value bigger than zero.
So I only want to showcase that if I have
the actual messages. So what I'm trying to
say is, I would only want to run it when my
value is bigger than zero. Because at the
moment notice, of course, we render the component.
And then since use effect runs after every
render, well, of course, we right away, do
the functionality that is within the use of
our rational thinking would be something like
this, where if value is bigger than zero,
then of course, we would want to run yours.
Sounds pretty reasonable, right? But remember,
seems like an eternity ago, when I talked
about general rules of hook, I said that we
cannot we cannot place hooks, as far as conditionals.
So this, we right away have a big fat complain,
because we cannot call hooks conditionally.
And at that time, I said that it doesn't make
sense for me to place a use in the conditional.
However, I will do that once we get to a use
effect. And of course, we have finally arrived
at the use effect example, which technically
would make sense to place it in the conditional.
However, we cannot do that because of the
rules of the hoax. So just keep that in mind.
Now, the question of course, is well, how
we can fix that. And one of the ways we can
do that is by setting up if and else inside
of the callback function. So the point of
this video is to showcase that even though
You cannot place hooks in the conditional.
Similarly, how we work with a set function
where we set up a conditional, and then depending
on the value, we called the set function with
some specific value, the same thing we can
do in the use effect. We're inside of that
callback function. Yes, we can set up a if
an if statement. So how is that going to look
like? Well, in here, I could say if value
is bigger than one, only, then I would want
to update document title. So what happens
notice on the initial render, nothing happens,
even though we still call the user. So we
still call it however, in the use of acne
in the callback function, we have a conditional
where I'm checking the value. And I only would
want to update the document title if the value
is bigger than one. So on our initial render,
nothing happens. However, once I click your
button, Now, of course, the value is one.
So again, nothing happens. So I guess in this
case, we can either look for bigger or equals,
and you'll notice how now once the actual
number is one, and of course, I'm also updating
right away the title, because it matches my
condition of without make sense, where we
cannot place the hooks in the conditionals,
something we already covered before our as
far as setting up the conditionals. Within
the callback function. Yes, we can definitely
do that. It is not against the rules. So in
a previous video, we covered how we can set
up a conditional inside the use effect callback
function. Our question still remains Is this
the only possible setup where our user runs
after every run? By default, yes, that is
the case. However, you can also notice the
two comments that I left here. One is the
cleanup function, something we'll cover in
the next video. And now I want to talk about
the second parameter. What on earth is that?
And essentially, second, brahmer is something
that we add here, as far as the user factor.
So we have our function. So that is the functionality
that will run and return will call the user
for. But as far as the second argument, we
can also pass it here, a array, and that is
the array of dependencies. So essentially,
that is called a list of dependencies. And
if we leave this blank, that just means that
it will only run on the initial render. And
now notice something interesting, where as
far as our logic, it technically is looking
for the value if it is bigger or equal than
one. Correct. So it will run on the initial
render. And then we have our if statement,
of course. So essentially, once we save, this
shouldn't update the title, originally, right?
Because we have our if condition, how are
we did call it, we can clearly see that, yes,
we have call us. And that is, of course, coming
from the console log. Now the first time I
click, notice something interesting, where
I clicked, I updated the value. But since
I have that second argument, I have the dependency
list, and I have nothing in there. Essentially,
it is empty, it only runs on the initial render
matters something very, very important that
you should remember. So if you only want the
user to run on the initial render, you just
add that second argument, and you'd pass it
as a empty array. That just means that it
will run on the initial render. Now the second
question probably is, well, can we add more
stuff in there? Because it's fine. All right,
it runs on the initial render, but maybe I
would want to run it each and every time I
change some kind of value. Now what that value
could be, or here, we could maybe run it each
and every time we update that value. So let's
try it out. So in here in the dependency array,
we just pass in whatever name is for our dependency.
So in this case, of course it is the value
if it will be text, you will pass in text,
and hopefully you get the gist. So now once
I say again, in rounds on the initial render,
virus, beautiful, but now you'll notice that
will also run once we increase
The value show, once we increase the value,
we change something about there's dependency.
And then the moment we change something about
that value, of course, then we trigger use
effect to run one more time. Since in dependency
array, we have the value. So each and every
time we'll change something about this value,
essentially, we will run the use effect as
well. So that's something to remember where,
by default, if you have no dependency array,
the use effect will run each and every time
the component get re rendered, including the
initial render, that if we set up the second
parameter, the dependency array, as far as
the empty list, meaning and the array, then
of course, it will run only once we render
the component. And then as we start adding
different values here, as far as different
dependencies, then each and every time that
dependency will change, if it is added to
an array, then also use effect will run. And
one more thing that I would want to add is
that you can have as many use the fact as
you'd want. So for example, in this case,
we have one use effect that will run on the
initial run there, also when the value changes,
but nothing stops me from setting up another
one. And then again, I have my callback function.
And in this case, I will just set it up to
be on the initial render. Now, I'm not going
to do much, I'm just going to go with simple
console log, and I'll say hello world. And
what you'll notice is that, yeah, it runs
on the initial render, just like the previous
use effect of we have, however, a war on the
second time. So each and every time I'll click
on a button, you'll notice that use effect,
the second one with hello world doesn't run,
because the value is not in the dependency
list. Hopefully that makes sense. And now
we can talk about the cleanup function. Not
bad, not bad. We're done with use effect basics.
And now let's take a look at the cleanup function.
Why would want to use it.
First, I would want to change the file. So
all this time we were working in use of basics.
Now, of course, I would want to navigate to
objects. And I'm still looking forward to
set a folder. But now I'm looking forward
to file number two, use effect cleanup. Again,
it's still going to be a setup since I didn't
change the name. And what you see on the screen
is use the fact. Now of course, let's navigate
to that particular file. So again, not the
final one, we set up one. And in here, what
I would want is to check for the width of
the window. So we're still using years, on
ladders. Good. But I would want to check the
size of the window. And we can do that by
setting up the event listener on the window
object. Now first, let's set up some use state
value. So again, notice we have imported use
state and use effect. What I'm looking for
here is const. Now online this size and set
size, set size, and we'll use the US state
that is our hook. And then in order to get
the width of the window, we're going to go
with window and the property is in there with
now if you'd want to console log, you can
just go with console log and check the size.
And you should see some value over here. So
let me open up the console. And of course
it tells me here that is 484. Now of course,
it's not going to change at the moment, we
haven't set up the functionality. But that
is going to be the whole idea where we set
up the event listener on the window and as
the size of the window changes, so does the
value. Now first, let me open up a bigger
browser window because it's going to be easier
to operate. I'm going to go here with localhost
3000. Of course, I still have the same setup.
Now in this case, though, of course the value
should be different, correct, because of course
the window is bigger. So as you can see it
is 12 131. So now what I would want to do
is to set up a some kind of return. So I guess
again, we'll go with a fragment first. And
let's type in one, we'll say window. And then
let's write Heading Two, and heading two.
We'll be looking for that size. So first,
let's access the set value. And then let's
the pixels. So we should see here a window
and then whatever is the value, and of course
it should match exactly one
We have in console. And now let's set up a
event listener on the window. For that case,
we will use the use effect. So we're going
to go over here we'll say use effect. And
then in the use effect, what I would want,
of course, is to pass in my callback function.
Now that is true. And then within that callback
function, I will want the event listener on
the window. So first, I'll be listening for
resize event, that's number one. And then
we need that callback function. So essentially,
a function that will run each and every time,
the event will take place. So the resize one,
and in this case, I think I'll call this check
size. So let's write check size. Now the thing
is, of course, we need to create that particular
function. So let's create it or say check
size. And as far as the function, it will,
all the time, update the size. So all right
here, set size, and then whatever is the value,
get the inner width. So what we're doing here
is we have the use effect, we have the callback
function, and we're setting up the event listener
on a window, each and every time, this event
will take place the resource one, we will
invoke the check size function. And as far
as check size, now we just call set size,
and we get the current width of the window.
So let's see whether this is going to work.
So the moment of course, this is 1463. Now
let's see whether we can update it. And everything
works nicely correct. So we can make it bigger,
we can make it smaller. And each and every
time I'm resizing the window, I'm getting
the correct value. Because again, we have
the event listener, we're getting the routers,
and everything is beautiful. Or let me throw
you a mind grenade. What if we will go to
element? One will check event listeners?
Or check for the resize one? Now, what do
you think? How many will have there? We shouldn't
have one correct. Now, does that look like
one? No, it doesn't. And the problem with
this one here is that eventually, we'll just
have a memory leak, where the moment your
app gets bigger and bigger and bigger. And
if you have a bunch of components that are
setting up these event listeners, left and
right, it will cause huge problems. Here,
there has to be a way where once we of course,
exit, then we remove that event listener.
Now first, we need to understand well, why
is that happening here? Well, we have the
use of correct, we have the window listener.
Now, in the callback function. What are we
doing over here? What do you think we have
set size correct. Now what is the set size
doing? It is triggering the rerender? Correct.
Because the moment we invoke set size, we
update the value. As far as the state value
as far as the size. And what was used to doing,
it was preserving the values, and it was triggering
the rerender. So each and every time, we call
this callback function, meaning each and every
time we resize the window, we also trigger
the rerender. So the moment we trigger rerender,
then again, we call the use effect. Now if
you want, you can just simply console log
in, you'll see that in a console, where I'll
say hello world, the moment we refresh, notice,
technically we have one correct. Now we have
one event listener. But of course, the moment
I'll start adding some changes, you'll notice
first of all in the console, I have a bunch
of hello world. So each and every time, I'm
calling the use of an Of course, if I'll check
my events, and I fall refresh, I have a bunch
of event listeners as well. This is where
the cleanup function come into play. So every
time we have this user, we also have an option
of returning a function. So we go here with
return.
And as far as the function, wherever we place
over here, will be invoked once we exit. And
I think the best way to showcase that is adding
another console log. I'll say clean up here.
And let's set up a remove event listener.
So we'll go with window and remove event listener.
Again, we need to set up a resize on the same
callback function. So we would want to remove
once essentially, we are done. And what you'll
notice right now is something really interesting
We call the HelloWorld. course that is initial
render. But what you'll notice, before we
do anything show before we set up another
event listener, because notice this is happening,
as I keep changing the screen size, then we
also call the cleanup function. So I think
the best case scenario is going to be add
in here console log. And I'll say render,
burn here. We'll call this use effect, use
effect. And then we'll have our cleanup. You'll
notice how it works. So initially, we have
the render correct, then we call the user
for now, before, we call the use effect, one
more time, we'll also clean up Shall we have
our initial render, again, don't pay attention
that there's two of them. There's initial
render, then we invoke the user. And then
again, once we trigger rerender, once we render
the component one more time, before we call
that user. So before we add that, another
event listener, essentially, we clean it up,
we remove that listener. And of course, we
can also see that by the console log. So that
is going to be how the cleanup function works.
So yes, the use effect will run after each
and every render node is of course, the default
event. In this case, we're setting on the
event listener, we're checking for a resize.
Now, that will trigger the rerender. However,
before we around the use of after that render,
we will run the cleanup function first. So
that's how the setup works. And you might
make a good argument where technically in
this example, we don't need to clean up function.
Now, what am I talking about here, are remember,
we had that initial render, we had that dependency.
So for example, in here, I could say you know
what, I would just want to run the user only
once we render the component. And in this
case, you're actually correct. Because what
you'll notice that even if we comment out
the return, meaning the cleanup function will
still have only one event listener. So notice
how I'm re rendering the component that is
true. But if I check out the elements, I can
clearly see that I still have only one event
listener, because my use effect only runs
once. Now, before you dismiss the cleanup
function where you can say, well, each and
every time on just this empty dependency array,
you need to understand that the cleanup portion
is very important, when we will start dealing
with component appearing and disappearing,
meaning there's going to be conditional rendering,
where Yeah, at the moment, this component
is all the time on the screen. So totally,
honestly, this makes sense, where we just
set up a dependency array, and we say, you
know what, once the component renders, we
will set up event listener, and life is great.
However, we need to understand that there's
going to be component that, for example, are
displayed and they are moved. And the problem
with this one is that even though it runs
on the initial render each and every time,
we will show and hide that component, it will
add again, the window listener, or event listener
or whatever side effect you added there. And
that is something that I'll show you a little
bit later, once we talk about the conditional
rendering, just don't dismiss it. Even though
in this case, here, we could have fixed our
issue with this empty dependency array. Essentially,
don't forget that it is a good practice, each
and every time you set up a side effect is
to also set up a cleanup function. So you
don't make a big fat mash, by just adding
tons of subscriptions, tons of event listeners,
or that kind of thing. Nice. And once we have
covered all the use effect works. Now let's
put it to good use. And let's see how we can
fetch data using use effect. On first what
I want you to do is in the app j s, change
the import a little bit. Now I don't think
I'll change the name. But we're gonna grow
with us effect again. And we're looking for
the final in this case. Let's look for use
a quick fetch data file. And once it renders,
you'll notice a bunch of GitHub users. So
essentially, this is what
What we're trying to create, where there's
going to be some title,
we'll just get some default GitHub users.
And of course, we'll do that using use effect.
So now let's change it around to a setup.
So instead of the final folder we're looking
for to setup. And we should see on the screen
fetch data, that's the one that we're looking
for. I think I can close the console, it's
not going to be necessary. And let's navigate
to fetch data, I already provided the URL,
if you want to double check what you're going
to get back, you can just copy that and navigate
to your browser, copy and paste browser will
perform a get request. And as you can see,
essentially, we'll get a array of objects.
And then in each and every object, we have
info about the GitHub users, I believe we're
getting 30. But don't quote me on that. I
might be wrong, but I believe there's 30.
So once we have this particular setup, Now,
of course, let's work on our component, where
I think I would want to start by setting up
some kind of state value. Again, we have the
use state. So let's set up the users, I'm
going to go with const
users. Now I will need a set users function
as well,
users here, and that is going to be equal
to use state. Let's start with an empty array,
that is going to be my default setup. Then,
of course, in the return, let's also add some
kind of heading three.
This is where we'll place our users, eventually,
we're below it, we're going to go here with
GitHub users.
All right, that's a good start. And now let's
set up our user. So I'll set up my hook. So
use effect. And then I'll have my callback
function, of course, share within the callback
function, what I want is to perform a fetch
request. Now we have multiple scenarios, we
can set up the function here. So you can just
start typing away, that is always an option.
Or you can set up a separate function. So
in my case, I'm going to go with separate
function for a very simple reason that I'm
going to use async await. And that is one
more rule that I would want to mention that
you cannot, you cannot make this function
async await. For simple reason that Remember,
a sink await returns what it returns a promise
correct. So if I'll say here, a sink, right
here, it is going to be an issue. Okay, this
will work, there's going to be a big fat or
because you use a frickin cannon to be a sink,
it cannot return a promise. Because remember,
in the previous video, we talked about that
cleanup function. So use effect is looking
for that, not for the promise. That's why
you can either set up async await inside the
callback function. Or you can just set it
up as a separate function, which exactly what
I'm going to do. So I'm going to go here with
cons, and then I'll call this get users. Now,
like I said, it is going to be a sync function,
because I'll use the async await syntax. And
then within the function body, I'm just going
to be looking for a response. So go with responses
equal to await. And then I'll use the built
in fetch. But of course, you can use axios,
or some kind of external library as well.
By the way, I think during the projects, we'll
use the external libraries, because it's just
going to be a little bit easier. And then
we already know that within the fetch, we
just need to pass in the string, meaning the
URL, which of course, he is, right now, the
API github.com, and then forward slash users.
Now we already know that as far as fetch,
we would need to run the JSON because we're
looking for that format. And again, we can
await for that. In this case, I'll go for
users and is equal to await or response. So
that is, of course, my variable. And then
I run the JSON. So my key thing here is getting
this users. And before you're on set users,
let's just do a little bit of dance, where
I'm going to show you what would be an issue
if you just directly call set users. So first,
let's start by console logging, whether we
are getting the data in the console. And then
once we get the data, then of course we'll
discuss what steps do we need to take? So
in the console at the moment, I don't see
anything. Of course, the reason why I don't
see anything, because in the use of I didn't
call it. So let me call get users let's invoke
it. And now our console Yeah, I have 30 users
will
Life is beautiful. Like I said, it is an array.
And each and every user in that array is an
object. Now, what are the steps that I would
want to take? Well, I would want to use set
users. And of course, instead of this empty
array, I would want to set it up as the users
that I'm getting from the GitHub, correct.
Show, instead of this empty array, it's going
to be array of 30 years. And then once I set
her up, then in the JSX, I will iterate over
my users. And then for each and every user,
I'll just set up some type of return, meaning
there's going to be named, there's going to
be an image, and all that good stuff. Now,
before we do anything, I would want you to
think about something. So I'll purposely placed
this in the comments, because I don't want
you to run this right now. But what do you
think is going to happen if we go with set
users, and then we pass in the users? And
let me tell you right away that as far as
the code, this is correct. There's nothing
wrong here. So I have my GitHub users, and
then I'm just using my set function, and then
passing in the GitHub users. But there's a
different problem. What do you think is going
to be a problem? Well, I have my use effect,
correct? It runs after every render. Now,
again, I've said this already 30,000 times,
but it's very important. What is the use state
doing?
It preserves the value. And it triggers rerender.
So what do you think is going to happen right
now? Everything was fine. With console log,
we did not trigger a rerender. That was fine.
But with this one, what are we doing over
here? So we're getting to users, then I call
set users, I update this, I update users.
Now, what is that doing in return? that triggers
a rerender? Now, what are we doing in the
rerender, we're getting users. And then again,
we're setting users. So essentially, we're
sending up a infinite loop. So if you're on
this, essentially, your browser will clash.
Now, it's not the end of the world. But that's
why I commented out because I don't want my
browser to crash, if you want to test it out,
be my guest. Again, it's not the end of the
world. But essentially, you will have the
infinite loop. Because in your function that
you call in the user fact, you are triggering
rerender, because you call set users. And
once you trigger rerender, again, you call
user, and on and on and on and on. So what
is the solution? Simple. Out here dependency,
right? Correct. Something we already talked
about. And in this case, I only want to run
once the component renders. So I'll add empty,
dependency West. Correct. So now everything
should be fine. Where I think I can just comment
on the log or your reference. And I can call
set users. And if I don't have the infinite
loop, then life is great. So now, of course,
what I would want is iterate over those users.
So again, we'll set up curly braces, we'll
say users have no map. So we're mapping over
for each and every user. Of course, I'll have
my parameters. So call this user. And as far
as the return, I don't know, I'm going to
go with a list item. And you know what, I
think I'll place this in the unordered list,
showed me fix this a little bit where I'll
be on our list. Let's add a class name. And
by the way, this class is coming from the
images, just adds a little bit of styling.
And then let's wrap our users in that unordered
list. And then for each and every user, course,
like I said, I'm returning a list item. Now
user is an object, and I'll right away, set
up my destructuring, where I'm looking for
ID login, and then avatar, and then URL. Now
if you want to console log, you want to see
what is the user Be my guest. But in order
to speed up everything on won't do that turn
here, I'm going to say HTML URL, these are
just the properties that are on the object.
And that is coming from my user. And as far
as the list item, remember each and every
time we have a list, we needed to pass this
unique key. And of course, this is what I'm
doing over here. And then for the user, or
want to have the image as far as the source
is equal to the avatar, underscore URL. And
as far as the alternative, you know what,
let's pass in the login, just so we have some
reasonable value. And let's go with a dev.
So right next to our image, we're gonna have
a dev with a hearing for and then let's place
here to login. Matt is going to be
My name, once I save, it should look something
like this. And then right below it, let's
add a link that just links back to a user
profile. So here we will go with HTML URL.
Let's just type profile like so. And we are
in good shape, we're essentially within a
matter of minutes, we set up a data fetching,
where we're looking for get up users. Again,
the biggest takeaway would be the fact that
if you have some kind of functionality within
the function, whether that is directly in
a callback function, or within one of the
functions that you're calling within the callback
function of the use effect, if you are triggering,
re, render, make sure that you the dependency,
alright. So our either you only run it once
the kimono renders or if certain values change,
but be very, very careful of how you set this
up. Because essentially, if you will fail
to do that, then you'll get the infinite loop.
Again, I keep on repeating, it's not the end
of the world. But it might just get annoying
to keep on restarting your browser, just because
you're not checking when you are triggering
the rerender. And of course, when the use
effect runs, as well done on completing the
use effect part of this tutorial. And before
we jump over to the project and start practicing
by building something useful, I would want
to cover one more topic. And that is not going
to be a hook or it is going to be a very important
topic. And that is conditional rendering.
And essentially, what that means is that we
will display different components or different
content based on some condition. And then
once we cover this topic, yes, then we will
right away, jump over to project and practice
it. So let's start first by importing a specific
file. And you can probably already guess that
we're looking for folder number three. And
name is conditional rendering, of course,
we're working in setup. And we're looking
for this multiple returns file. So here in
the app j s, I'm going to go with import.
Again, I'll call this setup from online, we're
looking forward tutorial, we're looking for
conditional rendering,
setup, of course. And finally, the multiple
returns file. And I'm here, let's run the
setup component. And let's see what we got.
And we should see on the screen simple, multiple
returns. So what is happening over here? Well,
if you take a look at the component, you know
that it is a function. Correct? Now, what
can we do in a function as far as returns?
Well, we can have no returns, of course, that
just means that we're returning undefined,
which will be an issue or you fall comment
this out, where you know that there's going
to be a big fat issue. However, what it also
means that we can have multiple returns
based on some condition, I can, for example,
return one piece of content. And if the condition
is not met, then of course, I can return something
else. So how is that going to look like? Well,
I could simply say before the return before
the multiple returns, I can just return a
HelloWorld correct. Everything is going to
work nicely. I have hello world. Why not?
Because in JavaScript, we know that once we
have our first return, and of course everything
else is just ignored. So those would be the
basics. However, what we're looking for is
some kind of condition. And of course, based
on that condition, then we are returning some
type of content. So how is it gonna look like
well, the most basic example, we're just gonna
go here with loading
and then set loading. Now by default, we'll
set our loading to be true. So I'll say yeah,
loading is true. And once I have my state
value, I'm simply going to set up a condition
where if loading is true, ran out one to return
a Heading Two, with text of loading one show.
However, if the loading is not true, Van I'll
simply return the heading two with multiple
terms. If the condition is met, van, we are
returning a heading two
So however, loading data that if the condition
is not true, which of course, we'll change
it in a second, then we'll have our multiple
returns. So the moment I have loaded, Why?
Well, because the loading is true. So now,
of course, I'm returning this heading two,
please keep in mind, you can set up the whole
app in here. As far as this return, nothing
stops you from adding Dibs from adding models,
or whatever you would want. I mean, you can
go as crazy as you feel. Okay, just keep in
mind that if the condition is not met, then
of course, you have your default one. So your
turn the Heading Two, with multiple returns,
again, you can set it up the whole application
here, the way we can test that is by just
passing in false. Now, of course, we have
multiple turns. This is somewhat typical,
where there's some kind of loading state,
you literally can't check for loading, or
if the user exists, or something of that sort.
And then if the condition is met, then you
display one part of the application, one giant
component with multiple other components.
And that if the condition is not met, then
of course, you display a signup page, or something
of that nature. So hopefully, the basics are
clear. Where since it is a function, we're
going to multiple returns. Now, of course,
if we don't set up the condition, then we'll
just return the first one, because all the
other ones will be ignored. How if we start
setting up conditions, nothing stops us from
setting up returns within those conditions.
So if the condition is met, we'll have one
return if the condition is not met, and of
course, we have a different type of return.
Now way, of course, you can make your components
way more dynamic, because now they're not
static. Now they return based on some type
of condition. Once we've got basics out of
the way, of course, let's take a look at the
more complex example, where we're performing
some type of data fetching. And then we have
the loading state, we have the error state.
And then we have the final state if everything
was successful, because otherwise, you're
probably thinking, well, there's probably
no scenario where I will be statically, changing
the data from true to false, meaning, of course,
I would want to do it somehow dynamically.
And one very good use case is by setting up
some type of data fetching, which we already
covered in years. But of course, in this case,
it is just going to be a little bit different,
where I would want to still keep my loading.
So that stage, we still have our set loading,
that also can stay. And as far as you state,
you can go with true initially, or you can
go with false, that is up to you. In my case,
I'm going to go with Trump. So initially,
the loading will be true. And then I would
want to more state values. And those are going
to be error. So in here, we'll say is our
and by the way, again, this is one of those
common scenarios, where a convention is to
use this is if you have some kind of bullion
online, whatever name, again, there's no rule
for it is just something that you will see,
I would say somewhat a lot more people just
add this is whatever is the name. And then
of course, we still have our set function.
But again, it is just a naming convention.
If you don't want, you don't need to follow
it. And again, we're setting up a state value.
And by default error will be false. And let
me add that is in front of the loading as
well. So it's loading.
And then set is learning. And the last one
will be user. And essentially, as you can
already see by the URL will just be checking
for one GitHub user. And if the user exists,
beautiful, will display some data, just some
very basic data. If we are loading and of
course will display one content. If there's
an error, there's going to be another content.
And eventually, if there is a user, then of
course, everything is great. The user will
be displayed. And in here, we'll have a set
user and use state. And we'll go with default
user. Awesome. Now, like I just said, we'll
be performing a fetch request. And we already
know that we will need a user. That's why
it is important. But before we do anything
allegedly decide, well, what we're going to
display based on those values, and we'll start
by loading and we'll say if
is loading is true. And just to showcase that
we can add way more than just the heading
to, I'll just place a div. Again, let's just
signals that you can have as big of as the
return you'd want over here. So let's just
write loading, and then dot.so. That happens
if the loading is true. Now in this case,
we also have the is error, correct. So in
here we go is error.
Again, on just skip a little bit by copying
and pasting. And now say there was an error
or error, something rather nice,
short and sweet. So let's say that, of course,
now we have loading. Why not because this
is true. All right. And then as far as there,
it is false to begin with. And then eventually,
we have the default case. So if there is no
loading, if there's no error, then of course,
I would want to display my user, which simply
will be a div, same way,
where we have the heading one, I'll just display
the user. So you can probably already guess
that, if I'll set my loading to be false.
Now, none of the first conditions are met.
So we just go with the default cache, where
we display our user, but the moment loading
will be true. And of course, it will be displayed.
So that is good. That is going to be our return.
So now let's set up our fetch request in the
use effect, where we will control our conditions.
So let's go with use effect. Let's pass in
the callback function. Now, our right away
set up a second argument, I already covered
why we're using it. So please, if you need
to go back, go back to the last video of use
effect, where we covered that in detail. Because
I don't want to repeat myself, all right away
at this empty array, meaning it will just
run once. Once we do it, let's err on fetch.
Let's go with URL. As you can see, in this
case, I'm not using async await. And I'm typing
everything within a callback function, just
to showcase that, as always, you have multiple
words, or you can achieve the same thing.
So you don't think that you always need to
use a separate function that is async await.
Now, that is my preference, because I find
the syntax to be more straightforward, but
you don't have to. And then we know that with
French, we have that then because of course
we're getting back the promise. And then we
still need to go with our JSON. So let's go
to response.
And now I want to return response. json on
my and also I could set up a catch. If there's
error. Let's just start by console logging
the error.
There's going to be a little bit of code in
here. Because as far as the fetch, you know,
has a gotcha. Now at the moment, we fetch
everything we return JSON. Beautiful, what
are we doing after that? Well, in between,
we'll set up another dot event. And here we
should have the user. So let's set up our
function again. User for the time being, let's
just log whether we're getting the user. So
let's say right here.
And then if we inspect, we should see a user
now of course we do. So that is our object.
So we successfully set up a fetch request.
So now the question is or how we can start
operating with these vowels? Well, first,
we need to understand when are we calling
this function. So in my case, if I said loading
right away to true, when I would want to change
it, well, I guess when I get my data, correct.
So once I successfully my user, then of course,
I am good to go. Now, if of course the user
doesn't exist, then it's going to be a different
ballgame. Shown here, let's add curly braces,
like so. And now let's just set up a user
first. And then let's hide that loading. Now
I already know that user will be here and
login. That's what I would want to actually
display. So since the user is an object, I'll
just say const. And I'll be looking for the
login that is coming from the user. And then
I have two functions. I have set user and
then I have set is loading, since my initial
loading is true, since it is shown. Now of
course, once I have the user, then I would
want to hide. So first, I'll set up set user
and I'll pass in my login. That's the only
thing that I'm looking for.
Second thing is set is loading. And now of
course, I would want to set it equal to false.
Why? Well, because I have my data correct.
Instead of default user, now I have my login.
Now I have the name of my user. And then once
I set the login, and of course I can right
away call set is loading. So once we'll save,
we'll notice that we have our initial state
of loading. And then once we have our data,
everything is exactly like we expected. Okay,
so that's the first thing that we can do with
multiple returns, where we have a loading
state, which is either displayed right from
the get go. Or another way, you could do it
like this, where you say false. So technically,
it's not displayed. But when you set up your
fetch, or right before, I guess, we can set
up loading. That is true. So that is another
option that you can do. So let's go here.
So it is loading. And we'll set it equal to
true. And now what you'll notice, first, again,
we have this for split second loading. And
then, of course, eventually, we change the
state, we say set is loading is actually equal
to false. And then of course, instead of is
loading, which was true in the beginning.
Now we just go with our default one. Okay.
Hopefully that is clear. Now, again, I'm just
going to go by default, set it to true. And
then here, I said, set is loading false, which
is remembered, you have this option, as well.
Now, if you want to see that loading for longer,
the only thing you need to do is just go to
New Window, run again, or start a localhost
online, I'm going to go with 3000. And in
here, we can just slow down the network a
little bit, just so you can see.
We do that in network. And I'm going to be
looking for three G, the first one online,
once I refresh, notice, there's going to be
a loading dadadada dot. And then once we get
the data, then of course, we fall back. Hopefully
this is clear. As you can see, it's not like
every time we'll just do that manually changing
these values. Notice how this is happening
dynamically. Now, one problem with a fetch
is that when you talk about this error, essentially,
you're not talking about 404, for example,
you're talking about the networker. So what
I'm trying to say is, if I add here, Ash,
not technically, that kind of user doesn't
exist, but it is not going to trigger my error
over here. Okay. And this is why we'll have
to do a little bit of dancing around, where
when we are getting the JSON right before
that, essentially will check what is the status
of our response. Again, this has nothing to
do with react, it has to do with fetch, where,
as far as built in functionality, it doesn't
trigger the error if the status is four or
four, which means that there is no such user.
So how we would fix it, like I said, we would
set up all here curly braces, because there's
going to be a bit more functionality. Here
within the curly braces, I will check what
is the status of my response. And if the status
is between 203 100, then I would want to return
JSON, because I know that everything is correct.
However, if the status is not between two
and 300, then of course, I'll throw the error.
So then eventually I'll call this set is again,
for example, with axios, you'd have different
setup because axios deals with those kinds
of errors. But as far as fetch, when you talk
about catch, you're not catching here, the
404 b not found, you're just catching the
networker. That's why we're doing this whole
setup.
Like I said, I'll go with response and then
status. Also if it is bigger or equal to 200.
And let's do the AND operator response, and
status status, less of 299 299. If that is
the case, then I would want to return my JSON.
So say here return all look for response.
json server that is the case however, if it
is not a case, if it is four or four, like
we have over here, then I'll set up my house.
Again, I'll have to set is loading to false,
because initially in my case, it is true.
Then next, we would need to set is error.
So now of course I would want to try
That state set his error. And now of course,
we're setting it equal to true. So now we
can already guess that, where we have these
multiple returns, this will meet this condition.
So his error now will be true, correct. And
once that is the case, we should see this
error dadada. And then again, it's not a reacting,
but I'll also throw the error. So I'll say
here throw new
error. And I'll go the response. And then
status text. Usually, that's where we can
find more info. Of course, this is not correct,
it needs to be. And once we save, notice,
now we have the error. So we have error data.
So first we were loading, you can clearly
see that once I refresh, for split second,
we're loading. And then since our URL is incorrect,
since there is no user, we are hearing the
error, of course. And then since we're hitting
the error, now we're displaying Dev, and then
heading one with error dadada. And, as a side
note, of course, you can place your spinners
or whatever you would want. So once we start
working on more interesting projects, you
will see how that works as well. But essentially,
the main idea is following where we can have
multiple states. And depending on that state,
we are setting up the returns. Again, keep
in mind, you can return different components,
you can return a bunch of HTML elements, or
whatever you'd want. This is just a most basic
example. Okay, hopefully that is clear. Let
me go back to a proper user. And now as you
can see, I first have the loading, then since
there is no error, I'm just setting up the
user and removing the loading, because I said
set is loading equal to false, beautiful job.
And up next, we're short circuit evaluation.
Hopefully, you're clear with that concept,
because it is coming from the JavaScript now
I will try to cover the basics. Or if you
need to brush up, then please do that. Because
again, this is just straight up JavaScript.
Or of course, we will take a look at the React
implementation of setup. And we're looking
for conditional rendering, learn we're looking
for setup, of course, and short circuit file,
we save there is short circuit. Now of course,
we can navigate to that particular file, file
number two, and this is what I'm talking about.
If you need to Google hard works and draws
to please do so. Because again, everything
we're going to talk about in this video is
based off of that. So we have short circuit
evaluation. And the reason why would want
to use it because in react when we talk about
the JSX, we talk about the fact that it has
to return a expression, correct, meaning has
to return a value. And that's why we set up
a expression. So for example, if I have here,
a fragment, and then within this fragment,
if I would want to set up a if statement,
where I have the expression, this won't work,
because as far as if it doesn't return a value.
So if I'll try to go here with console log
on, say hello world, it's not going to work.
And it's not because I didn't pass any condition
over here is just not allowed in react. So
this is why we will heavily work with short
circuit operators, as well as the ternary
operator to display something conditionally.
Because we already covered it, of course,
we have multiple returns. But what if I would
want to have a one return. But again, based
on some condition, there's going to be either
some data shown or hidden stuff along those
lines. So first, I'll comment this out just
so you can see that this will throw an error.
And now let's set up some state value. And
also, let's set up some returns. So first,
I'm going to go with some kind of text and
I'll say set text function that will be equal
to use state and then it's just going to be
a empty value. And now notice here I have
some stuff that has been commented out. So
on commented an aria first value, the second
value, and the first goes we have the OR operator
and then in the second case, we have the AND
operator and now let's just see what
What are the values, I'm going to go with
heading one, I guess, I'll just get the first
value. First value.
I'm going to go with a heading one one more
on, let's just look at the second value, second
value. And once I render, I can see that the
first value is equal to a Hello World. And
the second value, I just found the value.
And basically the way it works in JavaScript,
when we're talking about the or on operators,
for example, 40. Or if this is false, the
meaning false. And of course, it is false.
Because it is an empty string, then we essentially
return the second route. That's why where
we have the empty string that is fuzzy. So
that evaluates to false, then we have our
operator, and essentially, the second value,
the one that is right, from the OR operator
will be returned. That's why when we take
a look at the first value, that's where you
can see the Hello World. Now, if I'll change
this around and add one letter, meaning now
it's not going to be a empty string, now,
it's not going to be fuzzy. Now, essentially,
it will evaluate to true, you'll notice that
now the value is k. So since this is truthy,
now, it's not going to return a second value.
Now, essentially, it will return that first
one. Now, when we talk about an operator,
it works a little bit differently, where if
this is truthy, which of course is now the
case, then we will return the second value.
Now, if it is fuzzy, like we had a previous
case, violin is going to return that first
value, which of course, in our case, is that
empty string. Okay. Now, of course, you can
console log, and you can see second value
in a console, we should see that a is going
to be empty, essentially. Correct. So if it
is true, then it returns this one. If it is
not true, then it returns of that first one.
Okay, so kind of the opposite. One is the
our operator, and then the second one is the
operator. All right. Now, why am I showing
you all this? Well, because we can use that
when we're setting up the expression in the
JSX. That's why it is so important. And I'll
start by simply showing you the example of
name. So I'll leave this for your reference.
I think I'll comment these ones out as well,
just in case you would need it present. Let's
imagine this scenario, where what if I have
a new one. And as far as the text, I would
want to display that text that I have over
here. But the thing is, I also would want
to set up some kind of default, if it is a
empty string. So if I go here with text, everything
is great. But of course, says the text is
empty string, and nothing is displayed. Correct.
So now I can use my OR operator. And I can
say You know what? If the text is halsy, then
return some kind of default value, just like
we were doing here with the variable. But
of course, now we're doing that in react.
Now say, if the text is there, awesome, great.
If the text is not there, then please return
john doe. And of course, since it is false,
it routes false. And now we're turning this
around. Now, if I add something here, if I
say Peter, now of course, you'll notice that
this is true thing. So now this gets returned.
Okay? Now another thing you can do is of course,
use the Add operator. Now an operator we use
a little bit differently, where again, we
will set up the curly braces. In here we're
checking for the text value. And if it is
true, then we're returning that element. Okay,
so in this case, we were returning the element
regardless, but using the AND operator, we
can trigger the showing or hiding of the component
or the element in this case. But you can also
of course do it with components. So for example,
if the text is true, then I'll say that I
would want to display the Hello World. Hello
World. Correct. Now if the text is not true,
meaning if it is going to be empty
The VLAN, you'll see that nothing gets displayed,
okay. So that is the difference. In this case,
if it is true, then of course, we display
the first one, if it is false, then we display
whatever is on the other side of the OR operator.
However, with and it is the opposite. If this
is true, only, then I will return this particular
element. If it is not true, then you can see
that, nothing will get rendered. And by the
way, you can double check that by looking
at the elements.
Or notice if you're checking the route, you
can see that you have the container, and the
only one is played is this one.
Because this is false, we use that is an empty
string. That's why we're not returning it.
And of course, we can also do the opposite,
where I copy and paste. And I'll say, you
know what, if this is false, then returning,
so we can kind of flip it by using the NOT
operator, that is also the possibility. And
now you will see that of course, there's going
to be a Hello World on a screen. Why? Because
now in this case, I'm saying, you know what,
if it is not true, if it is not true than
returning, again, of course, we'll add some
more dynamic setup a little bit later on.
But just keep in mind that everything that
we are going to talk about and use. And the
examples and projects later on, is based on
this short circuit evaluation that I covered
a little bit in the beginning. So if you need
to go and research that, please do so. But
the way it works in react is when we use the
wrapper, if this will be true, meaning if
this is going to have rallied to true, then
this value will be returned. Or if it is positive
or false, then the value on the other side
of the OR operator will be returned. However,
when we talk about and if the value will be
true. So if it will evaluate the true, then
of course, we will return whatever he is on
the other side of the an operator However,
if it is going to be false, and of course,
we won't return anything. Now we also have
option to check for the opposite value. And
that is also the case. So here the only difference
is that I'm saying you know what, show the
heading one, if it is false, which of course
it is palsy, so it evaluates to false. So
we are in good shape. So those are the basics
of how react implements short circuit evaluation,
my bad and bad. Hopefully, we are comfortable
with short circuit operators. Next, I would
want to add a button to the mix. So that way,
we'll see how we can set this up dynamically.
Essentially, instead of hard coding, of course,
this will depend on the value. And mine will
change that value using the button. And then
also to want to talk about the ternary operator.
And why is that useful? All right, so let's
start, I guess by setting up our button. So
right below the heading one, or Yeah, I think
the heading one is going to be the best case
scenario, we're going to go with button.
And then again, a little bit of styling, so
it'll say class name, not equal to A btn.
And then inside the button will write toggle
error, toggle on error. And now let's imagine
that we're going to have some kind of state
show, of course, this is going to be the error
state. And then I'll toggle it using this
button, show up where I have the text. And
you know what, whether we're at this point,
can just come in there mode, I'll create another
state variable,
it's going to be error. So I'm going to say
is error. And then of course we have set function
as well set is her man in here that is equal
to a US state. And by default, it is going
to be false. So by default, there is no or.
And now what I would want is to set up some
kind of element, same like we did with heading
one over here, or you're not having we're
gonna do the same one. Hopefully you have
it for your reference. Because what I'm gonna
do right now is just change it around a little
bit, where instead of relying on text I'm
learning to rely on is error. So I'm gonna
say his error. And now what I'm trying to
say is that if the error is true, then I'll
want to display this hidden one. So of course
we can change that.
text as well. So say here error, and then
three dots. Now, of course, the moment I save,
I have nothing there. Correct? Why? Well,
because here I'm checking whether the error
is true. And we know that with an operator,
only if this is true, and of course, will
display the heading one, unless we the exclamation
point. And of course, I'm checking if this
is false or false. And then I'm displaying
the heading one. So now of course, I can see.
But I actually would want to only display
If the error is true. And now I would want
to use this button to toggle the error using
the set function. And the way we can do that,
is by turning on click over here, then again,
we'll need our inline function. And also here,
set is error. And then I'll use again, the
exclamation point. And I'll say is error.
So what's the code saying over here? Well,
I'm calling set is error. But then on all
the time grabbing the opposite value of the
current is error. So currently, is error is
false. Correct? That's the default, how the
first time I click it is going to check. All
right, what is the value that is false? Sure,
let me flip his error to true, because that
is going to be opposite. And then of course,
the next time when it is already true, then
again, we run the same functions. Now, of
course, it will change it back to false. So
essentially, we set up a toggle state, where
the moment I click, notice, now I'm displaying
the error, why not because I change the value
in the state, I change it from false to true.
And I think this would be a good use case
for react dev tools. So let's go with localhost
3000.
And remember, we had to look for components
here. So let's say where it is where it is
profiler components. And of course we have
short circuit, and check out the state we're
gonna have state is false. So the moment I
click, notice, now it's going to be true.
Okay. So again, once we click, we flip it
back to false. So essentially, this is how
we're toggling the state. And as we're toggling
the state, we're also toggling this heading
one, because we're using the AND operator.
And only if this is true, when display. If
it is false, then of course, we don't display
it, right. And also take a look at the ternary
operator. And the difference between a ternary
operator. And the OR operator is the fact
that ternary operator will give you two possible
values. So for example, in this case, I'm
checking for his error, only if it's true,
then I'll display our ternary operator, we
will display something if it is false. And
then something else if it is true. Again,
it is just a JavaScript thing. So if you need
to go brush up on that, please do so you can
Google it, or you can use my playlist. It's
up to you. But essentially, we'll deal with
the ternary operator
syntax for ternary operators following where
we have a question mark, then we have first
thing that we would want to show if it is
true. And then the second thing if it is false.
So in our case, I think I'm going to do the
same thing we use error. So let's set up the
curly braces first. Again, we'll check for
his error, whether it is true or false. And
then the syntax for ternary operators following
where we add a question mark. And then like
I said, even this is true, then we'll have
our first value. If it is not true, then we'll
place the value after the colon. So in our
example, what I would want to display Well,
if it is true, I would want to display a paragraph.
And I'll say some kind of tax. Now again,
keep in mind, you can set up whatever you'd
want over here, you can add 10,000 components
that are sitting in one giant component. In
my case, I'm just showing you with paragraph.
But sky is the limit. Just remember that as
far as text, I'm going to say there is error.
And again, we go with three dots. So this
is going to be the case if the error is true.
Of course we know that by default is not the
case. Now after the colon will place one will
display If the error is false. So notice in
here, we had no fallback case. We only display
if this is true. In this case, though, we
do have it
know if this is true, beautiful will display
the paragraph. However, if it is not true,
not me showcase that we can set up something
more complicated. I'm going to go with div
within a div, there's going to be heading
two. And I'll say there is no like show. And
once we'll save, check it out. Now it says
there is no error. Why not simple? Because
error, of course, is false. Correct. So if
it is false, then of course, we skip the first
part, because we check what is the value 40
is error. And of course it is false. So we
skip this one, the paragraph, and then we
right away, go to the second value. That's
why we have here, there is no error. Now the
moment I will click, notice what's going to
happen. So first, I'll have my error, we already
covered up because that is of course, our
operator, but then I have my paragraph with
there is a error. So those are the ways how
we can display elements or components conditionally
in react, because Please keep in mind, we
cannot use if, because if doesn't return the
value, need to use something that returns
the value, whether that is a short circuit
operator, or that is a ternary operator. Alright,
and once we're clear with ternary operator,
now I would want to set up a small example
where we will toggle the component in this
case, and in a process, I'll try to hammer
home, why we need the cleanup function. So
there's going to be a little bit of repetition.
Eventually, we will set up again, the event
listener on the window. And I'll showcase
why it is important to use the cleanup function,
because setting up the dependency list empty
is not always going to save us. All right.
Now what we're looking for in the app, Jess
is File Number three, still conditional rendering
still set up, or in this case I'm looking
for, and then forward slash, and then of course,
show and hide. So the moment you're on it,
this is what you're going to see. Now I'm
going to navigate the file. So again, in the
setup folder, File Number three, show and
hide in first out want to set up a state value.
Again, we have the use state, let's go and
say const. Show and then set show function.
All right, bad. And that is equal to use state.
And by default, it is going to be false. All
right. Now as far as the return, let's make
it a bit more interesting. More. First, I'll
set up my fragment. And we'll start with a
button, I will say that there is a class name
for the button. And the class name is button,
of course. And then remember how we were toggling
the state value. Again, we'll do the same
thing where we have onClick, then we'll have
our inline function. And then let's run set
show. And each and every time we'll click,
we will set the new state value opposite to
the current one. So if it is false, then it's
going to become true, if it is true, and it's
going to become false. And here, let's type
show an forward slash hide, let's save. Okay,
we should have the button. Everything is awesome.
And now depending on that show value, I will
show or hide another component. So that is
going to be the difference where I previously,
I mentioned multiple times that we're not
limited to HTML elements. So of course, this
is the example where we will toggle the React
component. And for the time being, it's simply
going to be a div. So let's go with div. And
I'll add a little bit of styling here. Minimal,
go with a margin top amount is going to be
equal to two RMS. And then within the Dev.
Let's again go with window window, and we'll
check for those pixels. So for the time being,
of course, we haven't set up anything, so
I'm just gonna say size, and then colon. So
once we save, we should see something on a
screen, but of course we don't, because we
haven't implemented that show. So what I would
want here is set up curly braces, and then
I'll say if show is true, then we'll use the
AND operator and then I would want to display
the item component. Now of course I do need
to be a bit more specific here, where it is
a component. Now of course it is hidden where
we hope
But then the moment we click Check it out
my window size. So as you can see, now I'm
toggling the component. Correct.
It is important because of two reasons. First,
the fact that we're not limited to just HTML
elements, like we had in a previous example.
And a second thing, I would want to hammer
home, the fact that we need to use the cleanup
function, when we're setting up some kind
of side effect that needs to be cleaned up,
which in our case, is still going to be that
event listener on window. So within the item,
not within the show and hide component within
the item, what I want is to set up that size
state variable. So again, we go here with
const, on size, and size, like so. And now
we're using huge stay. Again, let's check
for a window in our width. Beautiful. And
then we will set up each and every time when
we render the component, our use effect.
So we're going to go here with use effect.
Now we have our callback function, just to
showcase that it's not going to work if we
simply are empty array. Now, let me add here
window,
the event listener. So as we'll be resizing
the window, we'll be listening for this event.
So resize,
we'll run our check size, like I said, a little
bit of repetition, because we already set
this up when we work with us. Now, of course,
let's come up with our function. Sure, it's
going to be check size function, not going
to be looking for any parameters. However,
each and every time, we'll resize the window,
I will set my state value equal to a window,
and then in our width. Okay, beautiful. And
I remember when we covered use effect, I said
that even though in that particular scenario,
the empty dependency array saved us. Because
we were not toggling the component. Essentially,
the component was there. And the first time
the compound rendered, we set up the event
listener, and we were good to go. However,
the problem now is going to be that we will
be toggling this component. So even though
we run this only once, because we will toggle
the component. Essentially, we will set up
multiple event listeners, I guess, in order
to see better what is happening, let's just
go with size here in adding to show now once
I click Check it out. Now, of course, the
window is 462. By the way, we can add pixels
as well if we would want. So let me go here
with pixels. Again, I show and then as I'm
going to be increasing or decreasing the size
of the window, of course, this value will
change. Now the problem is a little bit different,
where every time notice, as I'm clicking on
toggling the component correct. And if we
check out the elements and non event listeners,
and then research notice, is this the behavior
that we're looking for? No, of course, it
is not. So even though empty array saved us
in the previous example, because we were not
toggling the component. This is why this cleanup
function is so important. Because even though
this runs only once, because we're toggling
the component, we run every time we show the
component. So that's why remember, we need
to go with return. And we have the function
once when of course the component is removed
and discuss Of course, once we removed from
the DOM, and we'll go with window, then remove
event listener. Again, I'm looking for resize
on our on check size. So now what you'll notice
that once you navigate here, well, you can
see that there is no event listener. That
should be the case because the component is
not displayed. Then the moment we show the
component, then of course, we set up the first
event listener. But then as I'm clicking,
notice, I'm not going to be adding those event
listeners. So there's always going to be one
because we have our cleanup function. So once
we remove the component from them using the
show, toggle, and of course it will also remove
our event listener. So that's how we can toggle
component
In react using the operator, and also that's
why it is so so crucial to use the cleanup
function. Excellent. Up next in the tutorial
we have the forms. More specifically, we're
going to cover controlled inputs, what they
are and how they work, and also how we can
set up multiple inputs with just one function.
Before we cover any of those topics, though,
our just want to give you general info about
the how the forums work and react. So we'll
start working and control the inputs, but
we'll cover them in a next video. In the beginning,
I would just want to give you the general
overview.
The Fall, of course that we're looking for
years. Again, I'll call this setup, just so
I don't have to change stuff around in here.
And also tutorial when we're looking for to
folder number four forms. When set up, of
course, we're looking for controlled inputs.
And now instead of deciding to all around
the mine setup murders,
if you're working with forms in JavaScript,
you know that it works, something along the
lines of setting up some kind of ID or class
or whatever the input, then you targeted the
input. And then in order to get the value,
you are looking for the value property on
the node. Now interact, it's a little bit
different, where you have those controlled
on controlled inputs. By the way, we'll talk
about uncontrolled inputs when we talk about
use ref. But whenever we deal with controlled
inputs, you will be hooking up your input
to a state value. And since it's going to
be easier for me to show, of course, let's
just put this one on ice, just remember what
the setup is going to be a bit different than
a regular JavaScript. So what I would want
to do first, well, I think we could change
our JSX a little bit more or start with article,
by the way, there's going to be two articles,
one is going to be displaying the items. And
the second one will be dealing with forum.
So let's just start with the form. And then
next video, we'll add those items as well.
When it comes to a form, we're not going to
deal with action. So we'll deal with that
on our end. Now, I do want to add here a class
name just for styling purposes. And that is
going to be a warm
inside of the form not set up, I think two
inputs is going to be good. So go with form
control. Again, this is just for styling,
please keep that in mind.
Once I save, I should have the form on the
screen beautiful online within the sport control.
Again, this is just for styling, please keep
that in mind. It has nothing to do with react
within this div. Now I would want to set up
my input. But I also want to set up a label
because I would want to showcase how we can
connect label with input in react as far as
the React because the naming conventions in
JSX are calling for camel occurs, you'll see
the syntax where in regular HTML Of course,
you wouldn't write that like this. But in
react if you have label and you want to connect
it to the input that we're about setup, you
need to use this HTML for written in camel
case. And here you need to pass in the ID
that is eventually going to be on the input.
So in my case is going to be first name that
we're marrying it right here. And all right
here name,
colon, like show. And of course, we would
need to set up our input. So I'm going to
go with input. Now type the same works as
with regular HTML. So we are multiple types.
In this case, I'm going to go with most basic
one, which is going to be a text. And then
of course, I would need to have two things,
I would need to have the ID as well as the
name. So we're going to go here with an ID
and also the sequel to a first name, just
like I had in the label. And then let's also
set up the name. So say your name, and that
is equal to a first
name. So say read Emeritus. Now of course,
I have my label. Notice once I click on a
label, I right away highlight a my input.
And of course I have the input. And since
I would want to have two of them, I'll copy
and paste and we just need to change some
values around or form controls. There's exactly
the same
Now it is going to be a bit different. So
let me select both of them, we're looking
for email, and also the name will change.
So let's right over here, email. And by the
way in here, I also would need to change it
to email. And once I have my second input,
I also want to set up right away a button.
So we're going to go here with button, event
type will be met. And here let's just write
add person. And you'll see why we do that
in next video. So we have our button. Awesome.
And then when it comes to react, we have two
options. Either we can add on submit, form,
so the form element, or we can still add on
click on this button, I'll show you in a second.
Both of them will work. But let's start with
onsubmit. Because that is something we haven't
covered. So on a forum, we can set up a submit
event listener. And then of course, we'll
still need our handle. And
workshop, of course, we would want to come
up with that function across online handle,
met. Now eventually there's going to be an
event object. And I'll show you why in a second.
For the time being, let's just go with a little
world. And let's see what is happening. So
I typed my values, both of them will show.
And now Once I press the button, or I press
return, I should I should see hello world
in console. However, it's not happening. Why?
Well, because by default browser will try
to submit the form and then refresh the page.
That's why we don't see this HelloWorld. And
just like in JavaScript, we have access to
the event object. And on that event object,
we have a method called prevent default, we're
essentially we're saying you know what prevented
default behavior, we will deal with this form
data on our own. And so the way we prevent
the default would be falling way where we
go with prevent default. Now, of course, once
we fill it out, either, we can press enter,
or we can press on the button. And of course,
we'll be able to see the hello world. So essentially,
now we're not refreshing the page, the moment
we submit the form, awesome. Just to showcase
that it will still work. If we set this up
on the button with a type of Submit. Let's
go here with on click. It's the same deal
when we pass in animal Submit. Now our movement
for a second even though we'll push it back,
here, again, let's try it out and check it
out, it will still work. So again, that is
the case, where you have multiple options
of how you would want to submit the form in
the React either use this on submit, but make
sure you place it on a form. Or you can still
use the good old on click, make sure that
the button is type Submit. And then of course,
make sure that you in both scenarios as brahmer.
In this function, you are accessing the event
object. And then however you want to call
this brahmer. In my case, I call this E and
you can look for the properties that are available
on that event object. So my guess our move
this on click. So that would be a basic setup
when it comes to forms in react. Nicely done.
Hopefully we are clear on basics. Now let's
see how we can connect our input to the state
values. Because at the moment, yeah, we can
prevent a default, we can console log hello
world. But of course, what I would want is
to access the data that is inside the input
correct as I'm typing or as I'm submitting.
And the way we do that in react, we set up
state values. So again, we'll use use
not only to add two attributes on the input
value, that will reference the stored value.
And then on change on change event listener
will fire the callback function each and every
time we type something in the input. And I
guess let's start by setting up our state
values. So here I'm going to go with cons
on first name, and then I'll say set,
first name, first name and that is equal to
my use
straight on by default, it is just going to
be an empty string, I'll copy and paste. And
of course, I'll do the same thing with email,
where it's going to be an email and then set
email. And again, by default, it is going
to be a empty string. So now what I would
want is to head to my input. And then like
I said, we have to add two attributes, one
is going to be value. And the second one will
be on change event listener, where we'll set
up our callback function. So in here, let's
write value. And now which value would want
to reference from the state? Well, I guess
most sense would make personnel correct. So
again, I'll just referencing here, the state
value. And now I'll do the same thing with
my email. So again, we go with value online,
we're looking which state value would want
to reference. And the moment you do that,
you'll notice something interesting. First
of all, there's going to be a big fat error,
because react will complain, or maybe more
specifically a warning, where react will complain
that I provided value prop. However, I missed
out on the on change handler. Memorial react
will be on change handler a little bit later.
Now, I would just want you to understand that,
notice how you're typing, and nothing is happening.
Why nothing is happening? Well, because we
connected our forms, meaning our input to
the state routers. So since both of my state
values are empty strings, they all the time
will stay like this. Now, of course, if I'll
say hello, world, of course, in my name, one,
I will have that HelloWorld. Just keep in
mind, of course, now we have connected those
inputs to the state value. The last thing
in a puzzle is to set up that on change. So
each and every time we'll type something in
a form will fire the function. And within
that function, we will set up this state value.
And then in return, you will right away see
it in the form as well. Just hopefully this
is clear, we're now the value in the form
depends on state value, since it is an empty
string. That's why you can type all day long,
and nothing won't change in the form.
With that said, Now let's set up our on change
handler. So we go here with on change. Again,
we can set up a reference, meaning we can
set up a separate function and reference it.
Or we can set up the inline one. Now since
this is already fifth or sixth example of
inline and reference, I'm not going to set
up two separate scenarios, all just do the
inline, where we'll have to pass in our arrow
function first, because again, we will be
invoking. And now we'll go set, first name.
So here comes the interesting part. Remember,
when we were submitting the form, we have
access to the event object. And in this case,
the method that we're looking for on the event
object was prevent default. Now with on change,
we also would want to access the event object.
However, in this case, what we're looking
for is the event target value. So the same
deal, like we had with handelsman, where we
had access to the event object, same works
with onchange, where again, we can access
the event object, or in this case, what we're
looking for is the event, Target, and more
specifically value. So that is going to give
us whatever is typed in the actual input.
So I'm going to go here with event target,
and then we're looking for the value. So now
what you'll notice with the first one, as
you start typing, actually the values are
displayed. And what is even more interesting,
if you go to the components, you'll notice
that the moment there's nothing there. Yeah,
that is true, more controlled inputs, or I'm
sorry, in here. So notice we have the state
value as you start typing. Notice the state
value also changes. So we're affecting that
in two places. Because we have connected our
form each and every time I type something
in the form the on change, function fires.
And then within that function, I have set
first name, and then I'm controlling the state.
Now in turn, I'm also controlling the input.
Remember when it was just
empty string, while we can type all day long,
and nothing was changing in the input. Now,
of course, once we have our on change, we
have the function, we access the event object.
And then in order to get the value for this
particular input, I would need to go with
a rent object. And I'm looking forward to
target and then I'm looking for value. So
similar, like we worked in just vanilla JavaScript,
or in this case, we directly can access our
input, because we have an event object, then
we have a target. So that is going to be our
input. And then more specifically, we're looking
for the value property. And of course, once
we have this set up, I would want to do the
same thing for my email, where I'll copy and
paste
in the email, I'll also do the same thing.
So I have onchange. However, in this case,
of course, I would want to call set email,
my first name, but the event target value,
of course, won't change. So I'm going to go
here with email. And once we do that, check
it out. Now I can type and everything is displayed
correctly. And of course, once we have this
particular setup, now in the handle submit,
instead of looking for specific input, once
I submit the form, now I have access to them
in the state, the first name, as well as the
email. So let's do that. Our will console
log here, the first name, last name, first
name,
or I'm sorry, email, I guess more properly.
So let's type, I'm going to go here, you know
what, let's write some reasonable named john.
And then we're going to go with john@gmail.com.
And once we add the person, there it is. Now
we have
john john@gmail.com. So that's how we can
set up controlled inputs in react. Remember,
you need to have a value property that references
some state value. And then you have on change
event listener, where either you set up a
reference. So either you set up a function
here, like we did with an or submit, just
make sure that in either case, you're looking
for this event. So you pass in that first
parameter, because that will reference the
event object. And then in order to control
the state value, you call the set function.
And then what do you would want to pass in
is the event target. So you're grabbing the
input, and more specifically, you'd want to
get the value for each and every time you
type something in a form. In turn, you'll
change the state value. And since that state
value is referenced over here, also it will
be displayed in the form input. Excellent
work. Now we understand how we can set up
controlled inputs in react. And just to complete
this particular part on forms out also want
to create a little app where we can add about
person to our list, because up until this
time, all the time we work with lists, we
were just getting some kind of data, whether
that was external data coming from the API,
or it was ours. Our in this case, we'll take
a look at how we can add those items dynamically
divorced. Since now we have covered forms,
I can grab more inputs. Now, I'll start simply
by creating my state value for my list of
people. So I'm going to vote people,
people over here that is you state and we
are know that we need to start with an empty
array. Right? Not bad, not bad. Now, what
is the next step? Well, once I submit the
form, I can see that I can grab these values
show Wouldn't it make sense that once we submit
the form, I would want to add that new person
that I'm creating to my people? All right.
I think that would make sense. Now, before
we do anything, well, let's think about it.
Do we want to have the functionality where
once we click, we can also submit the form.
And notice how as I'm clicking on adding the
person, I have to empty routers. Now why do
I have to empty routers? Well, because first
name and email are both empty strings, right?
But nothing prevents me right now. From console
on show. Essentially, if I would want to set
up some kind of functionality where I'm adding
this to a people array. I can definitely do
that. So that's why I'll right away set up
the condition.
Where I'm only going to submit the form meaning
I'm only going to add my item to the array
if both of the values are true, because we
already know that empty string is positive
value. So of course, that condition will fail
if both of them or one of them, essentially
is a empty string. So in this case, I'll say
first name, I'll use an operator, and email.
And what you'll notice that only then I can
submit the form submit the form we form. And
here, let me write empty values. So that is
not the case, of course, the values all will
be empty. So I'll set up the else. And let's
say empty Mars. And you know, I think I will
leave this for your reference. So we'll have
the else there's going to be no modal no info
to the user. But at least we will know that
if we see in console and developers, that
just means that the user is trying to submit
with empty vouchers. Now, if both of them
have some kind of value, what I would want,
I guess, I'm going to start by creating a
new object. So I'm going to go here with const,
online person. And I'll start with first name,
and email. So what's really cool in ear six,
if the property value matches the variable
that you're assigning to, then you can skip
one step where essentially, if I'm creating
a new person, I could say something like this
first name is equal to a first name, and then
email is equal to an email. And now if I add
the value, let me just console log the person
first. But if I'll say here, by the way, let
me save it here. Now, not here, sorry, I'm
confused a little bit, I would want to save
my file first. And let's write again, john.
And we're gonna go john@gmail.com. So once
we add the person, notice how in the console,
I did create this person, I have the object,
and everything works beautiful. Now, the thing
is that I can shorten this a little bit, because
in the last six, we have a shorthand, where
if the key name matches the variable that
holds the value, I can just write something
like this. Where email is email, and first
name is first name, please keep in mind, both
of them essentially have the same value is
just a little short syntax, which I'm going
to use throughout the tutorial, as well as
the course. So if we go here with john@gmail.com,
you'll notice that new person, yeah, we still
have the value. So everything works correctly.
Now, next hour would want to add this new
person to Mirek. Correct? How do we do that?
Well, we go with set people. And just so we
can keep on practicing on a function setup
as well. Remember, that was my old people,
or current people, or whatever. So I will
call this same thing, people just remember
that we're talking about the current value
in the state. And what I would want to return
from this function is data.so, whatever we
have as far as the values in the array, so
we're using the spread operator. And then
of course, I'm returning a new array. However,
I would want to add that person object as
well. Again, I know I said this 20,000 times,
but we also have an option of just passing
this directly in set people. The reason why
I set this up as a function is I would want
you to practice on setting up the function
as well, if you see that in someone else's
code, you're not confused of what is happening.
And now of course, what I would want is also
set both of these, the first name and the
email back to an empty string. Correct. That
would make sense. So let's go with set first
name, now is going to be equal to an empty
string. And I'll have also a set email the
same way. So now, once we click, by the way,
if you want, we can console log it somewhere,
the people or not, let's use the React dev
tools. Sorry. Let's go here to a bigger screen.
Notice I have this value over here, the empty
array. And now if all go again with maybe
Peter,
if also the email at Peter
g gmail.com. Check it out.
Once we have the person, now, we clear this
one, we clear the first and second row in
my state, email, and name respectively, a
man in the state, check it out. Now I have
email, the first name for the Peter. So what
now we can keep on adding more and more people.
Now before we add more people, why don't we
also set up here a return, where we display
what people we have in our array. So again,
we'll iterate over the state value, then each
and every item will be an object. So I'll
name this in my Paramor as a person
as far as the return our return a deer over
here, and I'll go with const, a man ID, a
man first name, first name, email. So essentially,
what I'm doing is, I'm destructuring. My,
you're probably wondering about this ad, well,
don't worry, we will create that Id in a second.
Because remember all the list,
we needed to use something unique here, even
though technically, I could do something like
this index. And I'll set it equal to index.
The problem is we'll start once we start removing
the items. Now, I'm not going to do that in
this particular example. But in general, you
don't want to use index. Once you start adding
and removing items to the list. Or even though
you are technically in this example, we might
let it slide and then use the index, I'm not
going to do that, I'll show you how we can
quickly set up the unique key as far as when
we're creating the person. So for now, let's
just go with Dev. And notice how we destructured
the first name and email from the person.
Because we already know that of course it
is there, because we are creating a particular
object.
And then in here, what I would want is to
have the handling for
all show the first name so reading for
first, ma'am. And I'll also add a class name
of item, just so we have a little bit of styling.
And then let's have the paragraph with a email
site value. So now every time we add something
in a form, that person should be displayed.
Now, React will complain, because we don't
have that unique value in the key warrior
all summed up in a second. So let's go with
Anna. Mine is going to be on
G gmail.com. And yeah, we do have the honor,
everything is displayed correctly. Again,
the problem right now is that unique key prop.
And this is not the most vigorous setup. But
we'll cheat a little bit where I'm going to
use the new date get time to string. Normally,
you'd use some kind of package.
You You rd is one of the most popular ones,
where it's a NPM package installer, you import
it, just like we did with for example, react.
And then you set up that unique ID again,
in my case, I'm just going to cheat a little
bit, where I'll use a nifty set up off ID.
So now notice how I'm creating this new person,
I'll also add this key of ID, and that is
going to be equal to a new gate. And then
we're going to go and get time to string,
we invoke it. And now what you'll notice that
each and every time you create a person, there
is going to be that unique ID. So you fall
console log the person. In this case, we're
going to go with Susan, for example, Susan
on susan@gmail.com, check it out. Once we
are the person, there it is now of course
we have the ID. And the last thing, of course,
is where we are rendering the list of people
now want to also get that Id now I already
destructured out of my person. So now remember,
we needed to use the key prop
and set it equal to the ID. And once we do
that we shouldn't have no issues whatsoever.
We can type whatever names we would want.
And we can clearly see all they're also affected
in our state. So we go here with gmail.com.
Of course, once we are the person, where is
my person in the list, and I can clearly also
see that in a state. And I shouldn't have
no errors in the console, because I am using
those unique keys. So that's how we can combine
our controlled input with our list. So each
and every time we add some kind of item in
the form, we can just submit the form
If values are more than an empty string, and
of course, we trigger this functionality,
where again, we have some kind of state value
for the list. And we just add a new item to
the list, clear the items, set them back to
an empty string. And at the bottom, we just
iterate over the list of items, grab all the
properties that we want, nicely, displaying
them on a screen. Beautiful job. Now we know
how we can use our controlled inputs with
our list. Next, I'll want to showcase how
we can have multiple inputs with the same
on change number. Now, the use case that I'm
trying to showcase is the one with many, many,
many, many inputs. On my case, I'm just going
to add one more to our current setup. But
keep in mind that the whole idea is to show
you what if you would have, I don't know 10
inputs, you don't want to have 10 different
state values than different functions that
you're calling inside of the handler. Now,
first, we will need to navigate to the address.
And we're looking for a different file. In
this case, we're looking for file number two,
and
the multiple inputs is the name. So save it,
and what you will notice that it is exactly
the same, like we finished in the controlled
inputs. And that is by design. So essentially,
I'm not the biggest fan of refactoring. But
this is exactly what we'll do in this video,
where we will refactor it a little bit. So
our whole setup is going to be exactly the
same where we are still submitting the form,
we're still adding the items. And all that
good stuff is just the implementation will
be a little bit different. I would want to
start by adding one more input on again, when
you're looking at this setup, the one that
we're about to set up, please keep in mind
that we're talking about the form with multiple,
multiple, multiple inputs, not just two or
three, we have two or three, probably, there's
nothing wrong with our previous setup. Now
what I would want is to copy and paste, so
we're adding one more item over here, I'll
call this age. So we'll change this around,
we'll say that HTML four will be for age.
So also, of course, the ID will change, we're
going to add here age value as far as text,
let's change the ad to age. Now, we also would
want to change the name, which by the way,
we haven't used it yet. So in this video,
you'll finally see why we're setting up that
name attribute all the time. And then I would
want to get a state bar. So for the time being,
I will copy and paste.
I'll copy and paste and I'll say age and then
set age, by default age will be no no, I think
I'm going to go same way we have an empty
string cared about is going to be my age.
And of course, in here, where I have the value,
the treasure, I would want to change it to
age and set age. So this should work correct.
But wouldn't it be better if we would have
only one value in a state instead of three,
or instead of 10, or 15, or how many inputs
you have. And also wouldn't it be better if
we would have only one function that is responsible
for on change, regardless of which input we're
typing in. Because that way, if we need to
make some changes, we only need to do it in
one place. And we will do that by first setting
up one state value. So instead of first name,
email, the age, I will go with const. And
I'll call this person so say person. And then
of course, there's also going to be a set
person function. Now it is going to be equal
to a US state and now set this equal to A
object, someone wrote first name on that it
will be equal to A empty string, or email,
same spiel, empty string, also the age and
you guessed it, empty string. So once I set
up these values, now instead of using them
one by one first name, email and the age,
now I would want to reference the person and
you're not by the way, I will delete Donald
submit and we will write it from scratch.
So let's just delete it so it's not in our
way. And then eventually we'll set up one
more
Done. And of course, I have my person with
all those three properties. And now, where
we see the inputs, of course, we would also
want to change, or now the value will be person
dot person, not just the person. By the way,
I think in here, I'm just going to comment
this out, or you can delete it, it's up to
you. So we have person, that first name, and
person of that email. And eventually, also,
we have person of that age. Correct. Now,
the gotcha here is that we're still using
these functions. Correct. So we have set email,
we have set age, and all that. Now, there's
a big fat complaint from react, because, of
course, we don't have the handle Submit. And
also, we don't have the functions. So what
I would want to do right now is just delete,
we will flip it over to the submit button.
And as far as the on change, lead, just reference
the function in this case instead, so go with
no man change. So that is, of course, the
function we haven't created yet. We're going
to go with Collins and then handle change.
Again, I definitely would want that event
object. So I need to set up my parameter,
I'll have access to the object. And like I
said, we'll copy and paste. So we'll change
this around, there's not going to be three
separate functions, there's going to be one
function. And again, Frank 15 inputs. That
is where it definitely makes way more sense.
So we have onchange, equal to a handle change.
And then on the submit button, well, let's
go with on click, just so we can see that,
of course it is going to work on in this case,
I'll call this handle shop will scroll up,
crowns on handle.
Right now, still in the same setup, we need
to have access to the event object, and will
right away prevent
the fault arc. So that is the function that
we're looking for. Now, at this point, it's
complaining the handle change is not defined.
So of course, I call this handle. And that's
not what the function name is. So let's say
now we don't have the hairs beautiful. Now
everything works, but it will start to try
typing. Course, again, nothing will work,
or because the handle change is not doing
anything. Now, why am I showing you this particular
setup? Well, because now I would want to run
the handle change, regardless of the input,
I would want to get those values. And depending
on which input I'm changing, I also would
want to affect the person. Now, two properties
that I definitely want from the event object
are the name and the value. So if I go here
with const, name, equal to event, Target,
name, copy and paste. And if we go here with
the value,
changes there around again to event target.
So that is the input where we're typing. Same
how we access value. In my previous case,
remember, in the controlled inputs,
we use the value correct. When we were setting
up the first name or the email, we use event
target so that x is the input. And then we
use dot value property. In this case, I'm
looking for two things. I'm saying whenever
I call my handle, change our own check for
the name of the target, and the name will
be right here. Remember, each and every time
we set up that name attribute on the input.
Well, now we'll use it now say run target
name, and then the var. So if you'll console
log, you'll notice something pretty predictable,
where we go with a name and value. And the
planning depending on which input entrepreneurs,
this tells me that the name attribute on the
input is first name. And then I'm also getting
the values. Now nothing is displayed right
now in the input. Because we haven't updated
the person yet. Meaning we're accessing Of
course, the person that first name, and we're
not doing anything with that person yet. But
don't worry, we'll do that in a second. But
if we change to an email, beautiful on ours
again, it gets me the name of the input. And
it also gets me that current value. And the
same of course, is going to be with an edge.
Now, why is that? So cool? Well because now
once I know the name and the value, I can
use the
Dynamic Object Properties. Again, this is
coming from JavaScript. So please either utilize
my JavaScript nugget series, or just google
dynamic properties, how you would set them
up in JavaScript. So now I have the object,
correct. And of course, the object set person.
So what I could do here is I could say, set
person. And then remember, I need to copy
the old values first. Because since it is
an object, it has multiple properties. As
I'm updating one, for example, name, I don't
want to remove or delete the email and age.
That's why we first start by proper data.we,
copy the person from the state, and then we
add a comma. And then after the comma, we
would want to come up with whichever property
we would want. Now, of course, that is going
to depend on which input we're typing in,
correct. And this is the case where we can
do this dynamically, where I can say, you
know what, get me the name on that object.
Because in here, I'll pass in the value. Now,
what were my values, it was either first name,
it was either email, or it was age, now will
dynamically update this property equal to
whatever value we have, please keep in mind,
it's the same thing as you'd write over here,
first name, and then it is equal to a value.
Now the difference is that we are doing this
dynamically, because we have three inputs.
So if I'll just leave this as a first name,
you'll notice that each and every time I type
something, it's actually displayed over here,
which kind of doesn't make sense, right? Why?
Well, because I'm not selling this dynamically.
I'm saying first name, where if I have access
to the name, and of course, those names need
to match to whatever I have in the object.
Now each and every time, I'll type in any
of the inputs, I'll dynamically update that
state value as well. So that's why I need
to go with that name. And that's why we added
the name, right from the get go. Now, you're
not going to use it all the time. But there's
going to be some use cases where it is very
nifty to update whichever state value references
the input. So now again, let's navigate to
a bigger screen. Notice I have my state. And
now check it out. Where I have the name, I'll
start typing. And there it is, in my state,
in person, right away all access the first
time. And now of course, that it will be equal
to a job. Now if I go with email, I go with
john@gmail.com and murders. Now we have john@gmail.com.
And lastly, we have age of 24. So notice how
nicely, we updated all the routers. And now
what's left to do is again, to submit the
form, so we prevented default. And now I would
want to check if, and in this case, I'm checking
for three things. So first name, and person,
then dot email. And then the last property,
of course, was age. So I only would want to
submit this form, if all three of them
are more than just an empty string. And then
let's do the same thing where we are creating
a new person. Correct. So we go here with
const, then new person. And then as far as
the value out, we want to copy the person
value from the state with this one, since
this is what we're sending up as far as the
input. And now I also would want to add that
ID, someone roll with ID is equal to a new
date.
Get time, good time invoked. And then we have
to string invoked as well. And lastly, let's
just add person to a set people. And then
let's set up person back to an empty string.
So we go with set people. That is my array,
of course. And like I said previously, we
use the function and in this case, I'm just
going to pass in new array, where I'll copy
the values from the state. And then I'll add
that new version. So we're just practicing
in the previous example, where we used a function,
we can also pass directly here to value. And
then like I said, I also want to set person
back to empty values. So we pass in the object,
we say first name is equal to an empty string.
Then email is empty string, and then the age
is empty string. Now, watch this.
going out on a bigger screen, where we go
with Susan, then we're looking for susan@gmail.com.
And on the edge will be 25. And the moment
we add the person veterus, there is our Susan.
Now, if you want, of course, you can add also
in the JSX. That particular age, you've that
what you're shooting for, of course, we're
going to go here with age. And then in the
first name, instead of the first name, we're
going to go with paragraph.
Or let's just say age, like so. Let's try
it out one more time with anna@gmail.com.
She was going to be 26. And of course, the
moment we add the item that is displayed in
our list. So that essentially is how we can
set up multiple values with the same handle
change function. Now, again, are you going
to use that all the time? No, there's going
to be some use cases where it's just going
to be much faster and easier. Instead of setting
up all these multiple servers, separate functions
that update each and every time you type in
the input. In this case, we have the same
function. So even if I would have 20 inputs,
if I want to change something around, I just
need to do that in one place. amazing work,
we're done with forms and take a breather,
we will cover use ref. Remember, when we talk
about forms presented, we have controlled
inputs. But we also have the option of using
on controlled inputs. And we do that using
the use ref.
So even though there are multiple things that
we can do with user F, most popular one is
targeting the DOM element. And essentially
in turn, that allows us to set up uncontrolled
inputs, similar to how we would have been
a JavaScript, not the father, we're looking
for years user folder. And then of course,
we have a setup. And then we have the basics.
In the app JS course I imported a file user
of basics, and I'm just rendering the setup.
If we navigate to use ref basics, we can see
that I have three comments. And essentially,
user ref works a lot like us state corridor
some differences. So as far as similarities,
it also preserves the value in between the
renders, just like you said, however, the
difference is that online use state user of
hook does not does not trigger re render.
Like I just mentioned, one of the most popular
use cases is targeting the DOM element, just
like all the other hooks, we import as a named
import or we use react and then dot and then
whatever the hook name. Now I'll start with
my return because I simply would want to create
a form. So I'm going to go here we form element
will add right away a class class name will
be form, just we have somewhat good looking
form. And then inside of the form, there's
going to be a div with an input text. And
eventually we'll set up our ref. And then
also our want to have my Submit button. So
let's go with button type. And by the way
type needs to be placed here, type. And then
we're looking for the button. And we'll just
type here, a met button. And we should have
a form with a submit button. No surprise there.
Now let's take a look at the handle Submit.
Again, we have the form we can either place
it where we have the button or where we have
the form. Again just to spice things up. We're
gonna go with on Submit. And then of course
we'll have a handler show handle handle
met. All right, awesome. Let's try to submit
our form const.
Met function I would want to have access to
the event ardra show in the primer I type
II Amman first I would want to prevent prevent
the default. And I'm second I'll set up my
use ref. Now the white use RF orcs, we would
need to come up with a name for markers. I'm
going to call this ref
painter and that is equal to a huge array
F and now we need to pass in that in
initial value shall go with user F. And by
default, I'll set it equal to a no. Okay.
Now next thing, we need to use this value,
in my case, a ref container, and then set
it equal to a ref attribute. So in this case,
I have the input, and I have the button. So
what I could do is add this ref attribute,
and I need to set it equal to my ref container.
And once we have invoked use ref, assign it
to a container, bypassing some kind of initial
value, and then use the attribute in our input
and set it equal to the name of that we chose.
Now, of course, let's console log just so
we can see what what is actually a rough container.
So rough container was not as my name. And
we'll notice something interesting where it
is a object.
It is a object with a property of current.
So now what happens when we submit the form
water, you're going to see,
since we added this ref attribute, and set
it equal to a ref container, when we're submitting
the current dot value, will hold the value
of our input. So to showcase that, we're going
to go console log here, and then go ref container.
And then dot current show I'm looking for
a current property. And now this, the current
property is now our input show, what I could
do is just grab the value like we did before,
okay. However, in this case, of course, we're
not using EDA target, we're using ref containership,
whatever is the name, the current property,
which initially is no. And then once we submit
the form, it will have the value. So if I'll
type something here, and by the way, I probably
need to save it first. So if I type something
in my input, and once I click, I shouldn't
have some kind of value in the console. But
I don't, the reason why I don't have it is
because this should be submit, my apologies,
it shouldn't be button, it should be Submit.
And once we change this around, Now, of course,
once we type something in input, and once
we click, check it out, now we have the value.
So this is going to be different queries,
where we're not setting up a controlled input.
So notice, in this case, we don't have the
state value that reflects the value that is
going to be in the input. And we don't call
on change each and every time we type something
in the input. Instead, we use this ref, so
use the ref. And then we have this ref attribute.
In the current property, we're going to have
a value. Now of course, you can add this earth
to any HTML element, you're not limited to
just the input. And in order to access it,
you have to go with rough container on the
ground. For example, if right next to the
form, I pass in a div with a Hello, world,
e4, set up ref, I'll create a new container.
So let's call this div container, copy and
paste. I'll call this div container. I'll
still set it equal to null. By default, if
I go here with dev container now, once we
console log, when we're submitting, we should
see that there have container current should
point to that def. Sounds tried to submit
on top something murders. Now notice the dev
container current is pointing to my Dev. So
if you would want to do something specific
with this particular DOM node, you can use
the use ref book. Again, the general idea,
it preserves the value between the renders,
but it doesn't trigger a rerender. And then
it's mostly used to target DOM nodes. Now
One really cool thing that we can do, once
we have the general understanding of use ref
hook is to focus our input. The moment our
app renders, sure, the moment we see the form
will right away, place a input. Now since
use ref doesn't trigger a rerender, I can
simply call user fact I can pass in my callback
function, and I don't need to worry about
setting up this dependency array. I don't
I can just call it here.
Because it won't trigger the rerender. So
for example, again, I go with console log,
and then I'm going to be looking for ref container,
and then dot current. And we're going to go
with a ref container, van, current. And we're
going to call the focus method on it. So what
you're saying, the moment we render, we're
going to get our input tax, and right away
have the focus. So once we refresh, notice,
the focus is there. And then I can clearly
see that in console log, that the ref container
current is pointing to that input. That's
why I'm able to grab that value when we submit
the form, because again, we just call that
dot value property. But what we're doing each
and every time we render the application will,
we're adding the focus on the current one,
okay, and we simply couldn't do that without
any kind of dependency list. Because the ref,
the use ref hook won't trigger the rerender.
So those are the basics of use erfolg. And
probably the most likely use case we'll be
targeting DOM nodes, or elements. All right,
um, next we have use a reducer.
Now use reducer hook is used whenever we have
a more complicated setup, as far as the state.
So you can definitely use it with simple examples.
But honestly, if you have like a to do list
or something like that, I think using just
regular use state is good enough. However,
as your app gets more complicated, it definitely
is a good practice to use a juicer, because
essentially, it will add more structure to
your state. So you won't be able to add just
willy nilly however you want, and change the
state. Here, we'll have to go through certain
steps. And that is very, very useful when
you work in a team. Again, if you have a simple
to do, I don't see a big use case for that.
However, as your app gets complicated, then
of course, I definitely would suggest using
use redress, because it will just add more
structure to the initial setup that you have
in the state. Now, before we go any further,
let me just mention, I purposely picked this
example to be somewhat simple, and tutorial.
And then once you're done with the tutorial,
I would highly highly, highly suggest going
right away to the project and then do the
use reducer project. Because that project
will be a bit more complicated. And of course,
a better use case for a reducer. And before
we start working in our setup, let me just
showcase what we're going to build. So I'd
want you to import from tutorial, version
six, the user juicer, and then the final one.
And notice how we don't need to go for specific
file. And I'll talk about it in a second.
But for now, you'll just looking for that
component that is coming from the final. And
once you render, you'll notice that again,
we have the form, we have some kind of input,
I can go here with item, I can add it, not
only I can add the item, but I also have have
this model. And notice how the application
gets a bit more complex. And that's a good
use case for using users. And if I try to
add the item that doesn't exist, then I just
have please enter value. And we'll start simply
by building this using the traditional setup
where we had two values in a state of mind
we will refactor it to use reducer. Now user
juicer relies heavily on Redux. So if you're
familiar with Redux, awesome, if you're not
then once you understand use reducer, it is
going to be very easy to pick up Redux because
a lot of the lingo, and the functionality
is exactly the same. So first, let's deal
with this specific path where we don't have
any filename. And we're going to do that by
going to a sharp here. And instead of final,
we're looking for a setup. So I'm looking
for to set up of course I'll change my component
name as well. And once I save, I should see
the use reducer when we navigate to the six
we're looking for setup
Notice something interesting where I have
two files in there, I have in luxurious and
the model. So here's what's happening. In
this particular setup, more we can do is use
index j s in the folder. And then once we
import, we don't need to go with specific
file anymore, because index j s in every folder,
unless you change the setup manually, will
be the main entry. Meaning if I, for example,
go with import from the folder, and if I have
their index j s, it will right away import
that index js. And you'll see that in a lot
of people's setup, where we have a bunch of
folders, and then each and every folder has
this index. And that index is that main entry
in that folder thrown here, I can do whatever
I want inside of that folder, but index JS
will be that main entry point. So everything
at the end of the day will be either imported
here, or the logic will be sitting there.
So I can have as many components as I would
want in the same folder, but all of them in
some way, or shape or form will meet in that
index js. And like I said, we'll just start
with a very basic setup, where we'll still
have the form, we will still have the simple
state value, and all that. Also, we'll have
a simple toggle as far as the model. And then
slowly, but surely, we will refactor it to
use reducer. Now, let me close some of the
folders over here.
Notice we have the modal component monitors
the component that's sitting right next to
our index j. s. Great, beautiful index js,
I would also want to import data, import data.
And that is of course, the name the imports
we go from. And then again, we go few levels
up, we're looking for the data because first
we'll just try to do that, using the regular
setup. As far as the state values are concerned,
I'll close the sidebar, we're going to go
here with comms on people. I'm not upset people
that is equal to our your state. And then
we pass in our data. Okay, awesome. And also,
I want to toggle that model. Now if you check
out the model, there's nothing there, there's
just a div, that I am model, but eventually,
it is going to be there. And as far as my
state value, I think I'll say show, model,
and then set show model show model. By default,
I'll say that I'll hide the model. So it will
be hidden by default. And now of course, I
would want to come up with my return. So let's
go again with our fragment here. And as far
as the return, we'll start by just checking
the model. What is the show model scenario.
So if it is true, then I would want to showcase
we already know how we can do that, of course,
we have our model component correct. So I
go to model, and I go here with a modal component.
So if the show model will be true, or some
If not, then we're going to hide that. Now
we're going to go with form. We'll go with
form. And I think I'm going to go with on
submit, on Submit. And as you can see, I'm
kind of keeping up the pace here because we
have already covered this before. We'll have
a handle on met. And then of course, we need
to have a dev and an input. It's going to
be a text. Now as far as the value,
well, we'll have to come up with a new State
Route. Correct. So let's just go with text,
I guess I can call it that way. I think it
is going to be good enough or not. Let's just
go with name. So name, and then set name is
equal to reuse state. A manager is going to
be an empty value for now. Variable Type name
here, and then on change over will invoke
again our inline function. And then once we
invoke it, we would want to go with set name,
short name, and then we pass in whatever we're
getting back from our input. So event, target
and event dot value, not the moment it completes.
Well, we have no access to event, because
he is not defined. There is now here is the
fun, and also the handle summit. So let's
just go with const and then handle.
Sir met, that is my function. Now I would
want to prevent a default, of course. So I'm
going to go here with E and then rent, default,
let's invoke it, let's save. Yep, we shared
something there, then let's add a little bit
of styling as well. So let's say here, there's
going to be a class name, form, once Also,
our button. So right next to Dev, we're going
to go with button type is going to be met.
And let's just right here, add person or add
or whatever you want. And there it is. Now,
of course we have our form. If I would want
to add that item to the people, well, I would
need to do that when I'm submitting the form.
Correct. So first, we prevent the default.
And then now we want to check if the name
is more than just a empty string. If it is
a empty string, then of course, I would want
to display the more now how I can display
the model. Well, I can go here with else.
And I can say show model. And I'll set it
equal to true. Correct, because now our one
of the split, also, you know, the value is
empty. Now I'm not going to pass in any kind
of values, we'll deal with that once we set
up use reducer. So for now, we'll just display
that show model. Now, if the name is of course,
there, if we have typed something, then we
can say show modal. And again, we'll set it
equal to true. So that is also going to be
use case where we show the model. And then
I would want to add that item to my list to
more people. So let's write here.
We go with certain people, than all passing
that new era where we spread out the old values
first. And then we pass in what we pass in
the new person, now new person is going to
be an object. So let's say here ID property.
We'll go with new date, again, a little bit
of cheating, get time involved. And lastly
to string invoke. And now let's set up a name.
Let's say that the name will be equal to our
state value. And of course, we show the model
we added to the people. And then lastly, let's
use set, set name is equal to an empty string.
And now of course, let's iterate over here
we show the list show right after the form.
We're going to go we people, people van map.
And then of course, I'm looking for each and
every person, like show.
Once I access it on one return, the diff
needs to have a ID of course. So he and then
person have that ID,
we're going to go with heading for
let's just display person, dot name. Now eventually
we'll add the button, but not right now. So
let's type some gibberish. And once we add,
of course, show modal is not a function, because
well, it's not a show model. It is set show
model, set show model, as well as here, set
show model. Again, straight out some gibberish,
I can see the item over here. And I also can
see the model. And once I refresh, it will
also happen if I tried to submit the empty
realm. So that would be a scenario if we use
these state values. And like I said, if you
have a small application, there's nothing
wrong with that. But as your app gets bigger,
bigger, bigger, bigger, you'd want to have
some kind of structure, because notice here
how we have no problems, changing state values
how we would like. But that's not usually
a best use case. If you have a bigger app.
And if you work as a team, you'd want to have
some kind of guardrails, where you're only
updating the state in a certain way. So that
way everyone is on the same page. This is
exactly what we're going to do. Starting from
the next video. Our basic setup worked somewhat.
Okay. Now let's refactor this sucker to use
array juicer
All start by removing this people show now.
So we won't need these guys, because we'll
set up a new one. And we're going to go here
again with our array destructuring. And we'll
set up a state, again, versus just a name.
Or you can call this burrito if you want,
but I'm gonna go with state. And then we have
a second thing, a function, a specific function
by the name of dispatch. Again, you can call
this whatever you'd want. But a common practice
is using this dispatch. Why? Well, because
when we invoke use reducer, again, we're getting
two things back, we're getting the state value.
And then we're getting the dispatch function.
So similarly, how we have with us state. Now
the difference right now is that in the use
reducer, the first thing we pass in is the
reducer function. And the difference between
the US state and use reducer that each and
every time, you want to do something with
that whole state, you always, always, always
mass use this punch. And it's going to go
through their juicer. And you can think of
reducer function as something that takes the
old state and takes in something called the
action, which we're going to cover a little
bit later, and then spits back that new state.
So you always need to have that reducer function.
And the kicker here is that eventually we'll
move this into a separate file, just so we
have less code in our main component. So reducer
function, it is just a simple function. So
we set up a reducer. And eventually it's going
to look for two things. So state, that is
going to be the state right before the update,
and then the action. And you can think of
actions of what are we trying to do. Now for
now, we'll just leave it blank, we'll get
there in no time. So user juicer is looking
forward, you sir. So the function of that
will manipulate the state, it will happen
once we call dispatch or once we dispatch
the action, I guess that is more proper way
of saying that. And then the second one is
that initial state, now we can serve this
up as for the separate variable you want,
or you can type it directly in here, I think
I'm going to go here, I'm going to say const,
and then default state, and that is going
to be my object. Now, any object what I would
want, well, we had a people, correct. So that
was my people array, and for time being is
just going to be blank array, then we had
show model, right? So as you're on, you're
going to go is model open, let's maybe try
it out that way, is modal, open, and by default
is going to be false. So it's not going to
be open. And then last one is going to be
modal content, whatever text we would want
to place on here, so have a modal content.
And on here, I'll just start with hello world,
eventually, of course, it is going to be an
empty string. And now where we have this use
reducer, we pass it that default state again,
you could have easily set this up as an object
right here as well. Now, once we have that,
of course, our app will break for multiple
reasons. For example, there is no show model
anymore. So first, what I would want you to
do is just save, and then slowly, but surely,
we'll start dealing with these errors. And
first, I want to remove all these three functions,
if name is there, as well as this one, because
we won't need them anymore. And where we have
show model, well, now we have a state. Correct
that is the object. So now what I would want
to do,
of course, is change it around and say state
and then years model open, because that is
the property that is responsible for showing
the model. And then where we have the people
again, we need to go state and run people
now of course, it is going to be an empty
array. So don't be upset if there's nothing
on the screen. And of course, there's nothing
there show we are in good shape. And before
we go any further, let me just pass in two
things into the model or not. Let's start
with one and then eventually there's going
to be another one once we set up the function.
So we're gonna model out want to set up a
modal content, and I'll pass in state and
then model content again, property that is
coming from my state value. And then before
we go any further I also want to show the
model
Meaning I would want to add some changes to
the model, where it's going to be destructuring,
two things, model content and eventually close
model function, which we don't have at the
moment. And as far as the return, let's add
a class name and add model. And inside this
paragraph, let's just go with a modal content,
show modal, modal content, not save. And now,
of course, if you want to test out this manually,
the only thing you need to do is just change
these values. So we have the data. Right?
Now, I'm not going to set up adding data.
Because what I want, we will do through the
reducer properly, how if you want to see whether
you can access these routers in a state, simply
set people equal to the data. Now, of course,
you have the data, okay, just to showcase
that it is still just an object, we're still
accessing that in a state that has an object
and it has properties. So if I want to show
the model, and of course, I'll say that it
is true, because I have stayed model is open.
So if it is true than showing the model and
model continent will be hello world, America
is now of course, I have the HelloWorld Yes,
of course, we will do this dynamically starting
from next video. But for now just understand
that we have a state, which is an object in
the object, we have these multiple properties.
And the whole idea is why we're using that
user juicer, because I only want to update
these things. Once I call dispatch. And once
I pass in proper action, I'll handle all of
them in one place, it's only going to happen
in one place in that reducer, and essentially
will just be affecting this state. So now
let me go back to property for values, where
we have empty string, where it is hidden by
default, and the people will be an empty array
resave it. And now we can start dealing with
our reducer. Alright, and once we have refactor
to basic use reducer setup. Now let's see
how the dispatch works. How the reducer works,
what is a action, in order to affect anything
in our state, we would need to dispatch and
I'm going to do that if the name is there,
meaning if it is true, if it's not an empty
string, so I'm going to show you I'll have
to add at least one letter, and then I'll
click on Add. And in here, we'll call dispatch.
So that is our function. And we always, always
need to pass in the object with a property
by the name of type. So that is going to be
our action. So action is going to be our object.
And in an object, you must have the property
by the name of type. And when you need to
set it equal to something, a common practice
is using uppercase, but you don't have to.
So in my case, I'll just call this testing.
And then once you dispatch, once you dispatch
your action, that's what it's called, then
in reducer, you need to handle it. And like
I said, reducer is taking as parameter two
things state right before that update. And
then what action you will want to do for now
case, that is, of course testing. Now, one
thing you need to keep in mind that producer,
you always always, always want to return some
kind of state, because again, this is going
to be that use case, where if you don't return,
well, none of the functionality that you have
later is going to make sense. So let me just
simply start by console log, and you'll see
how there's going to be a big fat error if
we don't return the state. So we get the state
right before the update. And then I also want
to console log the action. But if I don't
return the state from this function, then
this functionality won't make sense. Because
now of course it is going to be on the phone.
So once I save and once I had the letter over
here, check it out. Now I have cannot read
properly his model open of undefined. Why?
Well, because I had the initial state, the
default one that is right here. But since
I dispatch the action, than the action went
to reducer, in reducer, I did not return a
new state. My whole functionality went bananas.
Because there's no more is more open. That's
why you always always need to return some
Kind of state, if you want your functionality
to work. So once I say run, once we have,
for example, letter F, once we click Check
it out, what do we see in the console. So
now, of course, I see my old state, correct.
And I also see this object with a type of
person. So that is the state right before
the update, where we have people array, and
then his model open, and then model content.
So now let's see how we can work with these
values. So we have the state, and we also
have the action. So why don't we go with if
statement, the condition and check whether
we are dispatching the action with a type
of testing? Let's do it, let's say if
we go with action, then that type, remember,
that was the property name. And if that is
equal to a testing, then we would want to
do something. So essentially, what you do,
you set up your dispatch functions with your
action object where you set up type property
with a value. And then in reducer, you catch
them, you say, all right, if I dispatch testing,
this is what I would want to do. So notice
how we are not directly affecting state. It's
not like we call set name, or set people or
set model, we're not doing that. We only control
the state when we dispatch the action. And
then in reducer, this is where we deal with
our state. And essentially, it is more structured.
So even though it's a little bit more boilerplate,
it is less prone to errors, or some kind of
silly bugs. So let's deal with RF. So if the
action type is testing, well, what I would
want to do, well, I would want to return correct,
I always need to return a state. So in this
case, this is default one now. But now, if
the type is correct, if it is testing, then
I would want to return that new state. And
since it is an object, again, we need to keep
in mind that if I just add some kind of property
here, then still my functionality will go
bananas. Why? Well, because I need to have
people, I need to have his model. And I also
need to have moral content was the way of
getting all those values, well, we are returning
the object correct. And then we go with dot
dot dot. And then I would want to copy all
the values from the state right before the
update. Correct. And now we add a comma. And
then we just decide what vouchers you would
want to change. And for now, we'll just do
it manually, where I'll say, you know what,
people will be equal to my data, right?
Then his model open is going to be actually
true. So say the model. And also as far as
the model content, model condom, well, we'll
set it equal to item
added work. So let's test it out. Again, this
will only happen when we click on a button.
Correct. So let me add something here. And
there it is. Now I have my list, john, Peter,
Susan Anna, and also have item added. So the
next time I will do something as far as dispatch,
I will already have this particular state
value. And you can clearly see that if your
console log. So if we go here with a state,
the first time we'll click, notice, eight
is going to be empty. But then if we just
click one more time, then of course, we already
have the last state value. That's why it's
so important to always return state. Now,
as far as this default, one, you can return
a state if you want. But another way, how
we can do that is throw the error, if the
action that you passed in, does not match
any of the types that you're checking for.
For example, here, I could go with throw
new
and also no matching action type sure where
I would use that, for example, if I have here
the house, and then I dispatch. And I don't
know by mistake, I'm going to go type and
random around them. So once I save once I
click on the button, if my value is not there,
if it is empty, of course, I'm going to have
a big fat error. We're just gonna say no matching
error type. So what is happening here? I could
technically return a state. Yeah, that is
an option. But this just gives me a clue that
I'm
dispatching something that I'm not catching
in reducer, because in the reducer at the
moment, notice, I have my Action. Action,
of course, has the type. And I'm just checking
for testing. Now, if I would be checking for
a random one that I pass, then, of course,
there is a different scenario, then everything
would work fine. But this is a good default
scenario where I have bunch of these ifs for
all the action types that we're about to set
up. And then if none of them match, then we
throw the error. Again, the alternative would
be just returning a state. And then if we
return to state, you'll notice that nothing
will happen, because of course, we're not
checking for that random. But also, the problem
might be that you won't notice that, hey,
there's something wrong, I'm not checking
for this action. That's why the alternative
would be throwing the show with me delete
it. And now let's set up to something useful.
Now, what is that useful? Well, instead of
testing, I would want to say Add Item, because
essentially, this is exactly what I would
want to do. So I'll say dispatch, and then
type. And now I'm going to go with add on
underscore item. Again, this is just a naming
convention, where everything is uppercase.
And then in between the words, we just use
the underscore, that is not a role. And of
course, in the reducer, I would also want
to check that. So I'm going to go back to
add, and then underscore item. Now, everything
is awesome. But of course, we understand that
we won't return just a data. So this is where
I would want to get that value that is coming
from the input, and then add to my empty array.
The people right, now let's just leave it
blank. But we're heaters.
And we need to decide what how we can pass
that data. And the way we pass that data is
by adding more properties in here in the object.
Now, of course, what would help is if I would
actually create that item once on trying to
submit the form. So let's do it this way,
I'm going to go with const. And then new item
is equal. Again, we need to have that ID.
So I'll come up with that property new date.
And then let's go with get time. And lastly,
we'll set it equal to a string. Now grab that
name for whatever is in my state value. And
now once I dispatch, remember, I just said
we can add more properties. And a common convention
is calling this payload. But again, there's
no rule. And the way you would do that you
would add a comma since it is a new property,
and payload is equal to my new item. Sure.
Now, in the reducer, not only I'm checking
for the type, which of course I'm doing, since
I would want to set up some kind of return.
But I also would want to grab that payload.
So right above my return in the Add Item condition,
odd want to say new items. And that is going
to be equal to data.so. Let's copy all the
values that we have from default state or
the state one before the update, which of
course essentially is going to be empty array.
But as we keep on adding items, there's going
to be more and more items would go with state
items. So whatever array items we have, and
then I would want to add action and payload
to the new items. So now where we have the
people, I'm going to go with new items. Now
of course, I would want to open up the model.
So I will leave his model true. And of course,
I'll also leave item added. So once we save
we have a big fat error because I did not
add space in between New. And so now let's
try it out our goal with random man, once
I click on Add, then I have another issue
set items is not iterable. And of course the
reason for that is because it is not items.
Sorry, it is people, my apologies. So now
everything should work. And you know, while
we're still on the subject, well just call
this new people. The reason for that because
in my original setup, I went with items. And
now as I'm recording, I just changed my mind.
That's why we got this bug. Let's just say
random, odd, and there is now we have item
added, shall we display our model. Beautiful.
Also, we showcase that here in our list. Now
what else we would want to do
I guess I would want to clean out my values.
Once I submit, correct, that only makes sense.
So let's do it this way, where we have the
name, right after that, I'm going to go with
set name, and we'll set it back to an empty
string. And knowledge dispatch another action,
or this one will be no value action. So if
I tried to submit an item without any values,
then of course, I would want to showcase that
in my model, we'll just change the action
around where it's not going to be five random,
will say no, on the score, and then value.
Now when it comes to our no value action,
but we'll just go with action type is equal
to now underscore value. So if that is the
case, what I would want to do, I simply want
to return different modal content, correct.
And I also would want to showcase the model.
But remember, I still want to return my people
are still want to show my items correct. So
that's why again, we go with return data dot
state. So we copy everything coming from the
previous state state before the update. And
then we say show model is true. And also,
of course, I want to add different model content.
So say model content, and that will be equal
to a place and their value. Let's save it.
And the problem here is that course smart
enough, I added in my previous condition,
and you know what, also the name is a little
bit different. It is is modal, open, like
show analysis route, we're out tried to submit
and devalue. And now of course, we dispatch
the null value. And then in action, we just
check, again, the whole point where we copy
this virus, because essentially, we just want
to change two properties on that state is
more open and more complex. And I want to
leave the people, the list of people. In fact,
maybe there's going to be cases, for example,
with a closing model, that will only affect
one property. That's why it is very important,
once we return state, always to copy the values
the previous values from the state, and then
just decide which property value we would
want to change. And in our previous example,
of course, we changed all three of them. If
you want to dispatch a action, and then change
only one thing, just make sure that you copy
all the hours. If you would want to burn through
things, again, the same thing, make sure that
you complete the hours. If you want to change
all of them. Again, it is a good practice
to always make sure that you're keeping track
of your old state priors. And I think we're
in good shape. So now we can add more actions
to our arsenal. Nice work. And let's add two
more actions, one for removing the item. And
then also the clothes model one. So I removed
that console log, I don't think we need it
anymore. I mean, just keep on scrolling. So
we add one for no value. And I guess let's
start by passing in the closure modal function.
And the way we'll set this up, notice we have
handle submit,
let's also create a function that will be
responsible for closing the model. So const,
close modal, not going to look for any arguments.
However, within the function body, we will
dispatch an action that we haven't set up
in our juicer yet. And the type will be close
underscore, mortal. And the only thing that
I would want to do as far as this functionality
is again to return all the state values, and
then change his model to false. We're gonna
go if action and non type is equal to close,
none underscore Morrow, then return again,
copy all the previous state values state.
And let's go with his model open. And let's
set it equal to a false. Now the gotcha here
is that I would want to call it in model on
our we want to call it after three seconds.
So what I would want is to pass this close
model as a prop down to a model. So let's
go with closed model. is equal to a close
model work show. And then once we do that
in the model, of course, we can access it.
So I'm gonna say here, close, close model.
And in the model out want to set up a user,
where like I just said, I would want to close
it after three seconds. So let's go here with
use effect. And in our callback function,
we'll just set up a timeout. And let's say
we have a callback function. And I would want
to go with close modal here. And I would want
to call it after three seconds. And that,
of course, is 3000 milliseconds. So once we
type something, first of all, that item should
be added, we added the item. But then after
three seconds, notice how we dispatch with
dispatch this actual close model, I'm not
of course model is. And similarly, we could
add here a button to our items, and then remove
that item, if we click on that button. And
for that, of course, again, we'll have to
dispatch an action. And of course, we will
have to handle that action in the reducer.
Right below the heading for let's go with
button. I'll set up on click right away. And
here, let's pass in our callback function.
And our want to dispatch an action. Now type
will be remove item. So type, and then we
go with remove underscore item. And then I
would want to be payload again. Why? Well,
because I need to be specific, which item
I would want to remove on orders. In this
case, we're not passing that ID. Otherwise,
how do I know which item I would need to remove.
So we're gonna go with payload payload in
this case, is going to be equal to that person,
and then.id. So once we save, of course, we
should be able to see. And there it is. And
by the way, I should have added the item class,
first of all, is going to look a little bit
better. And also, I would want to add some
kind of text here. So let's say of course,
let me try, I'm saying item. And then once
we have various, our item. Now that is our
model, okay, Ireson after three seconds. And
now we want to handle that remove item. So
if I'll click right now, what do you think
is gonna happen? Well, we're not handling
that, right. So we should have this error.
And this is awesome. Because at least tells
us Hey, listen, you are dispatching an action
that you're not handling in the reducer. So
I go with if action men that type is equal
to or more item, or more, move around. So
within my condition, I'm going to come up
with new variable, new people, that is equal
to state people
out want to use filter, I'm going to access
each and every item as far as the parameter
of person. And then I'll say person ID, there's
not much to a action, and then pay well. So
that is the case, then I wouldn't want to
return this particular item. And now of course,
I just need to return the state. So I'll say
here return a new object. So we'll go with
dot, dot, and then state where we have the
people that is going to be equal to a new
people. All right, we save it. And what should
happen once we click the button, the model
shows up for three seconds, and it says, Hey,
please enter the value. Now, if we successfully
add that item, example will say a random item.
And once we added it displays random item,
and of course, we can remove it as well. So
that's how we can set up our state using user
juicer where notice how it adds way more structure.
And last thing that I would want to showcase
is that normally, since reducers, are going
to have a lot of functionality, you do move
them to a separate file. So in a setup, I
want you to create a reducer j s, then take
everything as far as the function reducer,
cut it out or show and in the reducer, copy
and paste. Now of course we would want to
export now if you want to export this as default,
you can definitely do markers I will export
this as a named export. And here we go with
import, Van reduce. And then of course we
are importing this from the reducer Now our
functionality should still work. But I just
need to make sure it is reducer. And now,
of course, I can keep on working with my form,
and everything will work. And now notice how
much cleaner, more structured is our application,
where we have the reducer, that just deals
with our data. And each and every time we
want to do something, we just dispatch this
action. Again, like I've said this before,
of course, it has way bigger use case, as
your application gets bigger, or you get more
people on a team. And if you'll go right now
to the project and start working on the use
reducer project, you'll see use reducer in
a more complex setup. And of course, like
I keep on saying, it is going to be a better
use case for use reducer hook. amazing job.
And once we have covered use reducer, and
hopefully worked on practice project as well.
Now I want to talk about the prop drilling.
Now, let me just emphasize something right
away, where prop drilling is not an official
term. However, it is somewhat of the side
effect. When you have multiple components
on line, you're out the big component tree.
And then you need to start passing some state
from the top component all the way to the
bottom of your component tree. And the reason
why we will cover prop drilling first is because
in a next tutorial chapter in the use context,
we'll see how use context fixes that. And
more specifically, we'll take a look at the
context API that is designed for the use context
hook is the new way how we can access that
context. So this is going to be somewhat of
a repetition, where we will share up a component
where basically we have less than than each
and every item in the list has a button, and
we would just want to remove that item. So
a little bit of repetition, just to see what
is prop drilling, and how it looks like. And
then in the next chapter, we'll see how we
can fix that using the context API, as well
as use context.
Alright, now, we're going to navigate to our
prop drilling folder, we have prop drilling
dress, and of course, it is being the folder
number seven, and then the setup file. In
the app, only one input I guess I want to
start with that, where I'm going to go with
import. I'm looking for setup. And it is coming
from the tutorial, Van prop drilling, of course,
and then the setup. Now we would want to render
sure we're going to go here or hit a sharp
and there. Now of course, it complains that
there is some type of issue. So let's navigate
there, we have the prop drill, and everything
should work. And of course, the reason why
it doesn't work, because I successfully messed
it up by not pointing to a specific file.
And now of course, we have the prop drilling.
Now, once we're here, like I said, a little
bit of repetition, where essentially we'll
create a list. And we will have the items
in the list. Of course, each and every item
will have that option of removing itself from
doors. Now we do need to have a data here.
So let's go with the import and data that
is coming from. And of course we need to go
multiple levels up. So I believe three, there
is our data. So once we have the data, now
I would want to set up a my main component
where I have the const I'll have a list value
here. So people again, set people set people
amount is equal to a year state. And then
we'll pass in that data, we're sure to have,
again, that basic array that we already covered
before. And now of course, what I would want
is to do some kind of return in my JSX. So
we'll start by returning a section. So let's
go with a section. And let's write heading
three, maybe, let's just say Prop, a drilling.
And also I would want to have a list. So there's
going to be a list component that takes as
a prop, the people. So we're going to look
for people here. And that is going to be equal,
of course, to my people state value. And what's
missing is my list correct? So we'll go with
list now I already know that I'm going to
be looking for People prompt. So that's why
I will destructure it right here without any
hesitation. And as far as the return, I would
want to iterate over that array, because we
already know that it is an array. And then
for each and every item, I want to render
the single person component that I haven't
created yet. So I'll just go with return,
we'll close out our fragment. And like I said,
we'll just go with people array, we'll use
map, each and every item is a person. And
what I would want to return is a single person
component that we're going to create in a
second. So columns, and single person is equal.
And now in a single person, again, I know
that person is an object, there's going to
be multiple properties. If you need to jog
your memory. This is our data. So we have
ID a name. And what I would want in that single
person is to target the ID, and name for now,
eventually, there's going to be more data.
But for now, we'll just Target ID and Name
work show online as far as the return, let's
just return a div with a class of item, class
name. And item here, for the time being largest
right, single item, so heading for one single
item. Now, of course, what I want is where
I'm returning, I'm going to go with single
person, and all right away get my ID, because
remember, we still have the list. So we need
to use the key Prop, we'll just say here,
person, and then.id. So once we save, we should
have four single items on the screen. Now
why do we have world because my array
has four objects. Just so we all are on the
same page, we have our array, we set it equal
to data, that's our initial value, then we
have the first return, where we have a heading
three with prop drilling, and then our list
component that takes a prop. And I named people
and I set it equal to my state value of people.
Then in here, I'm the structure right away,
the people prop out of the props on returning
a people map. So a new array, where I'm iterating
over people. And then for each and every item
in my array, I return a single person component.
Since it is listed, I need to pass in the
key. And then in this component, of course,
I'm accessing the ID mm, which I'm not using
at the moment. And as far as the return, I'm
returning a single item. So that is something
that we have already covered more than few
times when we talk about tutorials, as well
as the project. Now here comes the interesting
part. Well, what if I would want to set up
a function that deletes that one single item
from the list? Okay, let's first set up the
functionality. And then of course, we'll do
with rest on the use case. So we're going
to go with const, I'll call this a remove
person is equal to an ID, because this particular
function will be looking for the ID, then
we need to call set people that again, just
so we can practice a little bit, all call
this in a function. I'll say my current state
value is equal to people. And then let's just
return people filter. And each and every item
will be set up as a person. And I'll say,
if the person ID does not match to whatever
ID I pass, then then of course, I'll return
it. If it does match, then I'll remove it
from the person ID is not equal to an ID work.
So let's save it. And we have the function
beautiful. And now the interesting part starts
where now I need to get this function where?
Well, I need to hear correct. So what are
we doing? first need to pass in the life,
then we'll have to destructure it of course,
then we'll need to pass into a single person.
And then eventually, we'll also have to use
it over here. So the big question is, how
can we get this function all
the way here, and this is that prop drilling
where essentially, we have the component here
and you can make a good argument that this
component last component does not, does not
need that remove person function. But there's
no other way for us to pass it down to a single
person. I mean, I cannot simply say, all right,
remove person, you'll be called here in a
single person, a single person needs to somehow
have access to that remote person. And this
is what the prop drilling is where the list
component will have to take the remote person
and pass it down to a single person. So first,
let's start by passing the Remove person as
a prop down. That is something that you need
to keep in mind, where when we talk about
the functions, we also can pass them as props,
we're not limited to just state values. So
in this case, was to go with remove person
is equal to A remove person. So now I'm passing
in my function. Now in the list, like I said,
I would need to destructuring I would need
to say, all right, so get me this remove person
from my props. And now I need to pass it into
a single person. Now, I also need to pass
in this ID and Name. And like already previously
covered, we have multiple ways how we can
do that. But my preference is using this spread
Object Notation, where I just go with curly
braces, and then dot, dot dot, and then whatever
is the name of my primer, meaning list now,
points that item in the list. And I'm just
saying, you know, add all the properties,
meaning in this case, ID and Name on to the
props of the single person. And that's why
right away have access to the RDMA. And then
again, we need to pass in that remove person.
So go here with remove person. So now we're
passing it down. And of course, if I'm looking
for ID and Name, I can also look for remove
person Prop, correct, because now we pass
it down. So we say remove person. And now
it's finally set up our logic, we're not going
to say heading, forcing the item, nurse a
name here. So I'm going to be looking for
my name prop. And also, we want to set up
a button where I could set up a on clerk that
will trigger that remote person. So button
on click is equal to A in one function here.
And we'll say remove person, I also want to
grab that ID, each and every item, single
person item will have that unique ID correct.
And now of course, I would want to invoke
my remove person, once I click on a button
with that specific ID. And then as far as
the value again, we are right. And again,
idea of Prop drilling is following where list
component technically does not, does not need
to have access to the Remove person. But we
have no other way to pass down our function
into the single person, unless we actually
pass it through the list. That is something
called prop drilling, because we need to understand
that there's definitely could be more components.
So if we, for example, set up this function
all the way up in the prop drilling, what
if I'm gonna have, I don't know, two, three
components down the component tree. So from
the single person, I would need to keep on
passing and passing and passing and passing
all the way down to that one specific component
that is looking for a remove person. route
is something that the context API, as well
as Redux. But Redux is definitely for more
complex cases. I wouldn't suggest setting
up Redux for this particular scenario. But
context API is beautiful for this type of
scenario, where essentially, we can avoid
this prop drilling.
Okay, hopefully that is clear, understanding
waters prop drilling. And then in the next
chapter, we will take a look at how context
API helps us to fix it, where we won't have
to pass in return through the list or any
other components we would have into that one
specific component that is looking for the
function that is all the way up in the component
tree. And once we have looked at prop drilling,
once see how context API as well as use context
hook will help us to resolve that issue. On
first I would want start by pointing to a
different folder on the file. Can we're looking
for tutorial then I'm looking for use context
As well as the setup and context A p II, once
we render, we should see the prop drilling,
and especially everything that we worked on
in a previous video. And that is by design,
because this is going to be the use case where
we'll have to add a little bit of code, as
well as refactor or old one, in order to see
how context API as well as use context works.
Now, what you'll notice here is the same exact
file. And I would want to start by adding
a few things, I'll say, use context. So that
is the hook that we'll use eventually. And
also, you know, I don't want the same name.
So I will remove it. And I'll say, context
API. It's not a big deal. But just makes a
little bit of sense if we do that. And once
we have the setup, ran, let's see. So we have
this remote person. And again, the whole deal
was that we were passing this remote person
through the list through many other components.
Of course, if we would have more components,
down to that one component that is looking
for that particular function. So how we can
fix it? Well, first, we need to create the
context. So I'm going to go above the context
API. And I need to come up with a name. In
this case, I'll say person on non-complex.
Now that is equal to A react, and then we
say dot, and now we're looking for the function
of create contacts. Now we can pass in some
default one, but in my case, I won't do it.
Now, the moment we do that, now we have access
to two components, the provider and the consumer.
So let's say here, two components. One is
going to be a provider. And then the second
one is the consumer. So with the arrival of
us context, we want to use the consumer previously,
before the hook was introduced, we were using
the consumer. However, now we don't have to,
I'm just telling you that you will get essentially,
two components back, once you set up that
create context. And the way you access those
components, you are going to go with person
context, and then dot and then provider, or
the consumer. So the thing is, provider works
as a distributor. So what you would want to
do is, for example, this is your root component,
correct. This is where the rest of the components
are rendered. Because you're less than nine
within less you have a single person. So you'd
need to find out a root component, and then
return of that root component you would want
to wrap in person context. And then the provider.
Let me show you why is that important? So
instead of section, I'm going to go here,
we a person context. And then like I said,
I'm looking for that provider. Now, why is
that important? Because for the provider,
we have the value prop. And what's really
cool is that we can pass whatever would want.
So we'll start very simply by passing in the
Hello. And what's even more cool. I can also
use use context to access this value, whatever
it is. And to showcase that. If I go to single
person, I can simply say coms. And I know
that there's going to be some kind of value.
So I'll call this data. Right now. We'll refactor
it a little bit later. But for now, let's
just say that it is data. And now let's use
our use context hook. And inside the use context
hook, we need to pass this context that we
created. So please don't mix the two, we have
person context provider that needs to wrap
your whole component tree, or later, in different
projects, it will wrap our whole application.
Okay, that is important. Please keep that
in mind. But when we talk about person context,
we need to pass in that context into the use
context. So don't mix and match don't say
personal context, that provider here. Now,
here, we're looking for the person context,
but we would want to wrap our component tree
or our whole application in the person context
dot provider. Now of course, I keep on all
the dimensional person context, whatever name
you have, or here for the context, okay, in
my case, that his person context if you would
have bananas context, then you would go bananas
context, dot provider. And what's really cool
that if you log data You'll notice something
really, really interesting. Check it out in
the console. I have Hello, hello, hello. And
isn't that awesome? Because what that means
is that I have here, person, context provider,
all the way down in my component tree. And
I can pass whatever values, regardless of
how many levels deep. And I'll have access
without this prop drilling. So without passing
it through the list. Now, you're probably
saying, okay, you just pass in a simple Hello.
I mean, it's not a big deal. Yeah, but remember,
we are using JSX. Correct. So why don't we
pass in the object? Again, we have first curly
braces, which just means that we're going
back to JavaScript plan. And here I'm just
saying object. Again, this is not some secret
JS x syntax, where we have double curlies
and just simply means, yeah, I'm going back
to JavaScript. And in here, I would want to
have an object. Now what do I really want
in that object? Well, I would want remove
person, correct. Here's what I can do, and
say remove person. And now, of course, I need
to scroll down, I know that this is going
to be an object so I can right away destructure
it. And I can say, remove person. And now
you'll notice that our functionality still
works. Now, of course, is going to be a big,
fat, massive complain, because the name is
exactly the same. So now what I would want
is to return or to remove all these instances,
I don't need it over here. And I also don't
need it over here. Correct.
Lastly, I don't need it, where I'm setting
up my list, so I can remove all of them. Now,
of course, data is the same name, like I have,
as far as the import. So now let me remove
it amorous now, my functionality still works.
But I was able to go around that list. So
if I would have, I don't know, two, three
more components that are inside the single
person, I would be still able to do it. So
we set this up in a room, and then whatever
is set up inside here, all those components
will have access to whatever we pass it down
into the value list, because of course it
was just from person. But keep in mind that
since you're setting up the object, you can
do pretty much anything. And similarly, you
can argue well, we can also maybe omit the
people. And you're right, because I can pass
here, the value of people. So the state value,
and then I can access it where well in my
list, right. So now I don't need to pass it
through the component as a prop, I can simply
say that I want to access it using the use
context. Now in order to speed this up, I'm
just gonna copy and paste. And then notice
we have the remote person. Now in this case,
I will showcase that it is an object. So let
me call this main data, something like that.
And if you'll console log, you'll see that,
of course, main data will be my object. Now
it's gonna complain to people is not defined.
Because of course, now you need to access
that main data, and then dot people. Now,
of course, everything works. Now the reason
why I set up a separate variable, because
I want you to understand that in this case,
we right away destructured, the Remove person
from the object that we're getting back. In
this case, I'm just showcasing that, of course,
we're accessing the object and you don't have
to destructure you want to do it this way,
you can do it this way. Whatever is the name
of the object, whatever you're getting back,
and then whichever property or method you
will want to choose. So in my case, since
I'm looking forward to people array that I
just passed them. That's why I go with main
data, and then dot people. And then I'm iterating
over. Now, few things that I would want to
mention. I personally don't find it that useful.
If I have
only one level, meaning with the list, I see
no problem of passing that people state value
as a prop, where I would introduce the context.
That is definitely if I have to three or whatever
lows the ban definitely mentioned. And also,
a lot of times I stick to setting up it one
time globally. Don't worry, we'll cover that
in the projects where essentially we cover
our whole application in that context provider.
All right, and the way we do that we need
to export this The person context the provider,
as well as the main context, and we will need
to wrap it in the index js. Again, that is
something that we'll take a look at. In the
project, I didn't see the point of jamming
everything here and authorial. But just keep
in mind two things that I have no problem
of passing this one level as a prop. Now,
some people right away introduce the context.
Again, that is their preference. It's just
a lot of times I see students where once they
learn about the context, they say, Well, why
we're still doing the prop drilling. Now,
in my opinion, the prop drilling starts when
we start passing in two or three levels deep.
Essentially, we start passing through the
components that don't need that info. When
we look at the people that we just passed
into the list list was using. Again, I have
no big issue over there. All right. Now, last
thing, I guess, what I would want to do is
just change this title, from say, context
API, and then forward slash use context. So
hopefully, it is clear how we can avoid passing
unnecessary data through the components. And
now we can move on to our next topic. of Next
we have custom hooks. And essentially, custom
hooks allow us to reuse the functionality.
So let me be clear, we're not talking about
reusing HTML elements, we already can do that
with components. We are talking about the
functionality, whether that is fetching data,
saving to local storage, and that sort of
thing. Also, before we begin, let me just
mention that I purposely added only one example
of custom hooks, since you can easily find
other custom hooks examples. So the code community
has created for three years by just typing
custom hooks in your favorite search engine.
The point of this example is to make sure
you understand the purpose and the setup of
the custom hooks. So after that, you can either
create your own custom hooks, or with ease
use someone else's custom hooks in your own
apps. Without Let's start by importing the
module. The module we're looking for is module
number nine, by the name of costs them. Again,
we have final setup folder. And of course,
in the address, we're going to be looking
for the setup folder. So we go here with import
online the setup. We're looking in the tutorial,
online more specifically, folder number nine
custom hooks, of course, the setup. Now in
this case, there is a file name, and we're
looking for fetch an example. So in this case,
I'll remove the heading to learn of course,
I'd want to showcase the setup show once we
load, notice we have loading the doc, and
then we have the data. So what is happening
over here? Well, if we navigate to our file,
the first example, we'll notice that we'll
have somewhat standard setup to fetch data.
So we have used state we have used effect,
we have loading state variable, we have set
loading, of course, by default loading is
true when we have some kind of state variable
that is called product. Initially, it is an
empty array, then we have the function that
fetches something. So in this case, this is
purchasing from my own API. And we use this
in my JavaScript course where we have the
product. Now, if you want, you can of course,
navigate to a bigger screen. And then copy
and paste, it is an array of
products. And don't worry, we'll use it a
little bit later in tutorial. So you'll see
what this is all about. But essentially, it's
just a bunch of product with some price with
some name, and image and all that. So we're
fetching that, I hit the URL course I get
the response, I rhombi. json, and then I set
to state values, my offset product, and then
I have set loading to false. And of course,
I'm running this with my user. And I have
the empty array means that it runs by default,
the moment we run that, and that's it. And
then of course, I'm just console logging the
product. Now the point of this is not to tell
you that there's something wrong with the
setup. The point is to showcase what what
if I would want to reuse this functionality,
because there's no way for me to reuse it.
I mean, I can use this with this. particular
URL. But if I have a different component that
also needs to fetch something, again, I'm
just reinventing the wheel. Now, before we
do anything in our custom Hawk, let me just
showcase that. If your console log, of course,
you'll be able to see the product. Again,
the point is not to setup anything, as far
as the component, we simply have loading.
So we check whether the state value for the
loading is true. If it is, then we showcase
loading dock. And then once we're done with
loading, we just display the data. And what
you should see in a console are these 12 products.
So again, this is not our main concern. If
we have the products, that just means that
our fetch was successful, our point is somehow
to come up with functionality that we can
reuse. So if I have another component, that
also would want to fetch data, I don't need
to duplicate these lines of code. By the way,
in this case, we don't have the error. Keep
in mind, normally, you'd have the error as
well. And of course, once we set up our custom
hook, we can definitely add error, as well.
And I already said that, we will be creating
a new custom hook. Sure, you can probably
already guess that in the second file that
is in the folder called use fetch. This is
exactly what we're going to do. Right navigate
there, I can see that I have react, I have
used state and I have used effect, not don't
honestly, we actually don't need the react,
we can just use use state and use effect.
And then I have this function, I have this
use fetch function. So here's what we could
do. First, I could save it. And then where
we see the fetch example, show our previous
component, I can just cut out the lines starting
with loading all the way to where we have
the use effect. So let's just grab everything.
So starting with line five, all the way to
line 17. And just get it up, and then navigate
to use fetch, and copy and paste. Okay, that's
an awesome start. So we still have our loading
state value, we still have the product. And
of course, we still have the function. Now,
if you want, you can rename this something
more generic, for example, data. But since
we will use them later, so we will use this
customer later. But we'll still be fetching
products, I won't do that. Just keep in mind
that you are not limited to calling this product.
It's state valor. Sure, you can call it whatever
you'd want. So my whole idea is that I would
still want to perform this functionality.
Correct. But I'm not doing this anymore. In
the component show, I have my custom hook.
And of course, in order for this to work,
I would need to return something from this
customer. And what I would want to return
is an object. And then in the object, I'm
going to place my two state vouchers, one
is going to be loading. And then the second
one is going to be product since I also would
want to make this reusable, I will set it
up where I'll pass in the URL into the function.
So I wait when I call this use fridge later,
in different components in different topics,
I can simply pass in the new URL. And I'll
still get back my loading, meaning whether
that is true or false. And also the data that
I'm getting back. So I'm going to say here
that I'll be looking for one argument, the
URL argument. And also, our would want to
call this user for when the URL changes. So
it's going to run one time when essentially
we invoke the function. And also if we change
the argument for the US fridge custom pork,
so I'll save this beautiful. And now of course,
I need to navigate back to fetch example.
And I need to import. And as you can see,
in line number two, this is exactly what we're
doing. So we import the use fetch custom mock.
And of course, it's coming from of the file
the use fetch. By the way, I just noticed
that my naming is somewhat off, should be
used fetch. So of course in your example,
it's already going to have a proper name but
in markers, I would need to change this where
this is used much and also my import should
be used Now once we're done, of course, now
I want to invoke my custom hook. And this
is the case where notice, we're returning
a object over here. So normally when we use
use state, since we're returning an array,
we did a array destruction. So this is going
to be the case where now of course, I would
want to destructure the object, because that
is what I'm getting back from my custom code.
So here, I'm going to say cons, and then loading.
So that is the first thing that I'm looking
for. And the second one is the product. Correct?
Man, I'm going to set this equal to use fresh,
so not use effect not used. But my own custom
hook by the name of us, and lanforge. And
now, of course, I need to pass in that URL.
And, of course, we already have the URL in
the component correct, because we have the
variable by the name of your URL, and not
point back to my own API. And now the cool
thing about you'll notice that once we run,
our functionality didn't break. So now we
can still check the loading animal can still
get the product for navigate there, check
it out. Once I refresh, I definitely can see
that I'm still fetching my products. However,
now my functionality is tucked away in a separate
place. Now my functionality is tucked away
in a custom hook. So if I would want to reuse
it, and which is exactly what we'll do in
the later topics, just so I can emphasize
the point of using the custom hook, every
time I would want to fetch data, instead of
using use state and setting up the loading,
setting up some kind of array, and that type
of thing. I will just call use fetch, pass
the URL from the function, I'll get back to
you things, the loading, as well as the product.
So like I said, if you'd want to introduce
her as well, definitely be my guest. But in
my case, we're just going to stick with loading
and product. Now the one thing that I would
want to mention that since this is a custom
hook, it has to have this huge. So for example,
if you'll just say, fetch, so you're exporting
fetch, you'll see a big fat error, even if
I change the correct import, because we're
not allowed to use hooks inside the regular
function. So either the function needs to
be a component, or it needs to be a customer.
That is something you need to keep in mind.
So that's why we need to make sure that when
we're creating our own custom hooks, we need
to use this huge show. In this case, I call
this use fetch. So now of course, I just need
to make sure that my import is correct. So
I'll say here, use fetch. And of course, everything
is going to work. Nice work. Next, we have
prop types. And effectively prop types allow
us to validate our props, so the props that
we're passing into component.
In order to get up and running with our example,
course, we will need to import from folder
number 10. In this case, again, we're looking
for the setup. And as you can see here, I
have the images, meaning the main entry. So
we just need to look for the folder in the
app js. So we'll go with import and set up
from online tutorial of course, then we're
looking for the folder number 10, the prop
types and then forward slash setup. And we're
good shape. So right after the heading to
or not Miramar with. And we're right here
set up my clothes, my component, I should
see the product, the devs with a single product
backlog. So what's happening over here on
what we're trying to achieve? Well, of course,
we would need to navigate first to the index
js. And what you'll notice is the imports.
So we have import for the product component,
which essentially is where we're going to
do most of our work, then we have our use
fetch custom hook. And if you didn't watch
the last example the last topic, then please
do so. Because I'm not going to go over what
is happening with use fetch with our customers.
So we import from the folder from the final
folder in this case. And then of course I
have the URL which I pass into the use fetch
That's the nice thing about the custom hook.
Because now, every time in a project, when
I want to fetch some later, I can simply use
my use fetch when passing the URL. And I know
that I'll get back to you things, I'll get
back to loading as well as the product. Now,
in my case, notice how I don't need loading.
So I'm not using him. So I'm just getting
the product. Again, this is just to emphasize
the cool thing of custom hooks, were now of
course, I don't need to set up your state,
I don't need to set up use effects. Everything
has already done in the US fridge custom.
Now, with that said, Of course, I'm grabbing
the product out of my return. And then I have
the section with a class name of products
that I'm iterating over those products. And
then for each and every product, I'm returning
a product component. And then of course, we
need to pass in the key prop value is equal
to a product.id. And I'll show you the API
in a second. And then we do the object spread
operator, where I pass in all the properties
from each and every product into the product
component. Beautiful. Now, I guess we'll start
by checking out the API, and essentially are
set up this API myself, just so we can have
the example, of course, which you can do is
again, navigate to a browser, and then just
copy and paste URL. And you'll see that again,
we have some kind of array. And then each
and every item in the array is an object,
which represents product. And there we have
the ID property, we have the name, we have
some kind of image. Of course, if you want,
you can open this up. And then we also have
the price. So far, so good. Everything that
we have covered already before. And we can
probably already imagine that in that product
component. Well, we'll have to access those
properties one by one correct. Only to have
the name, we'll need to have an image with
the URL more specifically, as well as the
price. So let's try it out. And let's see
where prop types come in handy. So I'll open
up the sidebar, and I'll check my product.
Like I said, the moment the single thing that
I'm returning is just single product text.
But of course, I would want to change that
around access those properties, because I
know that I'm passing the amendment correct.
In the next jarius, we do pass them in. So
it's not like they're missing. But there's
going to be a gotcha. I'll look for my image,
I'll look for my name. And I'll look for my
price. Now, of course, in the return, well
out mana make it a bit more interesting, where
I'm going to return article with a class of
product, that still stays the same. But then
I'm going to look for heading four. And I'm
going to say you know what, show me the name,
get me whatever is the name of the product.
And so far, so good. We have utopia so far,
all the way to a surface.
Alright, so that worked. We got our prop by
the name of name. And of course, we can split.
However, what do you think is going to happen
when we try to do the same thing with a price.
So let me access here to price. And what you
will notice that all of them have some kind
of price. But the last one, for some reason,
displays nothing. And that some reason is
simply because in this API, well, all the
objects have those properties, apart from
the last one. And I did this on purpose. Because
if you're ever worked with API's, you know
that you're not always guaranteed some kind
of value. Yeah, for the most part course,
if you have an array of objects, the values
for the properties won't be there. But once
in a while with some images with some prices,
some of the values might be missing. So here
the problem is that I'm relying on the fact
that I will for sure have this price.
But the question is, well, what if all the
data that I'm iterating over that property?
So that value is not there? We're done. Because
Yeah, it's nice to say, Yeah, I would like
to get the price. But if the price is not
there, what are my next steps? And what's
even worse, is because we have the image,
an image purposely, I set it up as an object
in the object. I'm looking for the URL. Now
what do we know about JavaScript? If I'll
try To access the URL property on the image
that is undefined, in my last object, you'll
see that we will get a big factor. So what
I'm trying to show here is that even if 99
out of your 100 items have all the properties,
if one of them is going to be missing, since
you're checking for the property that is in
the object, you'll get a big fat error. And
of course, you'll have to deal with that,
showcase that I'm going to go here with an
image. And what I would like is, of course,
set up my return, then I have my source. And
then remember, we needed to go for image,
and then dot URL. All right. And now of course,
for the alternative will also go with a name.
So once I save, like I said, there's going
to be a big fat or Now why is that error?
Well, it's simply there, because I already
mentioned few times that we are getting the
property values on the object. And even though
for rest of the items, image property is right
there. The last one doesn't have it. Since
I'm checking the property on on defined, course,
reacts, complaining, if you ever see this
kind of setup, first of all, I would suggest
not freaking out. And what I mean by that
a lot of times I see students right away going
for questions saying, Hey, listen, there's
something wrong with my project, because,
well, I cannot access the property, I have
this on the phone. If you ever get this case,
what you simply need to do is just make sure
that you're turning some kind of static value.
And then one by one, you start checking, hey,
listen, what is happening with my prompts.
Now, why do I want to return a static value?
Well, because of course, I don't want to access
them dynamically. Because that will always
throw the error. So always, always, if you
ever run into some kind of issues like that,
I would suggest, in this case, commenting
out and then saying some kind of value, some
ground return, it's going to be heading for
and then again, back to single product. I'll
save it. And of course, I would want to check,
hey, listen, what is happening? Where is my
image? Where's my name? Where is my price.
So once we go back, of course, we're going
to do that in the bigger browser window, and
I can see that something's off. So yeah, for
some of them, I have the values. But then
I see those on the fines. And of course, now
I would want to set up the prop types that
essentially would check that forming. And
the second thing that I would want to do is
set up some kind of default values. So first,
let's start dealing with those prop types.
And what's really cool, as far as the prop
types, we don't need to install, any extra
package is coming right away. By default,
when we set up create react app. And we go
with prop types. And then from and package
is exactly the same, it is called prop types.
So notice how this one is with an application.
And that is done on purpose. Because in order
to set up prop types, we'll have to set up
a prop types property on the component. So
we go with the name of the component, in this
case, it is a product, and then we go with
prop types. So that is the name of the property.
Keep in mind, this is an import from the package.
And then this is the property on the component
that is always going to be there. And then
we just say, Hey, listen, what kind of props
are we getting. So if I have image name and
price, then the same way in this object, I'm
going to say that I'm going to be looking
for image prop. And then I need to run my
import the prop types. And then of course,
we have multiple prop types, whether that
is a string number, object, or whatever justified.
So in my case, I know that image is going
to be what? Well, it's going to be an object
correct. So go with prop types, then I go
with object. And then since I would want prop
types, to yell and scream, if something's
missing, we also add this is required. And
effectively for every prop that you have,
you would want to do the same thing. Now in
my case, I have name and price. So just copy
here. Then since it is a JavaScript object,
I just need to add a comma. Of course, change
the names. So I'll change it to name
and also change it to a price. Now in this
case, of course, I'm not looking for the object.
I'm looking for the string. Like I said, I
can add whatever job value would want. And
here we go with number. Now, since I set them
up as required, which you'll notice in the
console, now we don't need to go and manually
check and say, Hey, listen, is one of them
without the image in price, because I can
clearly see that in my console, where I have
the warning that says failed prop type, prop
image is marked as required, but then the
value is undefined. Now unfortunately, it
doesn't point me back to that specific product.
But at least it tells me Hey, listen, there's
something off, you need to do something because
the props that you're expecting, well, in
one of the items, they are missing. So that's
step number one. Now the next thing that we
can do is start using either the short circuit
operators, or we're going to set up default
props. So first, let me show you how we would
set up a default props. And then from then
we'll take a look at the short circuit operators,
as well. And the way we set up default props,
simply because I don't want those big fat
errors, if the image is missing is like so
where we go with the product. And then the
property name is default props. It's as straightforward
as it gets, where again, I write my prompts.
By the way, here, I need to have a equal sign.
And then of course, what is going to be a
default prop if that prop is missing. So I
go here with default name. If the name is
missing, then I go with the price. Now for
the price, I'm just gonna go with 399, just
in case it is missing. Remember, last one
also have the price missing. And when we have
the image shown here, I'm going to go with
image. But it would help, of course, if I
would show some kind of image. Correct. So
that could be either URL, or, in our case,
if we check out our project, we should see
the assets folder. So right next tutorial,
notice we have the assets folder. And in there,
I have default, hyphen, image. jpg. And this
is going to be the case where I'll also show
you how we can import images into our components
when we work with create react app. So what
we would want to do in that file, in the component
where we want to use, we're going to go import,
then we need to give it some kind of name.
So in my case, I'm going to give it somewhat
explicit name, and somewhat long, I'm going
to go default image. And then we need to navigate
to that folder. So this is going to be three
levels up. Because of course, now we're in
a product. So we need to go first to the prop
types Vantage authorial and not eventually,
we need to be in source. And this is where
we look for assets. So we go dot dot, and
then we leave one folder, then dot next one.
And then finally we arrive at assets. And
then since it is not a JavaScript file, we
need to go with default. And then hyphen,
image and then jpg. So essentially, you need
to have a full path, including the extension.
Okay, hopefully, that is clear. And now of
course, what I could do is just say, default
image. So if the image is missing, then of
course, this is going to be set up as a default
image. Now, what are we doing next? Well,
now are concerned. And of course, I can try
to uncomment. So on comment, and of course,
I can see something beautiful. So that is
not that bad. I can see that I have all these
products. Okay, good, good, good. And by the
way, there's extra single product that I don't
need. And then for all the products that have
those properties, life is great. But then
the one that is missing, remember the last
one, not only the image was missing, but also
the price was missing. Now I can see that
I see that default price. So that's already
a good start. However, there's one more problem
where now of course, this image is an object.
Correct. So even though I set up default value
for the image, when I'm going with image on
that URL, well, I still cannot see the image.
Why? Well, because there is no URL property
on the image that I'm providing. So we'll
also need to take a look at how we can use
short circuit operators in order to fix that.
Now before we go any further don't. I would
just want to showcase that. As far as the
image we can import In any file we would want.
So if we go back to index, if I'll just copy
and paste the path, because of course, it's
going to be exactly the same. And if I want
to place my image, I'm just going to go with
image from source. And then of course, we're
going with default image, just to showcase
that each and every time you'd want to use
it. And by the way, I need to push it above
the URL. That's why it's not working, then
of course, I can use my image. Again, same
setup is going to be for every component.
So you can set up your images. And as far
as the import, you just need to give it some
kind of name. And then of course, the full
path because it is not a JavaScript file.
So that should cover my images. And I'll just
comment them out for your reference. But now
let's finally deal with this product. So I
have the product, I have some problems that
are there, some that are not, technically,
I was able to fix somewhat a lot when I talked
the default props. But there's also another
way how we can set up those default props.
So I'll comment this out for your reference.
And now take a look at another way. Now yes,
there's going to be a big five compliant.
But first, I would want to showcase that we
can use or operator. So if I know that price
might be missing, what I could say is, get
me the price. If the price is not there, then
we use or opere. And then we can add that
default value. So in this case, I can go with
399. Now the problem is going to be that we
will still have this error, because when we
check for this URL property, and the image,
we cannot use this or I can say here, get
me the property on the object. But if the
image is undefined, while this all makes sense.
So even though you might think that I could
just check for default image this way, it's
not going to fix the situation, because JavaScript
still complains about we're trying to access
the property on the on their farm, which of
course is going to be our last project. And
this is where the AND operator comes into
play, where we can set up some kind of variable
markers, that is going to be a URL where I
can say, you know what, if the image is there,
only then get me back the URL. So if the image
is there, then get me URL. If the image is
not there, well, van is just going to be defined.
So that way, what we're doing is we're only
checking for the URL. If the image exists.
If the image doesn't exist, then we're not
even checking it. So the last product, of
course, it doesn't have the image, it is undefined.
So if that is the case, we're not even checking
for that URL. So in our case, you will notice
that I nicely display that default image,
because for all the products, I'm checking
for the image images there, and then I get
back the URL. And then of course, I display
the URL, or here. However, for the last one,
since the image is not there, I'm not checking
for the property that is not an object, so
I don't get the error. And then in here, I
say, Well, you know what,
if this is false, then just display the default
image. And of course, I can do the same thing
here for the name if I would want I could
use my OR operator. So that's how we can use
prop types in react. And before you ask a
question, Well, why we won't use it all throughout
the project as well as remaining of tutorial?
The simple answer is that, well, it is adding
too much code. And in my opinion, it just
gets a little bit messy. So since our goal
is to learn whether or not is building the
project, or working on a specific part of
the tutorial, that's why I will avoid using
a bunch of these prop types because in my
opinion, they just make our files bigger and
harder to read. Now one last thing before
I let you go is the fact that of course, you
can set it up the prop types using the snippets
as well. So I'll just create some testing
file here. First thing js. If you'd want to
add prop types, you just go here with this
B. So you have our A f c and e is going to
start for export. But then if you add this
B you also right away get this prop types.
And then of course, you export the testing
component. And then one more thing if you
want to have a short Got where you're setting
up the prompt. So for example, I could go
with name, prop. And then if you want that
is required, then you go with PT. And then
whether that is an array or string or whatever.
So in my case, I'm going to go with a. And
then if you want required, then you just go
with our under notice you have prop types
array, and then years required. So those are
just the shortcuts that you can use. And those
are use cases for prop types, where they first
allow you to see which props are missing.
And then when you combine them with short
circuit operators, you can just make sure
that if the prop value is not there, you have
some kind of default value. So for all our
examples, we're in the same page. Even though
it works for our tutorial, when it comes to
real apps, it's nice to have multiple pages.
Now when we talk about JavaScript frameworks,
we are not talking about traditional HTML
pages. In that case, we have a new term, a
single page application, which just means
that we have our one page, in this case where
we have a div with an ID of root. And instead
of going back to a server and requesting info
about the pages where the user navigates,
we set up a routing on a client side without
the page refreshes. To give you a visual example,
navigate to App j s. on import. As always,
you can call it whatever you would like my
case, I'm going to go with final Of course,
from we're looking into tutorial, when we're
looking at the folder number 11. And the final
folder, show here where we have the advanced
react. In this case, I'm just going to add
my final component to give you a good understanding
what we're going to create. So notice here,
we have the number. And then we have three
links, and check out the URL bar as well as
the refresh icon. Where notice, as I'm going
from one page to another one, I'm switching
the URL, but we're not doing a full page refresh.
So each and every time we navigate to about
or people, or Hey, we're not going to a server,
and fetching the data and then coming back.
Instead, all this is happening on a client
side. And of course, this is what we're going
to create in the following videos. Now when
it comes to react, it does not have built
in routing, and will need to use an external
package for that. And the most popular routing
library in react land is by far the React
router. But let me be very clear, it's not
part of the official react. Even though it
might seem so because of its popularity, it
is still an external package. If you check
the folder for react router, you will find
a markdown file with more info. Sure, what
I would want right now is to remove our example.
Hopefully you can see what we're going to
create.
Navigate to react router folder, and then
you're looking for react router, info markdown
file. And here, you'll find a link to official
docs, just so you can see where I'm getting
the information from. And also keep in mind
that for your own project, you'll have to
install the React router Dom first. And you
do that by running npm install react router
DOM. Now, of course, I already installed this.
So if you go to package JSON, if you check
out the packages, you'll see that there is
react router DOM, and more specifically, the
version of 5.2. Now just to showcase how we
would install the package, I'll stop the dev
server. And then again, we'll run NPM. And
remember, what was the command, it was npm
install and react, router and then down. So
all what you need to do in your own project,
you would install the dependency and then
it's going to get added to the package JSON.
And then of course, you can start using it
because you'll see that there's going to be
some imports in the upcoming videos. Now let
me start up the server again. So we go and
start. And the last thing that I would want
to mention, as far as the React router general
info is the version number. It is safe to
say that you'll be watching this in a future
just like any other software course. There's
going to be some update. So if you're watching
this, if you install it, and you can see that
the version number is already, for example
six, then of course, you will have to go to
docs and see what are the changes if there
are any, and most likely there will be as
far as the syntax. So the syntax that we're
about to cover is for version five. Keep that
in mind. Once we switch to a different version,
it's a good chance of that also, some syntax
will change as well. Now, you'll still be
able to use a vis index, if you go with this
specific version. But if you want to use a
newer version, if it is available already
at the time, then of course, you have to go
to a doc, and make sure that you follow the
proper syntax that relates to that specific
version. Nice. And once we're done discussing
the general concept of react router, of course,
let's get to work and set it up in our own
application. First, of course, we would need
to navigate to address then we're looking
for folder number 11. And you can probably
already guess, of that, we're going to go
with the setup folder. And you would be correct.
Server navigate to tutorial. And we're looking
for folder number 11. And then we're looking
forward to setup. Again, I have there the
index show the main entry point, so we don't
need to show specific file. And then of course,
instead of there's a random text, the React
router, one, we're going to go with a setup
component. Awesome. Now it's still going to
display the same text, so you're not hallucinating.
But now of course, I would want to navigate
there. And most of the files that you find
in a setup folder are going to be our pages.
Now, Iran is a bit confusing, don't worry,
once we set up the router, you'll see how
it works. But essentially, we have about error,
we have also the home as well navbar people
on person. So everything apart from index,
where we're setting up our react router, and
then the navbar where we display the links,
those are going to be our pages. Hopefully
that is clear. Once we have that out of the
way. Now let's navigate to mixtures. And notice
how I'm importing all the branches. So once
we set up the router, depending on the URL,
we will display that specific component. For
example, there's going to be a home page as
well as a single person page. Now in order
to get up and running with react router, we'll
need to import from the package from the React
router DOM, the browser router, a common practice
is giving it an LS. In this case, we are giving
an alias of router, a route as well as the
switch. So one by one, of course, will cover
what each of them does. In this case, let's
start by setting up our return. And this is
the part where we would want to wrap all our
index return into the router. As a side note.
Normally, when you work with react router,
you'll wrap your whole application. Again,
most cases since we have a separate folder
for each and every example. That's why we're
wrapping the return of images. Just keep in
mind, when we will be working on our project,
we'll go over how we wrap our whole application.
So essentially, the setup is going to be exactly
the same. But the difference is going to be
the router, we'll wrap our objects or the
images doesn't matter, whichever
place you pick, as long as it is a root component,
because that way, of course your whole application
can access the React router and can use it.
In this case, only the setup folder. Of course,
the final one where we have the final code
can use the React router DOM. So with our
router in place, now we need to set up the
routes. Essentially, it just means that in
the URL, when we navigate with our data is
the homepage of bulk. Well, then we display
that specific component. Like I said, these
are just components but I gave it a comment
of pages. So these are just components that
will become our pages. And the way we set
them up as pages. We're going to go here with
a route. Then we have a path prop. And this
is a specific prop. So make sure you name
it exactly the same And then this is where
we showcase what is going to be our URL. And
the first one I want to showcase is the homepage.
Now for the homepage, we just go with forward
slash, that just means the domain. Now in
this case, of course, our domain is localhost
3000. But then normally, you'd have cnn.com,
or, or google.com, or whatever, just think
of the domain, for your application, whatever
is going to be. So that is going to be the
homepage. And then once we have the route
component, inside that route component, this
is where we display whichever component we
would want. So keep in mind, technically,
if you want, you can play whichever component
your heart desires. Because even though this
says that, yeah, it is going to be a home
page, you can easily place here, people components
as well. Keep that in mind. But of course,
in my case, since it is a home page, I also
have a homepage component, meaning the component
by the name of home, and then of course, I'm
displaying it. Now, in order to make it a
bit more interesting. I'm going to copy and
paste One, two. And then of course, I'll add
about as well as people now 40, about what
is going to be my era Well, if the forward
slash is the homepage, let's say that 40 about
page, I'm going to go with forward slash about.
But again, you are in charge, if you want
to write about shake, bag, Lazarus means that
this is going to be the page where you navigate.
Okay, keep that in mind that you are always
in charge. Well, what is going to be your
URL. Now in my case, I'm just going on with
forward slash about. And of course, in order
to showcase my about page, I'm going to say
that once we navigate there, I'm going to
display the about component. And finally,
I'm going to go also with a people. And you
can probably already guess that we're going
to be going to a people page. Now the moment
we refresh notice, now I have the homepage.
Now why do I have it? Well check it out. If
we navigate to a home dress, or home component,
this is what we have. So if I'll go here and
say shake, Berg, improv probably already guess
that will display the paragraph with that
specific text. So hopefully that is clear.
We have on page. And now of course, in the
URL bar, since we haven't set up the nav bar
yet. If we go with forward slash, and then
about, we should. And let me emphasize something
because there's one gotcha, we should see
the about page. And once I press Yeah, I can
see the about page, but there's a tiny issue,
where I can also see the home page. Now let's
try it out with people. So in the URL bar,
go here and say forward slash people. And
let's see what we're gonna get. Again, same
thing, I can see that I have the content from
the people page. And if you want to check
it out, here it is, essentially, I have my
data here, I set up the state variable. And
I'm just iterating over. And don't worry,
it's gonna make sense, once we get to URL
parameters, why we have this specific setup.
Most importantly, what is happening here,
why we have homepage with Shrek and back.
And then the people page, even though technically,
we are in the people page, where you're seeing
what's happening by default, when it comes
to
react router. If the path matches, it's going
to display both components. And as you can
see by the URL, well for the homepage, it
also matches the about correct. And then it
also matches the people. That's why when we
navigate to people to about or whatever page
we will set up, it will also display the home
page because technically, the path matches.
Now in order to fix that, we will need to
add another prop where we say exact. So once
we save, you'll notice that now only the exact
path matches whether that is people or whether
that is about or whatever URL your setup.
And only once I go back to my domain, then
of course I can see the home bridge. Now if
you want you can have this exact path to every
route. pad is totally up to you. But in this
case, since I don't have any nested pages,
so there's not going to be about Ford slash
and something else. I'm just going to avoid
that. Just keep in mind you're not limited
to adding this exact to only the homepage
you can add it To every route, and that way,
only the exact match will be displayed. So
that would be a basic setup for react router,
where we have a router, we wrap our whole
app being in this case, of course, it is just
the index JS in the setup. But normally, you
would wrap the root component. And then you
have routes online for each and every route
that you have, you just set up a component,
whatever you will place in that component
in return is going to be displayed. And then
we need to remember about the path Prop, where
essentially we say, Well, what is going to
be the URL as far as the homepage is just
going to be a forward slash. And then you
can come up with your own components, of course.
And once your display as well as the URL,
just go with forward slash, and then whatever
the name you choose. And then in order to
set up exact match, you just need this exact
prop is an easy now we're familiar with react
router basics, of course, let's make things
a bit interesting. And talk about the error
page, as well as why would want to use a switch
component as well. As far as the error page.
Well, if we go right now to the URL, and if
I go with forward slash, and then Hello, what
do you think is going to happen? I have three
pages of home about and I have people however
in the URL? Well, I'm navigating to a Hello.
With our current setup, the only thing we're
displaying is a empty page, it will be a better
experience. If at least we would tell the
user to Hey, listen, such a page doesn't exist.
And then he or she can navigate to some different
bridge, most likely the home bridge. And of
course, the answer is that yes, that would
be a better setup, the first thing we would
need to do is go with error page. Of course,
that is going to be our component. But as
far as setting up the route, it's going to
be a little bit different, where we go with
a route component. And then for the path,
we go here with the star. So instead of setting
up for slash error, or not found we just go
here with a star. Now it started means that
it will always always match. And of course
in here, our one on display the error component.
And now you'll see that I have my garbage.
And technically everything works nice. Now
I have my Hello, we haven't covered links
yet. So don't worry, eventually, we will add
here a link that allows us to navigate to
a different page. But at least it's a good
start. Once we navigate to a page that doesn't
exist, whether that is a Hello or shake and
bake. And of course we have the error page.
Now, the problem here is going to be a bit
different. Where once I navigate to a home
bridge, I can see the error page. Once I navigate
to a bulk page, I'll also be able to see the
error page. Why? Because this one always matters.
This is where the switch component comes into
play,
where we'll go with a router. And then we'll
have our switch component. And we'll put all
our routes in the switch component. And with
a switch component, only the first one that
matches is displayed. So that way, if I go
to homepage, then I can only see the home
page. If I go to your about page, of course
on the about page. But if all nicely go to
a Hello. Since this one always matches, we
have the error page. That's how we can set
up error page with paste which component in
react router. Nicely done, I think we're making
a good progress. So now let's talk about dealing.
Because even though we could technically leave
it the way it is, where a user needs to navigate
using the URL bar, you would have to agree
that probably that is not the best user experience.
And for that, of course, we would create a
navbar. Now I already created the component.
So the only thing we need to do is place it
inside the router. Now again, please don't
place it within a search insider or show right
above this, which we're going to grow here
with a navbar the moment the only thing we
have here is some kind of text. Now of course,
let's navigate to our navbar component. And
this is where I would want to set up a ordered
list. So I'm going to go here with our list
and list item and then instead of going for
traditional link Like we have been doing already
in the HTML. In this case, you need to import
a link from react router DOM. And, again,
there's a specific prop. And that is to show
you go here with link to prop. And this is
where you specifically say, well, where I
would want to navigate. In this course, I'm
going to go with a home page. So of course,
the only thing I do is match whatever was
my setup in the index. So for the home, I
had a Ford slash. So of course, if I would
want to navigate back your home bridge, well,
I will just use to prop and then forward slash.
And here I say home. Now, I would want to
make two more items. And I'm looking for about
10 people. So first, let's just change this
text around. And we'll say people, and also
we, of course, need to change the URL. So
if for about my URL was forward slash about,
and of course, make sure that it matches.
Otherwise, you will navigate to a error page,
not the end of the world, but probably also
not something that you're looking for. So
let's save it. And there it is. Now I have
my lunch. So instead of using the URL bar,
now, what I can do is just say, hey, show
me the people page. And as you can see, like
I said before, now we're just displaying the
people component, then we go to about, and
then we go to home. And we can already put
two and two together. If this only component
allows us to navigate to a different page,
not only I can use the nav bar, I can also
use it in the error correct. So navigate to
notice here, how I have imported already a
link component, just keep in mind that that
is a named import. So make sure you add the
curly braces. And the only thing that is missing
here is link to then we go for example to
our home page. Again, you can navigate to
whichever page you'd want. I'm just going
to a homepage, and just a little bit of CSS,
I'm going to go with class name. And we're
going to go with btn. Let's just say back
home, back,
home. And now try it out where not only Of
course, I can navigate around with my navbar.
But I can also do here where I say forward
slash and then shake, and bake. And now I
have the error page. Now in this case, if
I want to navigate back to the home bridge,
either I can use the nav bar, which is still
there. And by the way, this is somewhat important.
We'll notice this nav bar will be added to
every page. So these are my routes. This is
where we are setting up everything with a
search component. But navbar will be added
to every page. So that will be displayed on
every page, regardless which page it is starting
with home all the way to error. So if I want
of course, I can navigate back using the number
or can if we go to a Hello, the page that
doesn't exist. I also have a nice line that
says back home. I click it. And of course,
I'm back home. We're almost done with our
basic react router setup. But before we move
on to a different topic, I also would want
to cover how we can deal with alerts. So in
this case, notice I have the list of people,
which is of course coming from my data correct.
If we navigate to a people component, like
I said, I import data, the file the data that
we have been using. For our tutorial, I set
up this use state hook where I have people
and some people and I'm here are just iterate
over my list and then display the name of
the person. But now what I would want is to
set up some kind of placeholder where we can
imagine that this could be a list of blog
post, or list of products or whatever, some
kind of list of items. And then once we click
on one specific item, we go to that placeholder
page that just grabs the item that you clicked
on, and then displays it. So essentially,
I don't have to create four different pages
for each and every item in the list or 20
different pages, depending on how big is the
list. In this case, I can just create one
placeholder. And then regardless whether I
have 4000 items or four items, the moment
I'll open up that placeholder I'll grab that
specific ID, or some kind of data that is
specific to that item, and then display only
that one item. And if you're a little bit
iffy off what I'm trying to make, well just
hang with me. And we'll be in good shape.
So I have my list of items correct. I display
them, of course, by iterating, over my list.
But what I would want is to set up that placeholder.
And we can do that if we navigate to index
j, s, and I already have this person component.
So if you navigate to a person component,
you'll just see that we have a person component.
And it has a text of person, just like the
other components that we used for pages. Now
though, I would want to set up different things
in index js, where versus my person component,
I'm going to go right above the error, where
we set up the route. So that will still say
the same, where we go with route, or the values
are going to be a bit different. Because in
this case, I want to go with path.
Instead of just word slash, we also have something
called URL parameters. So the first part,
the beginning part can be up to you, you can
either go with forward slash, and then you
can set up the Euro parameters. And by the
way, those are going to be in react router,
the colon, and Lan, whatever name you would
want. So in this case, you can go with ID,
you can go with name, it's up to you. Again,
this is just going to show up once we start
accessing that value. So naming is up to you
Just remember that name because you will have
to use it. So in this case, I'm going to go
with it. But remember, I said the beginning
part is up to you. If you want you can right
person, forward slash and then of course,
colon an ID, if you don't, you can simply
write forward slash, and colon and then ID.
So this beginning path, you can make as long
or as short as you want. And then in here,
we do a little bit differently, where we don't
play that component inside, we go with children.
And we set up well which component we would
want to display. So this person component
will be our placeholder for each and every
time we will navigate to a person, and then
some kind of ID, we will display this person
component, now the difference is going to
be in that person component, we will grab
that ID and fetch that data. So in our case,
that is going to be that one specific person,
hopefully that is clear, we have our placeholder,
we use our URL parameters. In this case, I
named this ID, but you'll see in a second,
that name is definitely your choice. And now
what I would want is navigate back to a people
show let me find my people array. And in here,
right next to the hiring poor,
I would want to set up a link. Okay, so I
have imported the link component and also
here hiring for. And now of course, I have
my own component. Now the difference and now
is going to be that, check it out. we're iterating
over the list correct. And I have each and
every ID available for the person, we already
know that that's how our data is structured.
So now when we set up to, we need to set it
up dynamically. Now what do I mean by that
we set up curly braces, and then we go with
a template string, where I say that I'm going
to be navigating to a person. So the only
reason why I'm adding this first part is because
in the index, I also added this person, if
you don't have it if you just have the forest
slash, and of course, don't add markers added
add the person. So that's why I need to make
sure that they both match, then I have another
forward slash. And this is where I place that
ID. So I know that in the data object, I have
that ID. So the only thing I need to do is
go with person, and then ID and what you'll
notice that the moment you click on any of
the links that we're about to display, they
will all open the same page, that person bridge,
the difference is going to be in the URL where
the IDS will change. So within the link, we
can just write whatever we want. So in this
case, I'm going to say learn more And once
we save, notice, these are my links. And like
I said, Every time you click on them, we're
still opening the person page. So we're still
navigating to the person ID. And then of course,
since in the children, the value was personal
component, that is what we're displaying,
the difference is going to be the URL, because
notice now we have person and then one. So
if we navigate to the third one, we have person
and forward slash three. And hopefully you
get the gist. So now, of course, the question
is, well, how I can access that value, because
the idea in the person is somewhat simple,
where in the person, I would want to grab
that value. And then in my case, I'm just
gonna look for that specific person in my
data array. Now, again, this is oversimplified
example. Normally, the way it works is you
have a list of blog posts have a list of products,
and then you already fetch them from the API.
But then if you'd want to have a more specific
info, then of course, you fetch it one more
time. So you set up the link, where you navigate
your placeholder page, and you pass that ID.
And then in that placeholder, this is where,
again, you set up another fridge. Now, in
our case, since data, of course, is local,
I don't have to do that. So I purposely didn't
want to overcomplicate things, but just understand
that this is over simplified example. In order
to access that, we need to use use params
hook from react router now. So again, this
is coming from react router DOM, where they
provide this hook that allows us to access
the parameters. Now, just to showcase that
we can name our URL parameters, however we
want, I can go with log, and then we go with
use params. And then let me invoke it. And
what you'll notice, the moment I navigate,
for example, john,
I'll see of course, my placeholder, my person.
And then in here, I have the object. So in
the object, I have the ID property, and the
value is equal to a one. Now one gotcha, though,
is that list will always be a string. And
if you remember our data, it was a number.
Correct. So that sometimes might trip you
up, where some API's have their ID, strength,
and some of them as a number. So for example,
if their strength, no big deal, once you pass
it through the React router, you'll be still
in good shape. But if there are numbers, then
of course, you'll have to keep on watching.
Because in the following few minutes, we'll
fix this issue where this is a string, that
is very, very important. However, keep in
mind, this name is an ID. So what that means
is when I was setting up my index, and when
I say person, and then the name of my euro
primer was ID, if I change this around to
a orange, you'll notice that the value doesn't
change, it's still going to be one. So we're
still within the people, we can navigate around,
because we just pass in the value. However,
the name, of course, is the orange. So this
is where I'm trying to make a case that course
naming is, in most cases, up to you. So I
have ID on showcasing these placeholder. So
now I would just want to have a simple setup,
where I'm going to display well, which person
is actually the one that I have clicked on
in people, because for now, I'm just displaying
the person, correct. And the way I would do
that is navigating to person j s. And I would
just want to get that value. And since I'm
getting back the object from use params hook,
I can simply say that it is going to be an
ID. And I'll say use params sorry, not use
if I say use prompts. So that should give
me my ID. I know that I'm getting back the
object and I'm just destructuring the object.
But I also want to set up some kind of state
value. So say const, Morgan for name, and
then set name. And that is equal to use state.
And for now I'll just say default name. And
we're have the heading to our changes this
around Pentagon. And I'll say yeah, you know
what, I would want to display the name. I
also would want to add a link just so we can
navigate back to the people page. So let's
say here link. And as you can see, of course,
I have already imported. So we go here with
a link on to. And in this case, I'm just going
to say, let's navigate back to people. I'll
also add a class name here, because I would
want to add a little bit of CSS online. As
far as like value, I'll say back to people.
Beautiful. So once I save, when I click on
Peter, I should have default name and back
to people. But the good news is that I
have my
ID, here, we could set up the user, where
we could filter out, well, which person actually
clicked on. And then of course, just change
the name. So that way, we can always be sure
whether it's Peter, or john. So we're gonna
go with use effect. So essentially, once the
component around nurse, then we want to call
our callback function. All set up empty array
of servers, no dependencies in here. So just
on the initial render, node want to get that
person. So I'm going to go const, and I'll
call this new person, and that is equal to
a data. And now I'm just gonna use the find
method. Now, the gotcha here is that, of course,
I would want to parse the string, because
keep in mind that this is a string in my data,
this is going to be an ID. So if you'll simply
say, like, so where you have the person ID
matches the ID, this is not going to get you
any person. Why? Well, because of this one
is a number. And this one is a string. So
what you need to do is go with parse, int,
and then you wrap the ID inside there. And
of course, we need to be closing parentheses.
So now I have my new person. And I can go
with setname. And we're gonna go with new
person, and then dot name. So now what will
happen, I have the peer. So if I navigate
back to people, and I click on Susan, Now,
of course, the value will be Susan. So that's
how we can deal with less set up the placeholder.
And then each and every time we click on some
item, instead of creating a brand new page,
we use the same page. But there is already
some kind of setup, where I can get that unique
value about that product or blog post, or
whatever. And then we can fetch it. This display
that specific item in the placeholder, here,
we create only one component, only one page
that could be used by 4000 items, or four
items, like it is in our case. Excellent work.
And next we have performance optimization.
More specifically, we're going to cover react,
memo function, use callback, hook, and then
use memo hook as well. Now, before we go any
further, let me just be very, very clear,
where I purposely added this topic to be our
last one. Why? Because react is fast by default.
Again, let me repeat, React is fast by default.
And what I mean by that is just because you
have these tools to optimize the performance
of your app doesn't mean that you need to
run over to your to do list app, and start
optimizing. That's not how it works. Now,
I did include it. And by the way, I was debating
back and forth. I almost skipped it. But I
did include it in tutorial because I want
you to be aware of these functions and hooks
and how they work. But it doesn't mean that
you need to use them in your apps. Yes, there
are some specific use cases where they are
useful. But trust me when I say this, just
because Twitter guru says that you need to
apply these optimizations, you have to do
it. No. React is fast by default. And when
it comes to optimizations, they do add their
own costs. So it's not like it's a free ride,
where we just add these magic functions and
everything works like beaches. They do use
the memory, they do use the competition power,
they'll be mindful
when you actually use them. During the videos,
I will mention term memorizing. And that is
not my term that is not react term. That is
a computer science term, which just means
that we're caching results, and I'll simplify
it even more during videos where I'll say
remember Remember, we're remembering the value.
Just keep in mind what the official naming
is because of course, remembering is something
that I added, because I thought that we should
simplify this memorizing term. And then lastly,
if you don't trust me, if you think that everything
that I'm saying is gibberish, and that you
should use all of these functions, I would
suggest going to your favorite search engine,
and just type use callback will use memo on
type again, and you should get the article
by Kent Dodds, where essentially he talks
about when you should use memo on use callback.
And there's not much to add there, he just
lays out step by step, why you shouldn't go
crazy with use memo. Use callback org. So
that's what we're going to cover next, there's
going to be of course, an example. Now, I
created that example with this specific purpose.
Again, it's not normally where you would use
these optimizations. But since I wanted you
to have an idea of how they work and where
you can use them. That's why I created so
we get a good practice on the React memo,
as well as use callback and use memo hooks.
And once I've shared my two cents, about the
performance optimizations in react, of course,
let's go to our example. And we're looking
forward to folder number 12. I named my component
against setup, and you're looking in the memory
use memorials callback folder, and then more
specifically, the setup folder. Again, it's
gonna have the index, so you don't need to
give it more specific path. And what you should
see on the screen is the count. So of course,
I can increase the count, as well as I have
some products are here. So now of course,
let's navigate to that index. And let's see
what all the big fuss is about. And you can
see that I have some reports, I have you state
use callback, use memo, something we'll use
in later videos. And also, I'm using my custom
fetch. So use fetch hook, where I pass in
the URL. In this case, again, the URL is my
own API,
where I'm just sharing my product. So that
is for my JavaScript course, we built a ecommerce
store. And this is the API that is providing
those products are getting back the product.
Notice again, I'm not using loading, that
I have the count and set count. So this is
my state variable. Notice I have the heading
one for my account. And of course, I have
the button that increases the comp. And then
of course, things get a bit more interesting,
where I have my big list. So again, this is
oversimplified example, we're talking about
the big list, whether that is 100 items, 1000
items, or something along those lines, because
if you check it out, my list is not a big
sort of big list, then the problem is product,
and I pass in the product that I'm getting
back from my customer. And again, if you didn't
cover custom hook, please go back because
I'm not going to cover it one more time. I'm
not on here, I have the section, I iterate
over the product. And I created a single component,
sure single component for the product. Just
to emphasize one of the points online Of course,
I have the key matters, that specific value,
the unique one, because I have a list, and
then that product. So I use the spread operator,
where I grab all the properties of that are
on a product. Of course, if you'd want to
see what we're getting back, be my guest.
In this case, I'll copy and paste. And you'll
notice that of course, I have the array. And
then each and every item is that product,
I have the ID. I have the image and all that
good stuff. Now that is not the most important
part though. Because yes, in single product,
notice, I'm maxing the fields property on
the object, then I do a little bit more destructuring
are give the image and this should look very
familiar because we have done 1000 times already
in this tutorial. The point that I'm trying
to make is something else. We're at the moment
I have the list I have click me. And you'll
notice that if you add user for me single
product, as well as the big list each and
every time you click on a button, you're actually
re rendering. Let me show you how is that
gonna work. Sorry, imported, the use effect,
by the way, didn't My apologies, let's go
with use effect now again in your case is
going to be already there. And if we scroll
down here, and if we go with big list, and
if you go with use effect, and then you call
it. And we'll just log a big list called Big
list called. And I'll do the same thing over
here, where I'll copy and paste. And you can
also add the array here, the empty dependency
array, it's not going to change the simple
fact that every time you click on a button,
you will invoke both of them. So again, I
have used the fact and now say, single item
called, by the way, I can add here a count
as well. So if I navigate to a bigger browser
window, or refresh, notice, so once we call
our component, yeah, I have item called that
and called on, it goes all the way up to a
24. Now, what's more important though, is
if you check out the console, I keep on clicking,
notice these values, they keep on increasing.
So I have 12 items, and then pretty much each
and every time I click on a button, I see
this big list called and also each and every
item gets rerender. Now, first of all, why
is that happening? Because I have the state
value using use state. And then each and every
time I click the button, what am I doing?
Well, I changed the value correct. And remember,
your state was doing what it was preserving
the values between the renders, and it was
triggering the let's say it all together rerender
correct. Course, in my component in the index
one, I have my big list. So each and every
time I click on a button, I update my count
value. I'm triggering the rerender. And then
of course, I'm re rendering the big list.
And then in the big list, I have my single
product. More specifically, I'm iterating
over the array, and I returned for each and
every item, my single product. So those ones
also get rerender.
So what would be the solution? Well, solution
is the memo function that comes with react
again, please don't confuse it with use memo,
use, my more is gonna do something else that
is a hook, we're talking about function by
the name of memo. If you want to be really
specific, then of course, it is a method because
it is on react. And what we would need to
do here is just go with react, and othmar.
Or you can import it. You can also do that
up here where we're importing everything.
And what you would want is to wrap your essentially
whole component in that memo. So memoir is
a function, and you just pass in your component.
So simply your set of parentheses, and then
you set up all the logic that you had for
the component in that memo. All right. So
once we save, we will notice that yes, on
the initial render, notice, we have 12. So
we call this 12 times because we have 12 items,
then each and every time I increase, notice
how we're not calling that usually Why? Well,
because memo is checking it is memorizing
Well, what is the value? Sure, if this props
value did not change, then we're not triggering
the rerender. Because we need to remember
that every time the props or the state changes,
component re renders. So in this case, what's
happening is that we're triggering that rerender
with account, correct, because each and every
time we change the state value we triggering
the rerender. Now when we have this react
memo, what we do is we check, we say hey,
listen, did the value for my props change,
or it's exactly the same? And of course, the
answer is, as you're clicking on a button,
the value for the product is exactly the same.
But then react is like okay, sure, now I don't
need to re render my component. So if we don't
rerender the big list of course, as a result,
we also don't rerender the single product.
So our is the memo function in react. Not
bad. Not bad. We've got Got a react memo method
out of the way. Now, let me throw you a mind
read. What if I were to create a state value.
And I'll call this card on not the actual
item in the card, but will somewhat simulate
that action. Wherever we go with karten and
sipcot course we use use state, our awesome
Hawk, we provide the initial value, which
is going to be zero, then we'll also set up
Add To Cart function. So we're going to go
here with cost, and then add to cart Mark
show for time being is just going to be an
arrow function that does one very simple thing,
it sets the cart to the previous value plus
one, so cart, and then plus one. So that's
my Add To Cart function. The thing is, though,
that now I would want to pass that function
down to my item. So first, right after the
button, I'm going to create a new one. And
I'll add a little bit of inline styling here,
I'll say margin top is equal to three REM,
I think a lot is a good value. And then in
here, let's say cart is equal to my cart value.
Let's save it, it should be zero, because
that is my default one. But then, like I said,
I would want to pass this sucker down to a
single product. Yes, granted, we'll do some
prop drilling. But I think we can live with
that, because there's something else that
I'd want to show you. So where I have the
big list, now, let's go with the prop of Add
To Cart. And then of course, our Add To Cart
function, add to cart prop is equal to my
Add To Cart function. Well, of course, we
need to destructure it, we already know that.
And then we need to pass it into that single
component, correct. The single product component
of the cart again, add to cart over here.
And then finally, we're good down to the single
product. And then in the single product out
want to add a button that of course cause
it. So right after the paragraph, I'm going
to go with button, add on collect, and we'll
pass in our Add To Cart. So we're
not going to add that item literally to the
card. But we'll simulate that action. So add
to cart. And again, there's going to be a
issue. issue is going to be simply because
we click to add to cart and notice, again,
we're calling that single item. So every time
I click on this button, again, I'm re rendering
all the items. Okay. Now, why is that happening?
Well, if we scroll up, we see that we have
this big list. Now in this case, we have the
product that we technically took care of with
a memo. Okay, but then we have Add To Cart
function. So again, this is our prop. And
I told you in the last video that every time
props, or state changes, component will rerender.
Now the thing is, when we change the state
value, we trigger the rerender. And each and
every time we create this function from the
scratch. So that's why react things that hey,
listen, this value changed, because it was
recreated from scratch. And that's why again,
we're triggering the rerender. Now what is
the solution, the solution is using use callback,
which essentially somewhat similar like we
were doing with a memo, but now it's going
to do with a function where it's going to
check Hey, listen, has the value for the function
changed. If it hasn't changed, good, I don't
need to recreate the function from the scratch.
If the value has changed, well, then of course,
I would need to create that function one more
time. So what we do is called use callback
hook. And then we would want to pass in that
function. So here again, we wrap our function
in the parenthesis, that's step number one.
But also what I would want is to add the dependency
array. And that is very important because
what I would want is each and every time I
update the cart value, I also create this
function, and I'll show you what happens if
you don't do that. But the good news is now
that if I'm Just working with a count, I'm
not going to trigger that rerender. Because
what you'll notice that once you click the
count, check it out, see, the items are still
just 12. So I don't rerender each and every
time I click on a comp, because with our previous
setup, so without this use callback, by the
way, I didn't show you that. So my apologies,
let me delete it. And I'll recreate it from
scratch here, where now the problem is that,
as I'm clicking on account, all the items
still get rerender. Because again, this function
gets created from the scratch. And then react
thinks, hey, listen, the props change, so
I need to trigger the rerender. That's why
we use this use callback. So now we create
this function only when we update the cart
value. So just like we had dependency array
with use effect, we have the same thing with
our use callback. And that is a very important
because you might be tempted to do something
like this, where you go with, okay, I have
my count, I have the card, so I only want
to create a function, when I have the initial
render. Now the problem is going to be, you're
not going to get that second value. Because
if you go and if you console log the card,
it is always going to be zero. So if I go
here, if I click on the add to cart, now as
the cart is going to be zero. And then even
though my value got updated in the state,
since I didn't create this function, when
the cart value changed, well, it's always
going to be sitting on a zero. So here, you
can keep on clicking. And notice, it's always
going to be one because I didn't create that
function one more time when this value changed.
So that's why you have dependency array. That's
why you add whichever value you'd want to
use to recreate the function which of course,
in our case is the cart show. Once this value
changes, we would want to create a function
one more time. Now of course, in that case,
we will trigger the rear Enders Where is normal,
that is not unexpected. But at least in this
case, notice how I can keep on clicking the
count. And I'm not triggering the rerender.
Also, as a side note, if you check out the
console, you should see here the warning,
where we have react hook use effect has a
missing dependency, we get product analysis
coming from our customers. And this is another
use case where we can use the use callback.
So just wait a little bit. In the next video,
we'll cover use memo. And we'll circle back.
And we'll take a look at how we can use this
use callback to get rid of this warning in
the console much later. On. Next we have use
memo hook, which unlike the use callback,
which memorizes or remembers the function
show if the cart value didn't change. That
means we don't need to recreate function from
scratch. The use memo deals with a value.
So like I said, Please don't mix and match
the two, where react memo will essentially
be looking for the prompts. and see whether
the prompts change, or do you use memo is
specifically for the value. Now in order to
set up our example, I'm going to create a
function first that returns some kind of value.
Certain here also cow who late again, I'm
somewhat of the fan of explicit name for my
functions. So expensive. Brand serve here.
And I'll pass in there. And what I'm trying
to do with this function is just calculate
the most expensive value as far as my product.
And the way we set up the logic. I'm just
going to return from this function, a value
using the reduce function. So I'm going to
go with data, whatever I'm passing in, and
I can tell you right away that I will be passing
the product, then I'll use the reduce function.
And again, it's not really important what
I'm doing over here, in this calculate most
expensive one, but since I would want to make
it a little bit more realistic, I will actually
calculate the values from my items. Keep in
mind that you can return for this example
some kind of random value, and it's going
to work exactly the same. I'm showing here,
I'm iterating over my products. And then I
know that the price is sitting in fields and
price. And again, if you want to double check
that you can see it over here, I have my array,
I have my object that of course represents
that one specific product. And then I have
this value for price. So that's what I'm looking
for, where I would want to reduce it down
to that one single value, which is the biggest
one. So that's why I'll say that I'll be returning
a number and I'll divided right away by 100.
Because the price is incense, and then I'm
just going to say that there is a price variable
amount is equal to item fields. Right, so
that is the property here. And we know that
with reduced, we always need to return the
total correct. That is my first parameter.
And I'll just say that if the price so that
variable is bigger than the current total
one, well, then the total essentially will
be equal to that branch. So I'm simply checking
for the highest value of the price, whatever
it is. And then once I have my function, what
I would want in my return, right above the
big list, but below the cart, I'm gonna have
another heading one on in here, I'll say most
expensive. Math is equal, again, to $1 sign,
I guess, I will make more sense, I'm going
to go with most, or you know what, sorry,
the function name was calculate most expensive.
And then I would want to pass in my product.
What do we need to keep in mind that we talk
about some functions that take a long time
to calculate. So the function returns a value.
But let's imagine that it takes a long time
to calculate this value. And if I log on be
able to see that every time I click for example,
on account, I'm calling this Hello. And imagine
that if this function takes a long time
to get that value, it's somewhat of a pain.
Because I'm calling this every time I'm updating
the state value. So it would be nice if I
would somehow be able to remember that value,
and only recalculate it or essentially run
it one more time to function if my data changes.
So in my case, of course, that is the product
correct, because that's what we're passing
in. And this is where use memo comes into
play, where we go with const, I need to come
up with some kind of variable in this case.
So I will just rename it to most expensive
over here that I call use my mouse. So that's
my hook. And where we need to pass into use
memo is a callback function. And the first
thing we need to set up is the function that
returns a value, which in our case, of course,
is calculate, most expensive van, we invoke
it like so. And the second thing is the dependency
array. And again, in this case, I'm passing
in the raw duct. And then of course, I need
to change from calculate most expensive shoe
most expensive, and I can remove those products
right now. So what you'll notice that it is
still the same value. So we still call this
function, but then every time we click on
account, what we don't see the Hello. Alright,
so that means of course, we're not calling
this function, we remember the value using
the use memo. And not only were the products
change, essentially the data that we're passing
in, only then we run the function one more
time and recalculate the value. So that is
react memo, use callback, as well as use memo
hook in react. And the last thing that I want
to showcase just like I promised, there's
another use case for use callback. That is
essentially when we're fetching data. An awesome
example is over here, if we check the terminal,
we can see that I have this warning where
react use effect has a missing dependency,
get product year included or removed from
the pregnancy right. And of course that is
in my custom, the US furniture. So let's say
we'll navigate over there. We have our customer
And then we have our use fetch, I can see
that react is complaining that hey, listen,
you have get product function over here. So
you need to add it as dependency. But before
you jump over there and add it as dependency,
let me warn you, you will create infinite
loop. Why? Well, let's see, we have Get Products.
Correct. And what is this good products doing?
Well, it is calling ship products. So it sets
the stage value, which triggers the rerender.
So if I'll go here, and if I'll say get product
is my dependency, the first time I'll call
the get product, I'll change that value. And
then since this needs to rerun every time,
of course, when we change something about
this value, well, since get product, once
we added there, since it will get created
from the scratch, once we rerender. That's
why we'll create a infinite loop. Because
again, the same scenario like we had over
here with index, where we had the add to cart
each and every time you rerender. You create
a function from scratch. So if this gets added
to dependency array, technically each and
every time when it gets created from scratch,
well, you will rerender the component. Now
in a function, though, you also change the
state value. So you have that infinite loop.
What is the solution? Well, remember, we have
our use callback, right? So we can go here
with use callback. And then I can set it equal.
I can say use callback over here, one show.
So let me wrap everything. And now I just
need to say, well, one, I would want to create
a function. Of course, the answer is when
I have a URL change,
for once the URL changes. Yeah, please recreate
a VAT function from the scratch. And of course,
once we have this setup, I can bravely grow
to use effect and just add Mark get product.
Again, let me re emphasize the point where
previously, before we added this huge callback,
if we simply would add theirs and get product,
we would get a infinite loop. Why? Because
this would get created each and every time.
Now we only create a new function, launch
the URL changes. And of course, as a result,
we're not getting this infinite loop. So that
would be another use case for use callback
call.